...
Du arme, arme Kirchenmaus. Ja. Nicht nur kein Geld, sondern oder mehr Geld,
sondern auch kein Mechanismus, Gott gegeben, der es einfach über dich ergießt.
Das heißt, es gibt eine Inflation, es gibt einen allgemeinen Lohnanstieg.
Weniger Geld wird sich beschweren jetzt.
Und dann würde ich einfach auch davon profitieren, würde mehr bekommen.
Dann müsste ich vielleicht Bundestagsabgeordneter werden.
Zum Beispiel, Nico Simmsroth dreht ja gerade eine große Runde und steht auf
der Bühne und geht dann so die Privilegien der Parlamentarier,
vor allem in der EU, durch und beschließt damit der Pointe, sieht das nicht aus wie Sozialismus?
Und das Publikum so, ja stimmt, irgendwie sieht es aus nach Sozialismus.
Jedenfalls, wir hatten es ja im kurzen Teaser für das Buch, das wir demnächst
lesen, schon angesprochen. Es gab eine Diätenerhöhung.
Und zwar automatisiert.
6% mehr Lohnniveau heißt 6% mehr Geld.
In dem Falle, Spiegeltitel, Rekorderhöhung der Diäten, denn 11.227 Euro,
mehr als 600 Euro mehr, bedeutet das größte Plus seit fast 30 Jahren.
Also im Grunde eine Wiedervereinigungserfolgsgeschichte, mehr Geld,
während ich sagen würde, wir laufen gerade alle durch diese Landschaft und stellen fest,
Ich brauche nicht nur Essen für mich, sondern vielleicht auch für das eine oder andere Kind.
Ich gehe in einen Einkaufsladen, wo mir nichts zubereitet wird.
Ich muss es alleine nach Hause tragen und es ist trotzdem gefühlt teurer,
als wenn ich vor fünf Jahren ins Restaurant einfach gegangen wäre.
Also ich weiß nicht genau, die Leute verdienen ja wirklich nicht viel in Deutschland.
Ja.
Und trotzdem kostet ein Einkauf mittlerweile so immer einfach standardmäßig erstmal 65 Euro.
So ein halber Rucksack voll Essen irgendwie 65 Euro. Also ist alles schräg.
Gut, der Automatismus nach oben, also wenn man als Bundestagsabgeordneter einkaufen
geht und sagt, oh, das ist aber teuer geworden, dann gibt es einen Automatismus,
dann brauche ich auch mehr Geld. Und dann kommt das einfach.
So, es ist so geregelt, es gab 2014 eine Kommission, die hat gesagt,
Bundestagsabgeordnete sollen auf der Besoldungshöhe der Richter an den obersten
Gerichtshöfen verdienen.
Und dann jährlich nach Nominallohnindex eine Steigerung erhalten,
die das Statistische Bundesamt ausweist und dann wird ohne Streik,
ohne Streit, ohne Konflikt, ohne Aussprache im Bundestag einfach gesagt 6% mehr.
So und ich habe jetzt Claude, meine neue Lieblings-KI, weil GPT,
wir distanzieren uns ein bisschen,
wir reden heute gar nicht darüber eigentlich, vielleicht sehr wenig.
Machen wir dann noch im Laufe des Monats, wir sind ja noch auf der Bühne dann im nächsten Monat.
Ich habe dann mal Claude, meine neue Lieblings-KI von Anthropic gefragt,
gibt es eine Regelung zur Höhe der Mindestlöhne, die sich beispielsweise an
Median- oder Durchschnittslöhnen orientiert, so wie also die Diätenerhöhung
am Nominal-Lohn-Index orientiert ist? Und die Antwort ist ja.
Und zwar auf europäischer Ebene.
Auf allen Ebenen. Also das Mindestlohngesetz sieht vor, dass nach Paragraph 9 Absatz 2 Milo-G,
also Mindestlohngesetz, eine Mindestlohnkommission prüft und dann eine Gesamtabwägung
macht im volkswirtschaftlichen Rahmen, den man so vorfindet.
Aber das wird im Verlauf des Textes auch für alle verständlich zusammengebunden
auf die Formulierung nachlaufend an der Tariflohnentwicklung.
Also genau wie bei den Bundestagsabgeordneten. Man hat also grundsätzlich,
sagt Claude, eine Orientierung an der allgemeinen Lohnentwicklung.
Da habe ich Claude gefragt, Frage, gibt es das auch in der EU als Regelung? Ja, durchaus.
EU-Richtlinie 2022, Schrägstrich, also die ist von 2022 und dann 2041,
Schriftsatz also relativ spät im Jahr, 19. Oktober.
Solche Sachen haben wir immer so eine zwei Jahre, wir gewöhnen uns alle mal
dran, also die laufen Wir laufen jetzt auch ab Oktober 24.
Da steht wortwörtlich drin, die Mitgliedstaaten mit gesetzlichen Mindestlöhnen,
also Deutschland zum Beispiel, ergreifen die erforderlichen Maßnahmen,
um sicherzustellen, das und so weiter.
Und dann wird aufgedröselt, A, Kaufkraft ist hier relevant, B,
das allgemeine Niveau der Bruttolöhne und ihre Verteilung, C,
die Wachstumsrate der Bruttolöhne, D, Arbeitsproduktivität.
Also da kommt ganz schön viel rein, da läuft ganz schön viel Wissen rein.
Ich habe dann auch Claude direkt gefragt, wie sähe denn so eine Rechnung aus,
wenn wir das jetzt einfach mal durchgehen und stellt sich raus,
ja, also man kann das selbst von Claude,
wo es ja immer heißt, man kann nicht gut rechnen oder so, doch da ist so ein
Taschenrechner angebunden und man könnte den ganzen politischen Diskurs einfach
mal kurz mit einem Einzeiler prompt bei Claude durchrechnen lassen,
um eine Gesprächsgrundlage zu haben.
Für eine Talkshow, also bedeutet hier zum Beispiel Claude auf die 60% Brutto-Median-Einkommen
43.750 Euro im Monat, 12 Monate,
3.645 Euro, 83 Euro Median-Monatseinkommen, davon 60%, 2.187 runtergebrochen
auf 4,33 Wochen, 40 Stunden, bedeutet 12,62 Euro.
Ist jetzt eine rein mathematische Rechnung.
Wenn man das dann anpasst an diese ganzen politischen Überlegungen,
die man da so hat, ist man relativ zügig bei diesen 14 oder 15 Euro.
Die ja gerade im Raume stehen. Warum stehen sie im Raume? Scholz hat einen Mindestlohn Vorschlag gemacht.
Er hat dem Stern gesagt, ich bin klar dafür, den Mindestlohn erst auf 14 Euro,
dann im nächsten Schritt auf 15 Euro anzuheben.
Und mein Anlauf bis zu diesem Punkt ist, ja, Ja, der Kanzler hat es gesagt,
der Kanzler ist ein Politiker. Wenn ein Politiker spricht, ist es politische Kommunikation.
Aber da gibt es eine Kalkulation dahinter. Sein Gehalt, das Gehalt aller.
Es gibt Gesetze, EU, national.
Eigentlich ist das ein Argument, das zwangsläufig ist.
Und Kevin Kühnert ist aber gleich vor die Kameras getreten und hat gesagt,
nein, so geht das nicht, das müssen wir der Mindestlohnkommission überlassen.
Also der vermeintliche sozialistische Kevin Kühnert Kühnert ist also der,
der jetzt den Kanzler zurückpfeift, dass bitte nicht die Forderungen zu links sind.
Also wenn man mal beobachten will, wie sehr man sich anpassen kann in kürzester Zeit, dann bei Kühnert.
Wir kommen heute noch ein bisschen auf Kühnert.
Achso, okay.
Irgendwer muss ja verteidigen, dass Guy Witt sagt, wir sind doch kein Lenny-Staat,
wenn die Leute die Miete nicht bezahlen können, kann der nicht der Staat jetzt plötzlich eingreifen.
Also überall taucht dieser Kevin Kühnert auf. Ich will mal ein Beispiel,
wo es härter formuliert ist, spielen.
Gitta Connemann, wir kennen sie von der CDU, sie steht gerne mal als Ballwerk
rum oder als, falls der nächste Kanzler kommt.
Und der ist von BlackRock entsandt, dann ist das die neue Sozialministerin oder wie auch immer.
Gitta Connemann von der CDU redet jetzt über diesen Umstand,
dass der Politiker Olaf Scholz als Bundeskanzler publizistisch auftritt und
sagt 15 Euro, weil Hintergrundrauschen der Gesetze und so.
Und wir dann sagen, nee, das muss erst von der Kommission zerredet werden wieder.
Wir können nicht einfach die Mathematik gewähren gelassen. Bei Gitta Connemann klingt das so.
Der 15%-Kanzler fordert 15 Euro Mindestlohn, aber dem Grunde nach ist es natürlich
das zweite Mal, dass er sein Wort bricht.
Er hatte 2022 gesagt, wir werden als Politik einmal in den Mindestlohn eingreifen,
danach aber nicht wieder und jetzt tut er es wieder und damit löst er auch einen
politischen Überbietungswettbewerb aus. Das ist absolut schädlich.
Ja, das ist absolut schädlich. Was man nicht hört, aber sieht,
ist, Gitta Kandermann ist natürlich Vorsitzende der Mittelstandsunion.
Das heißt, sie spricht hier nicht für den Wähler, der vielleicht demnächst Blackrock
zum Bundeskanzler wählen soll, sondern sie spricht hier für ihre Klientel.
Also diejenige, die den Mindestlohn bezahlen sollen, hat sich natürlich was dagegen.
Würde ich sagen, okay, im politischen Gefecht, wenn man das ordentlich markiert,
sollte man das darstellen, dass es da auch Arbeitgeber gibt im Gefüge.
Aber was ich dann nicht verstehe, ist zum Beispiel beim Deutschlandfunk die
Presseschau zu hören, wo es dann folgende kleine Snippets gibt.
Der Kölner Stadtanzeiger kritisiert.
Inzwischen ist klar, die Sozialdemokraten wollen den Mindestlohn grundsätzlich
politisch und nicht nach volkswirtschaftlichen Kriterien bestimmen. Ein riskantes Manöver.
Ne, die 14, 15 Euro sind ja die volkswirtschaftliche.
Ich muss auch gerade so lachen, weil ich auch jemanden kenne,
der mal beim Kölner Stadtanzeiger gearbeitet hat. Also beim Kölner Stadtanzeiger die Löhne.
Die sind jetzt, sagen wir mal so, da gehört man jetzt nicht zu den reichen Leuten in Deutschland.
Und das finde ich dann immer so
lustig, wenn diese Leute, die selber wahrscheinlich äußerste Mühe haben,
in Köln noch bezahlbaren Wohnraum zu finden, die wahrscheinlich schon in Königswinter
wohnen und dann beim Kölner Stadtanzeiger arbeiten und hoffen,
dass sie häufig Homeoffice machen können, dass diese Leute dann nochmal aufschreiben,
also jetzt bloß nicht die Löhne erhöhen.
Ja, es passt nicht zusammen. Ich finde, dass allein der Kölner Stadtanzeiger
glaubt, da nochmal einen Kommentar machen zu müssen.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie vorher eine Berichterstattung aus eigenem
Hause zu dem Thema haben, sondern wahrscheinlich nur diesen Kommentar.
In der Hinsicht ist das schon, und vor allem in dieser Eckenbrille,
dass es dann auch beim Deutschlandfunk anlandet, als dass es,
Deutschland denkt so am nächsten Morgen, wir müssen die Hörer darüber informieren.
Das ist ja wirklich schräg. Aber richtig bestürzend finde ich auch,
wie verlogen die Diskussion, sagen wir mal so, im politischen Vorfeld ist.
Micky Beisenherz hat einen Podcast, der Apokalypse und Filterkaffee heißt,
sich also um Nachrichten kümmert, aber doch mit so einem lustigen Anflug, Humor und so weiter.
Er selber hat ja jetzt eine jahrzehntelange Karriere im Privatfernsehen gemacht,
wo quasi Drehbücher für soziale Konflikte, die als Reality-TV laufen,
also Dschungelcamp usw.
Ausgetragen werden. Und dass jemand mit so viel diebischer Freude an diesem
persönlichen Kontroversen und dem Wissen, wie man sie orchestriert,
dann Lars Klingbeil als SPD-Chef im Podcast hat und ihm die Frage zum Mindestlohn
und Olaf Scholz Beitrag so stellt, finde ich wirklich,
es kommt so sanft daher, aber man müsste es wirklich mal an Grund und Boden
diskutieren, was da so als latente Sinnstruktur eigentlich mitkommt.
Und Finanzminister Lindner fordert alle Koalitionspartner und die einzelnen
Ministerien auf zu sparen.
Und in dem Moment kommt plötzlich der Bundeskanzler und sagt,
so ein Mindestlohn auf 15 Euro, das wäre doch eine feine Sache.
Während wiederum die FDP sagt, naja, die Rente mit 63, also das können wir uns
auch langsam mal sparen. Also ist das jetzt einfach nur Payback-Time?
Ist es Wahlkampf im Hinblick auf die Europawahl und die Landtagswahlen im Osten?
Ist es die pure Menschenliebe? Also was soll das jetzt? Es ist doch eh schon
alles andere als ruhig in der Koalition.
Wieso denn jetzt auch noch der Mindestlohn von 15 Euro? Ich habe da mit dem
Kanzler schon oft drüber geredet. Insofern weiß ich, dass das seine Position ist.
Er war hoch unzufrieden damit, dass die Arbeitgeberseite sich in dieser Mindestlohnkommission
so einseitig durchgesetzt hat.
Bisher war das immer total etabliert, dass man gemeinsam etwas festlegt.
Und dann haben die halt gesagt, nö, obwohl das Leben teurer geworden ist,
sollen die Menschen jetzt nicht den Mindestlohn bekommen, der eigentlich angemessen
wäre, sondern eben 12,42 Euro oder jetzt irgendwie 12,82 Euro.
Und da sind wir uns einig, Kanzler, ich und andere, das ist zu wenig.
Es ist wirklich der Wahnsinn, dass man nur noch in diesem Modus denken kann,
wie bauen wir das Dschungelcamp in diesem Jahr zusammen.
Also so redet und denkt ja Micky Beisenherz, der ja selbst einen Stundenlohn
von wahrscheinlich zweieinhalbtausend bis fünftausend Euro verlangt,
wenn der irgendwo eingeladen wird.
Nehme ich mal an.
So, das ist so etwa, also so.
Ein Monatsmindestlohn.
Genau, der bekommt den Monatsmindestlohn in einer Stunde. So,
das wird der Betrag sein, wird ja von allen hofiert und so weiter.
Und dass er jetzt nur in diesem Modus darüber nachdenken kann und nicht darüber
nachdenken kann, dass das vielleicht das Leben von.
Etwa 20% der in Deutschland Arbeitenden verbessern würde.
Und zwar substanziell. Es ist ja dieser Modus im Hintergrund,
ich bin schon da für die Leute und bin auch im besten Ansinn für sie unterwegs.
Nur, und dann, das explizit da quasi, mir ist wichtiger, dass sich die Ampel nicht streitet.
Und nicht jetzt auch noch der mit dem komischen Vorschlag um die Ecke kommt.
Wir hungern doch extra dafür, dass sich die Ampel nicht streitet.
Wieso streiten die sich trotzdem? So ungefähr, ja?
Also da liegt so der fast religiöse Überbandespielen, wer hier Opfer,
wer sich opfert für irgendwen, damit es allen gut geht.
Also der gesellschaftliche Zusammenhalt ist, wenn Christian Lindner nicht gereizt
wird jetzt mit den nächsten irren Vorschlägen. Dafür hungern wir auch gerne.
Also die anderen hungern dafür gerne eher natürlich nicht. Meine Zuhörer im
Grunde. Er spricht so stellvertretend für die Zuhörer.
Interessanterweise ist Lars Klingenbeil dann auch nicht in der Lage einfach
zu sagen, naja, man kann es einfach durchrechnen. Fragen Sie Claude,
der prompt ist, eine Zeile, Sie kriegen eine Antwort, die wird Sie zufriedenstellen.
Da ist quasi alles erklärt.
Sondern er hebt es direkt auf diese von Micky Beisenherz abgezielte persönliche,
nein, der Kanzler ist dieser Meinung und ich bin es auch und wir haben halt eine gute Meinung.
Da kann man auch anderer Meinung sein, aber unsere Meinung ist irgendwie besser
oder sowas. Also auf der Ebene.
Während der dafür zuständige Hubertus Heil ja im Bundestag steht und einfach,
wenn auch dann immer nur kurz, aber Klartext redet.
Stellen Sie sich einmal vor, wir hätten den Mindestlohn nicht erhöht auf 12 Euro.
Da haben wir als Koalition das ja gemeinsam gemacht. Das war eine Lohnerhöhung von 22 Prozent.
Die CDU hat sich heldenhaft enthalten.
Und jetzt ist auch klar, der Mindestlohn muss weiter steigen.
Und da ist die Mindestlohnkommission dran.
Es gibt übrigens auch im Gesetz ein Kriterium, und das sagt sehr deutlich,
dass 60 Prozent des mittleren Einkommens bei der Beurteilung,
ob es ein angemessener Mindestlohn ist, wie das in die EU-Richtlinie auch vorsieht,
jetzt schon im Gesetz ein Kriterium ist.
Und ich erwarte, dass in der Mindestlohnkommission die Sozialpartner einheitlich
und gemeinsam entscheiden, weil das das Vertrauen auch in die Fortentwicklung
des Mindestlohns stärkt. Aber Sie haben recht, das kann nicht das Einzige bleiben.
Besser als eine Lohnuntergrenze, ein Mindestlohn sind immer Tariflöhne in Deutschland.
Und deshalb werden wir in diesem Jahr noch auf den Weg bringen,
ein Tarifstärkungsgesetz, was dazu führt, dass öffentliche Aufträge des Bundes
zum Beispiel nur an tarifgebundene Unternehmen gehen, die nach Tarif bezahlen.
Das stärkt die Tarifbindung, auch die Löhne, damit Arbeit sich mehr lohnt in Deutschland.
Man ist ja sowieso verblüfft darüber, dass das noch nicht so ist,
dass man also öffentlich Aufträge vergibt an Unternehmen, die sich nicht an
die Tarifbindung halten.
Naja, der Staat gibt ja da vor allem auch viele Bauaufträge.
Da kannst du gar nicht groß, weil du es einfach gar nicht durchschaust.
Also wenn du da anfängst so ein Ding aufzuziehen, da fehlen noch viel mehr Gesetze.
Aber ich finde, man könnte jetzt nicht nur beim Thema Krieg in der Ukraine,
Krieg in Gaza oder so, immer mal wieder auf eine, nee, wir haben eine regelbasierte Ordnung.
Wir wissen, Protagonisten, Konflikte und so weiter, aber wir haben auch regelbasierte Ordnungen.
In dem Fall eben, so wie Heil, und das ist dann auch wieder bezeichnend,
du hast auf der einen Seite so ewig lange Podcasts, Gelabergespräche und im
Bundestag eine Anfrage der Bundes, also diese Fragestunden der Bundesregierung,
tausend Fragen und dann immer nur 30 Sekunden.
30 Sekunden Antwort, 30 Sekunden Frage.
So, und da wünscht man sich doch, dass dann wenigstens Lars Kling bei sich in
einem Podcast mal 30 Sekunden nimmt, um auf die regelbasierte Ordnung des Mindestlohns hinzuweisen.
Ein Clip noch von.
Heil im Bundestag, denn all das muss man ja auch nochmal einbetten in diese,
fortlaufenden bescheuerten Diskussionen der CDU zum Thema Bürgergeld.
So, Bürgergeld ist ja angeblich immer zu hoch. Warum? Lohnabstandsgebot.
Und dann schweigen sie ja zum Mindestlohn. So wie jetzt Heil hier auch schon
den Bogen gespannt hat. Naja, der Mindestlohn muss so und so.
Und eigentlich brauchen wir ordentliche Tariflöhne, weil der Mindestlohn ist
ja dann gesetzlich da nachlaufend. Also kümmern wir uns erstmal zumindest da,
wo wir wirtschaftlich eingreifen als Auftraggeber, um eine ordentliche Linie.
Und die CDU blendet ja sowas komplett aus. Also für die gibt es ja nur Bürgergeld.
Das ist doch alles Betrüger und so.
Deswegen von Heil nochmal kurz. Nichtsdestotrotz, und wir wissen jetzt,
wie viel die CDU in allen Kanälen über das Bürgergeld geredet hat.
So, und Heil macht jetzt nochmal einen Aufruf an die CDU zum Thema Mindestlohn.
Sie müssen ihr Thema Mindestlohn mal als CDU für sich klären.
Wir sind dafür, dass sich der Mindestlohn weiterentwickelt und dass wir unsere
und mittlere Einkommen in Deutschland entlasten, damit Arbeit sich noch stärker lohnt.
Das ist der Unterschied. Sie schweigen zum Thema Löhne.
Ja, die CDU redet so gerne über das Bürgergeld und über die anderen Themen gar
nicht und zwar nirgendwo zu reden, auch nicht im parlamentarischen Betrieb.
Das muss man sich immer wieder vergegenwärtigen. Es sind Verlegenheitssachen, die da kommen.
Bürgergeld einfach nur, um so ein Stimmungsding zu setzen, wo man auch weiß,
der Wähler, auf den wir abzielen, der identifiziert sich niemals mit Bürgergeldempfängern.
Und dann hält man sich einfach die Mindestlohndiskussion so vom Hals.
Und er würde auch nie auf die Idee kommen, dass möglicherweise er mehr Lohn verdient hätte.
Dann ist das so, wie es ist. Und wenn ich zu wenig bekomme, dann sind die Bürgergeldempfänger
und oder die Ausländer daran schuld.
Genau, man macht dann diese Auswege. Also wir haben es hier mit einem Thema
zu tun, bei dem wir immer auf die regelbasierte Ordnung abstellen können.
Und wenn irgendwer kommt und sagt, nee, das sollte volkswirtschaftlich entschieden
werden, dann sagen wir, naja, das ist die volkswirtschaftliche Entscheidung.
Der Staat als Player, der Märkte erschafft, absichert, garantiert,
mit juristischen und ökonomischen Haltelinien, Grenzziehungen,
Untergrenzen, Obergrenzen, wie man es auch immer definiert, äh,
Einfach diese Semsrott-Logik übernehmen, macht es wie bei den Bundestagsabgeordneten.
Automatismus, wir haben ihn, wir können ihn anwenden, fertig. Keine Diskussion.
Ja, du hast sicherlich auch das Grundgesetz gefeiert in diesem Monat.
Natürlich.
Die Bild-Zeitung hat ja große Umfragen gemacht, was ist Deutschland für dich
und ich will die schönste Antwort mitbringen.
Was ist Deutschland für dich?
Ja, was liebst du an Deutschland? Und 75 Jahre Grundgesetz, da fragt man also
die Prominenz, was denn das Tolle an Deutschland ist an 75 Jahren Grundgesetz, Bundesrepublik etc.
Und die schönste Antwort kam natürlich von Carmen Geis, du kennst sie,
die Frau von Robert, genau. Genau.
Sie sagt, ich liebe Deutschland, weil es wirklich ein wunderschönes Land ist.
Es gibt unglaublich viele schöne Seen und Berge. Die Landschaft in Deutschland
beeindruckt mich einfach.
Und wir wissen, die Seen und die Berge sind dank des Grundgesetzes entstanden.
Ein Hoch auf die Gründerväter und Mütter und auf die Bundesregierung. Regierung.
Ja, vor allem ist so interessant, dass sie als diejenige, die ganz Deutschland in so ein,
wie soll man sagen, du kannst ja alles kaufen und so weiter,
dann genau die Sachen nennt, die man sich nochmal nicht für Geld kaufen kann,
sondern die wirklich allgemein gut sind.
Und die auch nichts mit politischer Macht zu tun haben. Also wenn hier jemand
anders regieren würde, wären die Seen und Berge vermutlich immer noch da.
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Wahrscheinlich ist es gar nicht so der große CSU Erfolg,
dass die 3000 Meter Berge die paar, die wir haben in Bayern anstehen.
Wahrscheinlich nicht. Man müsste es Söder schon beibringen. Ja,
jetzt machen wir hier ja manchmal Preaching to the Crier, in dem wir sagen, wir,
wollen, dass die FDP wenig Einfluss hat und so weiter.
Ja, wollen wir.
Aber ich will jetzt nicht so weit gehen und sagen, ich habe in den letzten Wochen
Christian Lindner lieb gewonnen.
Aber in gewisser Weise sage ich jetzt...
So auf freundschaftlicher Basis bist du schon mit ihm Ich sage es jetzt.
Nur halb ironisch, dass ich zum Anhänger der Schuldenbremse geworden bin.
Und ich will das ein bisschen ausführen, wenn du gestattest.
Die Hörer ballen die Fäuste, ich auch.
Alle sind wütend. Und vielleicht erstmal so ein bisschen Selbstbefragung.
Hat man sich nicht vielleicht ein bisschen zu sehr verliebt in diesen Gedanken,
die Schuldenbremse muss abgeschafft werden, egal wofür?
Also man kann ja mal darüber nachdenken, wofür wird die Schuldenbremse abgeschafft
oder wofür sollte man die Schuldenbremse abschaffen.
Ich glaube, ich muss hier nicht nochmal erwähnen und wir sprechen ja heute noch
über das Bauen und wir haben jetzt schon Soziales angesprochen,
dass der Staat mehr Geld in die Hand nehmen müsste und dass die Schuldenbremse
uns da bremst und dass ich natürlich, was das alles anbelangt,
sehr gegen die Schuldenbremse bin und daran wird sich ja auch nichts ändern.
Aber wir haben jetzt alle diesen tollen Streit nochmal so miterlebt.
Marie-Agnes Strack-Zimmermann wirft dem Kanzler autistische Züge vor in Fragen
der Aufrüstung und der Behandlung der Ukraine.
Aber hast du ihre Entschuldigung gehört?
Und sie entschuldigt sich jetzt bei den Menschen, die im autistischen Bereich tätig sind.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was das meint, aber es ist bestimmt gut gemeint von ihr.
Jedenfalls fand ich das so kurios, dass sie sich nochmal den Kanzler ausgesucht
hat, um sich an ihm abzuarbeiten.
Denn wenn ich jetzt mal ganz kurz mich in die Position von Strackzimmermann
hineinversetze und die einmal teilen würde,
dann würde ich ja überlegen, wer steht meinem Anliegen am allermeisten im Wege
und dann wäre das natürlich nicht der Kanzler, sondern es wäre Christian Lindner.
Ich möchte sogar so weit gehen und sagen, Christian Lindner ist gerade ein großer Pazifist aus Versehen.
Christian Lindner wird aufgefordert von Pistorius, mehr Milliarden zu liefern.
Lindner sagt, nee, nee, nee, wir müssen also hier ganz sparsam sein.
Roderich Kiesewetter, der Hardliner der CDU, sagt, der Krieg lässt sich nur mit Schulden gewinnen.
Und dann sagt Pistorius, ja, man muss mal darüber nachdenken,
es gibt da so eine verfassungsrechtliche Konkordanz.
Also was er damit meint, momentan ist das so, dass er also.
Aufrüstung und die Schuldenbremse gleichwertig behandelt werden und sich damit ausbremsen.
Was er eigentlich möchte, ist, dass die Aufrüstung über der Schuldenbremse steht.
Dies ist ziemlich exakt das, was die CDU auf europäischer Ebene in ihrem Programm fordert.
Nämlich, dass man sagt, ja, wir sind für die Austeritätspolitik,
aber bei der Verschuldung für Rüstung,
müssen wir das so regeln, dass diese Art der Verschuldung nicht in die allgemeine
Rechnung der Maastricht-Kriterien mit einfließt.
Jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, aber wenn die Schuldenbremse gelockert wird,
dann ist weniger Druck auf den anderen Haushalten da.
Das ist ja eine Argumentation, die beispielsweise auch Adam Tooze schon häufig
vorgetragen hat. Ich glaube das tatsächlich nicht.
Wenn man sich die Programme ansieht von SPD, CDU, Grüne und FDP,
FDP will sowieso Australitätspolitik weiter betreiben, Aufrüstung ja,
aber sagt gar nicht, wie das dann leistbar ist.
Aber bei den anderen drei genannten Parteien wird es so sein,
dass man die Schuldenbremse wahrscheinlich bei der nächsten Wahl,
nach der nächsten Wahl abschaffen wird.
Sehr wahrscheinlich, ja.
Aber man wird nicht dann damit, und deswegen sage ich, es haben sich viele Leute
sehr verliebt in die Abschaffung der Schuldenbremse, man wird nicht damit den
sozialen Wohnungsbau finanzieren,
man wird damit nicht mehr Bürgergeld gestatten, man wird damit nicht Schwimmbäder
bauen, die Kommunen entlasten etc.
Das wäre dann auch alles möglich, dazu fehlt aber dann der politische Wille.
Sondern man wird sagen, wir haben die Schuldenbremse aufgegeben und sorgen nun
dafür, dass wir in einem ganz, ganz großen Stil aufrüsten, denn de facto ist
es ja so, diese ganze CDU-Rede vom zu hohen Bürgergeld,
wenn man sich einfach mal ansieht, wie der Haushalt verteilt ist,
dann gibt es natürlich die Möglichkeit,
beim Bürgergeld zu kürzen und selbst wenn man es halbieren würde,
dann könnte man da ein paar Panzer kaufen, Aber das wäre nicht so relevant.
Man müsste die Rente, die ja über 100 Milliarden im Jahr bezuschusst wird,
müsste man also halbieren.
Dann könnte man sagen, wir haben jetzt richtig viel Geld. Dann kann man ja mal
in die Talkshow gehen und sagen, ja, also wir haben uns jetzt mal überlegt,
wir halbieren die Rente.
Was dann los ist. Also ist überhaupt nicht möglich. Das heißt,
man kann mit dieser Aufrüstungsdiskussion natürlich dafür sorgen,
dass man noch Lisa Paus zwei Milliarden abknöpft oder so, die sie dann nicht
ausgeben darf. Aber das alles ist nicht relevant.
Das heißt, wir werden eine Hegemonie wahrscheinlich bekommen,
die dahin läuft, dass die Schuldenbremse abgeschafft wird.
Und dann werden viele MMTler und so mal kurz jubeln, aber ich sage es hier deutlich, es wird.
Ein einziges progressives Projekt dann verwirklicht werden, sondern man wird
nur noch mehr aufrüsten und das hat noch eine oder hat zwei Problematiken, vielleicht sogar drei.
Einmal wird sehr viel Arbeitskraft dadurch wieder gebunden werden,
die man woanders benötigt. braucht, die man woanders benötigt.
Zweitens, wenn wir mehr Waffen produzieren, werden wir noch mehr exportieren
Waffen, wir werden noch mehr in Konflikte involviert sein.
Du hast das ja mal sehr gut gezeigt mit einem Tooth im Salon,
was Staatsräson eigentlich meint.
Das meint Waffenlieferungen nach Israel und inwieweit man da verquickt ist.
Und drittens ist das natürlich ökologisch ein ziemliches Desaster.
Gegenrede? Ja, die ist natürlich jetzt zwingend. Und ich versuche eine Einflugschneise
zu finden, indem ich dir mit Christian Lindner selbst versuche,
ein, nicht gegen Argument, aber ein Gegen-Gedankenraum aufzumachen.
Christian Lindner stand nämlich jetzt auf der Bühne des Finanzministeriums.
Ich habe es mit Mick im Fernsehpodcast geschaut.
Also es gibt einen O-Ton davon, wie er sagt darauf, dass Boris Pistorius jetzt
losgeschickt wurde, um zu sagen, ganz explizit, die Schuldenbremse geht so nicht, denn Verteidigung.
So, damit hat ja die SPD für sich zwei Entscheidungen getroffen.
Wir schicken den Kanzler der Herzen vor, um das Thema zu besetzen und wir verknüpfen
die Schuldenbremse jetzt mit dem, den Deutschen gerade am wichtigsten Thema,
weil Verteidigung ist ja auch so ein, wie soll man sagen, ein Thema,
bei dem jeder betroffen ist.
Also auch Carmen Geiss kann sich nicht davon freikaufen, dass wenn ein Verteidigungsfall,
dann brennt der Wald und sie weder den Wald noch die Gegenwehr kann sie selber
organisieren aus ihrem Privatvermögen, könnte sich höchstens ein Zaun bauen
für ihr kleines Grundstück.
Und in dieser Gemengelage, in der Christian Lindner in die Enge getrieben wurde.
Sagte er den Satz, fiskalische Resilienz ist auch ein Teil der Verteidigungspolitik.
So, und wenn jetzt fiskalische Resilienz, also Darben, Sparen,
Hungern, mit zur Verteidigungspolitik gehört,
würde ich sagen, dann lass uns doch die Schuldenbremse so weit abräumen,
dass wir wieder in so ein Vor-2009er-Ding kommen. Da gab es ja auch eine Schuldenbremse.
Nur eben so als goldene Regel, so viel wie wir investieren, dürfen wir auch
uns verschulden. Also es war halt nicht so streng.
Und dann lass uns doch in so einen Zustand zurückgehen und einfach alles als
Verteidigungspolitik deklarieren.
So wie wir ja auch schon gesagt haben, die Landesverteidigung mit der Waffe
an der Hand zur Grenze laufen, ist überhaupt nur erklärbar und logisch vernünftig,
wenn es an der Heimatfront stimmt.
Wenn man sich darauf verlassen kann, dass das restliche Leben gut funktioniert.
Und damit, finde ich, fällt alles unter, und dann kann man den Grundbegriff
austauschen, Resilienz.
Die pädagogische Resilienz ist auch ein Teil der Verteidigungspolitik.
Man könnte das so machen und ich stimme dir zu, ich will in keiner Weise widersprechen,
nur ich schaue mir an, wo sind die politischen Mehrheiten,
welcher politische Wille hat sich gebildet und der hat offenbar nicht dein Konzept
verfolgt, dieser politische Wille, der sich da gebildet hat,
sondern es ist ein anderer Wille.
Ich glaube, wir sind eher in einer Situation, die den 80er Jahren gleicht und
zwar der Reagan-Jahre in den USA.
Reagan hat den Sozialstaat beschnitten, wo er konnte.
Das ging auch nur bis zu einem gewissen Punkt, also man kann,
das sieht man ja gerade beim Bürgergeld, da ist jetzt Verfassungsgericht sowieso
schon dazwischen, aber ja, man kann Leute arm machen und man kann sie noch ein
bisschen ärmer machen, aber das hat doch Grenzen, man kann ihnen nichts geben.
Und dafür sind die Summen einfach zu niedrig, um da entsprechend dann noch mehr
Geld zu bekommen, indem man kürzt. Und was hat Reagan gemacht?
Er hat den Sozialstaat ein bisschen sehr hart angefasst und hat aber zugleich
wahnsinnig viele Schulden gemacht für die Aufrüstung, weil er die Möglichkeit hatte.
Also in den USA gibt es ja bis heute diese Art der Schuldenbremse nicht.
Und was ich glaube ist, dass wir generell auf der europäischen Ebene sehen,
von der Leyen ist, und wir haben das hier im Podcast sehr häufig dokumentiert,
vier, fünf Jahre lang damit hausieren gegangen,
jetzt haben wir hier unseren Mann auf dem Mond, das wird unsere neue grüne Transformation.
Keiner wollte das hören. Das wurde ja oft in den Medien noch nicht mehr reportiert.
Du hast es irgendwo rausgefischt und dann hier vorgespielt.
Und das funktioniert nicht. Wenn jetzt aber von der Leyen mit Meloni,
mit anderen zusammen, und damit kommen wir gleich schon zum nächsten Themenkomplex,
sagt Aufrüstung, wir müssen die NATO stärken, dann funktioniert das,
aber dann ist diese grüne Transformation, die kann vielleicht noch irgendwo
mitlaufen, aber das wird nicht der Kern sein.
Deswegen Noch einmal, natürlich bin ich nach wie vor jemand,
der sagt, die MMT hat da einen sehr guten Ansatz und ich halte nach wie vor
die Schuldenbremse für falsch in Bezug auf die eigentlichen Investitionen,
die getätigt werden müssten.
Aber wenn ich mir die politischen Mehrheiten gerade ansehe und wenn ich mir
den allgemeinen öffentlichen Diskurs ansehe, inklusive Anne Will denkt darüber nach,
wir könnten doch ganz viele Bunker bauen, dann bin ich mir sicher,
dass die Schuldenbremse fallen wird.
Und zwar wahrscheinlich spätestens
dann, wenn die CDU regiert und dann wahrscheinlich am ersten Tag.
Aber dies wird nicht dazu führen, dass eine Sozialwohnung mehr entsteht,
dass ein Kulturzentrum mehr errichtet wird oder irgendein Schwimmbad.
Deshalb warne ich davor und sage das auch ganz direkt an diese MMTler,
ich warne davor, sich einfach nur in die Idee der Abschaffung der Schuldenbremse zu verlieben.
Es muss immer um politische Mehrheiten gehen. Und deswegen habe ich einen Clip
mitgebracht und das war ganz zufällig.
Ich hatte also diese Provokation mir heute schon zurechtgelegt im Kopf und fand
dann gestern noch zufällig einen Clip, der aber relativ neu ist,
zwei Wochen alt, von Yuval Noah Harari.
Und der guckt sich mal an, was eigentlich so ausgegeben wurde für Rüstung.
Es ist ein längerer Clip, aber wir sollten uns ihn mal ganz zu Gemüte führen.
Every king, every emperor, every republic, every city-state was the military.
More than 50% of the budget of the Roman Empire, for instance,
was spent on soldiers and building fortifications and warships and things like that.
It was the same in almost every ancient and medieval and early modern kingdom.
Wenn man sich in den ersten 20.
Jahrhunderten anschaut, dann spielte Britannien während der Weltkriege ca.
50% ihres Budgetes auf den Militär. Während der Weltkriege ging es um 70%.
And this was the normal state of affairs. If you look, if you read state budgets
from the early 21st century, this is maybe one of the most optimistic reading materials ever.
Much more convincing than any pacifist track.
Nochmal, um sich das zu vergegenwärtigen, 50%, 70% des gesamten Staatshaushaltes für das Militär.
Das ist so unglaublich. Also wir reden jetzt da über Ideen, dass man vielleicht
auf 10% kommt oder so etwas,
oder noch ein bisschen höher, aber wir sind weit davon eigentlich entfernt. Aber nun.
Als auf dem Militär. Und das war unvergesslich für die meiste Geschichte.
Und das wurde tatsächlich erreicht. Und es ist kein gewisser Pazifist-Fantasy für die Zukunft.
Es wurde tatsächlich erreicht. In den letzten Jahren sehen wir die Rückkehr
der Kriege in vielen Teilen des Welt, insbesondere in meiner Region des Süden Osten,
Denn der Wandel war nicht das Ergebnis eines heiligen Wunders oder der Änderung
der Natur-Lösungen, sondern die Änderung von Menschen, die ihr eigenes Verhalten
verändern können und es can change it back.
And we are now unfortunately changing it back and we are seeing a resurgence of war.
But simply realizing that the level of violence is not constant and that if
we make the effort, we can create a much more peaceful können.
Society, this is the first step towards actually realizing it.
Also, ich will mit meinem Lieblingsthema kurz antworten. Die Zeiten,
in denen wir 70, 80 Prozent, ich würde jetzt weniger so im staatlichen Budget,
sondern mehr so im staatlichen Engagement begriffen bleiben.
Das kommt aus einer Zeit, in der Nachwuchs kein Problem war, also so zahlenmäßig.
Oder anders ausgedrückt, Nachwuchs war ein Problem, man wusste nicht wohin.
Junge Männer, die sich die ganze Zeit prügeln wollen, was machen wir eigentlich mit denen?
Naja, wir stecken sie mal in der Kaserne, wo sie den ganzen Tag über eine sinnvolle
Aufgabe, eine Handlungsorientierung und dann eine Zielgerichtetheit bekommen.
Das heißt, man hatte eine Organisation, die gerade so zusuchte nach einer Aufgabe
und es war am einfachsten, ihnen einfach eine militärische zu geben.
Das kann man sich heute nicht mehr vorstellen, Aber bis zum Anfang des letzten
Jahrhunderts, Hitlerjugend und so weiter, da ging es einfach darum,
die größte Gruppe der Bevölkerung, die man nicht im Zaum erhalten kann, weil...
Deren Elterngeneration zu 30% in Arbeitslosigkeit und so weiter,
also riesige Konflikte mit sich selbst austragen muss, die muss man irgendwie organisieren.
Also steckt man sie in solche Jugendorganisationen, bindet sie relativ nah an
die Politik an und hat dann halt Massenpartei-Organisationen,
die irgendwie eine Zielrichtung brauchen.
Also es gibt da auch so einen, ich will nicht sagen Automatismus,
aber eine funktionale Erklärung dafür, warum das so ist. Jetzt hat sich ja alles verdreht.
Nicht mal China ist in der Lage Taiwan zu überfallen, weil sie einfach die Kalkulation
vorher nicht hinkriegen.
Also die wissen einfach nicht, was bedeutet das jetzt so weltweit.
Sind da jetzt Killswitches in diesen Anlagen? Könnten wir da eh nichts mit diesen Chips machen?
Zerstören wir damit alles? Also auch unsere eigene Produktion?
Wie sieht dann die Antwort der Welt aus?
Und der ganze Kram. Also man kriegt es einfach ökonomisch.
Damals war es folgerichtig, Ökonomie,
also den Staat einfach über seine Verteidigungsfähigkeit aufzubauen.
Heute gilt genau das Umgekehrte, weil sich eben die demografische Lage einfach
groß umgekehrt hat. Und wir haben heute….
Und zwar wirklich vergleichbar mit nee, wir brauchen jetzt eine Impfpflicht. Das ist ganz wichtig.
Und alle sind sich so einig, dass selbst der Bundeskanzler, der auf jedes Thema
scheut, einfach auf der Bühne sitzt und sagt, ja, ja, das ist total vernünftig,
eine Impfpflicht zu machen.
Drei Monate später wollte davon niemand etwas wissen.
Was haben wir für einen Stress gehabt, irgendwelche Güterwagen mit militärischen
Mitteln, wenn auch in der Hand der Polizei, in der Schweiz aufzuhalten,
um zu sagen, das wird jetzt hier nicht exportiert. Worum ging es? Masken.
So. Jetzt, vier Jahre später, wir können es uns gar nicht mehr richtig vorstellen,
China überflutet den Weltmarkt mit Masken.
Keiner kommt gerade in Deutschland auf die Idee, hier eine eigene Maskenproduktion
aufzuziehen, obwohl das damals so zwingend war.
So, meine Vermutung ist, Donald Trump wurde jetzt verurteilt,
es wird diesen Wahlkampf nochmal zuspitzen, es wird keine Wählerstimme verändern,
also er wird weiterhin gewählt werden,
er wird sich noch mehr in der Defensive sehen,
er wird noch mehr den Ratschlägen folgen, jetzt einfach weltweit ein großes
Zeichen zu setzen, er wird sich mit Putin verständigen, der Krieg wird aufhören,
wir werden alle irgendwie so ein bisschen aufatmen,
weil wir denken ja, die sind zwar irre, aber die haben es halt jetzt in der
Hand und es steht in Frieden im Raum, wer hat denn ernsthaft was gegen den Frieden
und sagt dann, nee, wir Europäer sollen jetzt ohne Amerika diesen Krieg weiterführen.
Also dieser Krieg wird ein Ende finden.
Aber die Amerikaner könnten ja auch sagen, nee, der Krieg ist schon wichtig,
aber wichtig ist, dass ihr den bezahlt und führt.
Ja, irgend sowas. Und dann wird man feststellen, nee, wir Europäer schaffen es nicht.
Aber man möchte es ja schaffen.
Ja, das ist ja diese Hysterie jetzt.
Ja, aber da würde ich ja schon sagen, dass der Unterschied zwischen der Geopolitik
und Corona ist, Corona war ja dann aufgrund von Omikron, aufgrund davon,
dass sich auch einfach viele Leute haben impfen lassen ohne eine Pflicht, vorbei.
Und hier würde ich sagen, ja, der Ukraine-Krieg mag enden und möglicherweise
hast du recht, dass dieses Szenario da eintritt mit Trump.
Möglicherweise ist es aber auch so, dass tatsächlich Europa sagt,
wir kümmern uns drum und dann wird es richtig teuer und auch richtig gefährlich.
Aber wie dem auch sei, dieser eine Krieg, wenn er dann vorbei ist,
beendet ja nicht alle Kriege, sondern wir haben ja zugleich den Krieg in der
Ost und wo es überhaupt keine Unterscheidung in der Position gibt zwischen Trump
und Biden, ist ja die Perspektive auf China.
China und du sagst natürlich zu Recht, dass es ein demografisches Problem gibt
und wir werden nachher mal so eine Zahl hören, also die Chinesen rechnen, dass sie um Taiwan.
Besetzen zu können, also nicht mal da so gerade rein, sondern wirklich besetzen
zu können damit, dass sie 500.000 Soldaten brauchen für einen doch recht kleinen Fleck.
Und jetzt kann man natürlich denken, also wie viel ist dann da überhaupt möglich?
Allerdings kann man auch wieder sagen, Länder mit sehr viel Budget und so könnten
natürlich viel stärker umstellen auf Söldner.
Putin, der nicht so ein großes Budget hat wie jetzt westliche Staaten,
hat ja auch mit der Gruppe Wagner doch ein ganz, ganz großes Söldnerheer sich schon geschaffen.
Ich denke auch, dass die Kriege andere werden, nur ich habe nicht den Eindruck,
dass wir hier nur so einer Hysterie anheimfallen,
die dann in zwei Jahren wieder verpufft, sondern was hier jetzt so manifestiert
wird, da sind ja auch Investitionen, die gemacht werden.
Also da werden ja Zusagen bereits gemacht, Rheinmetall und Co.,
dass die überhaupt jetzt gerade auch noch 20 Millionen übrig haben, um den BVB zu sponsern.
Das hat man ja bei den Maskenfabriken alles nie gemacht. Das waren ja immer
so Lippenbekenntnisse, man müsste, man sollte und hat aber dann doch gesagt,
naja, ach so, die Chinesen liefern das und daher kommen die Handschuhe,
dann brauchen wir die auch nicht selbst machen.
Das läuft ja hier anders und wenn man sich das ansieht, wie wir jetzt Koalitionsbildung
vielleicht dann mit der Europawahl haben werden, dann gibt es da so eine Eintracht
wirklich von Grüne, SPD.
CDU und die europäischen Rechte.
Ich klammere hier bewusst die AfD aus, weil das ein anderer Fall ist.
Und deswegen, glaube ich, ist das jetzt ein großes Konzept, dass ja das BIP
nach oben treiben kann, das auch vor allem etwas ermöglicht.
Und das ist mir sehr aufgefallen in den Kommentaren, so Tagesschau,
Instagram-Kanal und sowas.
Wenn da irgend so eine Kachel kommt, Pistorius will 80 Milliarden mehr,
ja, und zwar jede Woche, dann schreiben die Leute reiheweise in die Kommentare.
Toller Mann, so muss es sein. Wir müssen wieder Stärke zeigen.
Und ich glaube, das sind ja nicht alles Leute, die reich sind,
die da schreiben, sondern ich glaube tatsächlich,
dass die soziale Situation für viele als so naturalisiert wahrgenommen werden,
dass sie sagen, ich werde ökonomisch nicht stärker, aber, und das ist jetzt pure Ideologie,
ich fühle mich stärker, wenn mein Land aufgerüstet ist.
Ja, also ich will nochmal dafür werben, einfach nehmen wir uns so ein bisschen
aus diesem Alltag, wie wir ihn jetzt gerade vor allem fühlen, raus.
Wir können uns eigentlich nur noch rational daran erinnern, aber es nicht mehr
wirklich nachfühlen, wie es war, als wirklich alle sagten, ne,
also da sollte die Polizei raus und jedem die Spritze in den Arm.
Maskenpflicht, überall, auch draußen und so weiter, ja, also es gab ja wirklich staatliche Befehle,
heute sieht man dann noch auf YouTube diese lustigen Clips wie irgendwie auf
einer Skipiste jemand fährt einsam den Hang runter und dann wird er angehalten
70 Euro, sie haben keine Maske aufgehabt ja, also wirklich der totale Wahnsinn,
Polizeiautos, die auf einer Wiese in einem Park Jugendlichen hinterherfahren
weil die irgendwie und so weiter und jetzt hören wir mal den ehemaligen,
Bundeswehrbeauftragten aus dem Bundestag der sich zum Thema immer diese neue
Wehrpflicht äußert und versuchen mal,
abseits dessen, was wir gerade irgendwie so vor uns hinfühlen,
was uns auch als Gefühle so vom Fernsehen,
wenn Agnes Strack-Zimmermann da irgendwie und so mit ihrer gewissen Vehemenz,
wir hören uns das mal an und ich denke das dann mal sachlich.
Der ehemalige Wehrbeauftragte des Bundestages, Hans-Peter Bartels,
SPD, jetzt Präsident der Gesellschaft für Sicherheitspolitik,
denkt in eine ähnliche Richtung.
Mir steht vor, dass wir die alte Wehrpflicht nicht in der alten Form wiederbeleben,
sondern als Auswahlwehrpflicht.
Und dann dazu kommen, dass statt 20.000 Soldaten, neue Soldaten,
Rekruten im Jahr auf dem freiwilligen Arbeitsmarkt freiwillig zu gewinnen,
Wenn wir dann vielleicht 40.000 im Jahr gewinnen über diese Auswahlwehrpflicht,
also einfach die Zahl des Nachwuchses verdoppeln, das würde der Bundeswehr jetzt schon sehr helfen.
So, eine Auswahlwehrpflicht. Jetzt überlegen wir uns mal.
Angenommen, dieser Krieg geht jetzt noch ein Jahr. Selbst wenn er dann noch
läuft, auch in dieser Härte, auch in diesem jeden Tag 300 Tote,
3000 Mordversuche, die auf diesem Kriegsgebiet stattfinden. Es wird eine Ermüdung geben.
Und die Leute werden irgendwann wirklich fragen, das ist irgendwie sinnlos.
Ich sehe da etwas, ich verstehe es nicht.
Jetzt mein Szenario noch ein bisschen extremer. Trump gewinnt,
macht mit Putin so einen Hauruck, die ganze Welt muss und wenn Europa will, ja, können sie halt.
Aber wenn man in Amerika anruft, geht niemand mehr ans Telefon.
Schaffen das die Europäer?
So, und dann, und ich würde mal sagen, so lange dauert es, wenn jetzt der CDU-Parteitag
hat jetzt auf Ansinnen der jungen Leute so eine, also diese Auswahlwehrpflicht
angeregt, die steht jetzt da irgendwie so in diesen Beschlüssen drin, dann regiert die CDU,
ab wann, mal gucken, vielleicht dauert es auch noch wirklich anderthalb Jahre,
dann kommt das irgendwann,
und dann haben wir so ein Szenario 2027.
Dieser Pflegestress wird auch zunehmen. Rentendiskussionen werden zunehmen.
Wir werden nicht mehr diese krasse Inflation haben, aber alle Schocks wirken ja weiterhin nach.
Es wird ja nicht zurück abgewickelt. So.
Und dann bekommen Familien Briefe, wo es heißt, sehr gut, dass ihr euer Einzelkind
gut durchs Abi gebracht habt.
Toll, dass ihr nicht den Staat angefragt habt nach den 7500 Euro für die Nachhilfe,
die das gekostet hat und so weiter. Den wollen wir jetzt haben.
So, wenn ich mir überlege, wie in Deutschland das, mein Kind soll auf diese
Schule gehen und nicht auf die, das ist so unfair, ich mache einen Aufstand,
ich gründe eine Bürgerinitiative, ich rufe den Bürgermeister an,
ich mache alles, alles auf dieser Welt, damit mein Kind nicht auf diese Schule
geht, sondern ich möchte, dass es auf diese Schule geht.
So, und dann glaubt der Staat, er könnte manchen Brief schreiben und anderen
nicht und wir bekommen dann keine Diskussion zum Thema, das ist aber unfair,
wir haben es hier mit Korruption zu tun, da wurden Leute bestochen,
damit manche diesen Brief nicht bekommen und so weiter und so fort.
Das ist Teufelsküche in dieser demografischen Lage, in der wir sind.
Und das haben wir bei ganz vielen dieser Themen.
Also wir denken jetzt immer gerade, ja, ja, diese mega Aufrüstung und irgendwann
wird die ganze Bundesliga von Rheinmetall bezahlt und so weiter.
Aber man kann diese Hysterie nicht allzu lange, wir müssen mit dem Virus Putin leben lernen.
Ja, ja.
Aber das wird so keinen großen Bestand haben.
Und es ist auch jetzt schon lächerlich, finde ich. Man muss sich das wirklich
mal anschauen und sagen, Leute, ihr könnt hier nicht, also ich habe hier Clips,
die sind so haarströmend.
Nur haben wir eine große, wenn wir jetzt, also für Deutschland stimme ich dir
da absolut zu und das ist die Gewalt des Faktischen und die können wir nicht aufheben,
aber auf der europäischen Ebene können wir ja schon sehen, dass Jugendarbeitslosigkeit
ein großes Problem ist und wenn man da beispielsweise sagt,
warum denn nicht zum Militär und das ist ja im Prinzip schon ein bisschen das,
was man jetzt auch tut, dass man Anreize schaffen will, warum man zur Bundeswehr geht.
Nun Anreize gibt es auch bei anderen Arbeitgebern, aber dass man jetzt sagt
kostenloser Führerschein,
dass man wie Pistorius das ja vorgeschlagen hat, dann auch noch sagt einen besseren
Zugang zu Fächern, die man studieren will, wo eine NC drauf ist.
Es ist also lauter solche Dinge.
Da kann man natürlich auch nochmal überlegen, wer wird eigentlich angesprochen?
Also den Krieg kämpfen müssen ja sowieso nicht die oberen 20 Prozent,
sondern die anderen kämpfen den ja.
Also nicht die Söhne von Journalisten kämpfen den Krieg, sondern ja,
höchstens die, die sich die Bild-Zeitung kaufen.
Aber ich will nur erinnern, wir hatten Eva Högl, die in der Bundespressekonferenz
sitzt und hat davon erzählt, die Eltern sehen die Stuben ihrer Söhne und Töchter
da und sagen, das geht so nicht.
Und klar, auf freiwilliger Basis, Anwerbetechniken und die armen Leute da anwerben,
das versucht die Bundeswehr seit zehn Jahren.
Wir sehen diese YouTube-Kampagnen, wir sehen den ganzen Kram,
es funktioniert einfach nicht. Warum?
Es sind wirklich zu wenige da.
Ja, und ich denke auch, dass sich, oder ich hoffe, dass sich zivilisatorisch
etwas gewandelt hat, dass man,
einfach das nicht mehr als eine Perspektive für sich sehen will,
wie man zum Beispiel auch nicht mehr als junger Mann, das war nämlich übrigens
die Alternative, wenn man nicht die Kinder in den Krieg schicken könnte, Priesterseminar.
Und da würde, also nichts gegen Leute, die sich dafür entscheiden,
aber ich sage mal so, das ist jetzt auch für viele nicht mehr so naheliegend
zu sagen, naja, dann lebe ich halt Solibatea, ich werde katholischer Priester.
Na gut, man hat ja den freiwilligen Sozialdienst oder so und dann mal alternativ für die Tätigkeit.
Nein, ich meine nur, wenn es ja darum geht, also es geht ja nicht nur die Leute
um den Zaun zu halten, sondern es ging ja wirklich auch darum,
was macht man mit denen beruflich?
Und dann sagt man ja, geh doch zum Militär, da kannst du Karriere machen.
Oder geh in die Kirche, dann bist du für immer versorgt, denn zu Hause haben wir nicht so viel.
Aber das ist jetzt auch nicht mehr eine Alternative, dass Männer sagen,
naja, ich lebe halt zur Libertär, aber dafür bin ich gut versorgt in der Kirche.
Also da können wir vielleicht hoffen, dass sich das nicht mehr einsetzt.
Und deswegen würde ich ja auch sagen, Insgesamt ist es eigentlich so verrückt,
dass das nicht viel mehr als Stimmung auch offen vorgetragen wird.
Also ich meine, die ganzen Influencer, die Rezos und so, die äußern sich ja
gar nicht zu diesem Thema.
Die könnten ja richtig schön mal ihren jungen Leuten sagen, wir spielen hier
Counter-Strike und so, aber wir gehen nicht aufs Schlachtfeld.
Also da könnte man ja eine große pazifistische Bewegung lostreten und die eine
oder andere Partei könnte es, wenn sie dann Interesse daran hätte,
auch in ganz anderer Weise adressieren.
Also in diesem Fall, glaube ich, wird sich vieles von selbst regeln,
weil sich vieles von selbst versteht.
Ja, aber die Aufrüstung kann es ja trotzdem geben. Also die Aufrüstung, ja,
die muss schon bedient werden, das Gerät, aber es ist ja auch viel Gerät,
was nicht mehr vielleicht so mannstark ist, beziehungsweise vielleicht wird
man noch mit Söldner-Konzepten arbeiten und da,
denke ich, wird es schon so sein, dass man also jetzt gerade das als Möglichkeit
nimmt, um die Schuldenbremse…,
abzuschaffen, aber das führt aufgrund der politischen Mehrheiten,
wie sie nun einmal sind, nicht zu einer, in irgendeiner Weise besseren Politik.
Also Küppers-Bursch hat letztens im Aufwachen-Podcast ganz pointiert darauf
hingewiesen, die deutsche Erfahrung der Nachkriegszeit ist, solange die Bundeswehr
mit Krieg nichts zu tun hat,
nimmt man den Führerschein, den man dort kostenlos bekommt, gerne mit, aber,
als es dann anfing, auch zu heißen, also wenn du in die Bundeswehr gehst und
eine Familie gründen willst, also du hast jetzt die Pastorenfamilie eingebracht,
das ist ja interessant eigentlich, dass man sich halt entscheiden sollte zwischen
Liebe zum Vaterland oder Liebe zu Gott.
Ja. Dann kam irgendwann die Liebe zur Frau dazwischen und die Liebe zur Frau
überwiegt immer auch die Liebe zum Vaterland, weil wenn es wirklich heißt,
du kannst jetzt Familie gründen, weil endlich ökonomische Sicherheit,
weil Arbeitgeberstaat, ist aber die Bundeswehr und es droht wirklich,
dass du dann entsandt wirst.
Ja. Dann entscheiden sich sehr viele Menschen, die vorher anders entschieden
hätten, wirklich dagegen.
Und ich glaube, die allergrößte Gefahr hier ist auch Die Automatisierung.
Also wenn wir Angst vor militärischen Auseinandersetzungen haben,
dann vor diesen Automatisierten, die demnächst kommen.
Larry Fink, also der Blackrock-Chef, saß letztens auf der Bühne und das war
wahnsinnig interessant, weil er meinte, und er hat so quasi diesen Hype,
diesen KI-Hype aufgegriffen. Und er meinte, ja, man kann sich schon lustig machen über diesen KI-Hype.
Und klar, das sind bislang nur Chatbots. Und vielleicht auch mehr so in dieser
kreativen Ecke. Die können halt tolle Bilder und mittlerweile auch Musik.
Was brauchen wir das in der Wirtschaft?
Aber, er meinte, der Handlungsdruck durch die demografische Wende ist so groß,
also einfach zu automatisieren, dass man aus dem letzten Unsinn noch irgendwas gestaltet.
Die Hauptsache, man ist nicht auf Recruitingstour und sucht irgendwelche Leute.
Und das ist natürlich im Militär eine der größten Gefahren überhaupt,
dass wir demnächst, und Herr Ari habe ich jetzt auch kürzlich in so einem Interview
gesehen, wo er so meinte, naja, bislang haben wir halt Technik entwickelt und
da haben wir eine Entscheidung darüber getroffen, wie wir sie einsetzen.
Nur, jetzt haben wir Atombomben, die selber nachdenken, die einfach selber entscheiden,
wann sie losfliegen und so.
Und in die Richtung, würde ich sagen, muss man es dramatisieren.
Was die Kriege mit menschlicher Beteiligung angeht, würde ich sagen,
die Kosten sind so hoch, es wird diese großen Auseinandersetzungen nicht geben.
China muss sich mit sich selbst befassen. Wenn, haben wir ein größeres...
Problem mit Terrorismus, also dass Putin die Ukraine überfällt,
wieder aller ökonomischen Logik, ist für mich ein terroristischer Akt,
ein ideologisch getriebener Akt.
Wir kommen ja zu dieser Thematik heute noch, weil wir ja uns mit den strukturellen
Realisten beschäftigen wollen, die sagen ja, Putin hat rational gehandelt.
Xi und seine Regierung ist ganz weit von so einer Art irrationalem Handeln entfernt,
also die kalkulieren wirklich alles auf dem Schachfeld durch.
Wir werden gleich mal diskutieren, ob das vielleicht doch rational war.
Aber lass uns noch kurz über die AfD sprechen.
Krah hat sich wieder was geleistet. Nämlich hat er ja gesagt,
naja, die Leute da in der SS, die waren ja jetzt auch nicht alle Täter.
Kannst du das erklären?
Warum er das tut?
Warum er das in der internationalen Presse sagt, nochmal so eine Verherrlichung
des alten Nazi-Denkens, das Neue, das er auf Anschlusssuche ist,
die große neue rechte Internationale, okay, aber mit so einem Blick zurück.
Ja, das war einfach sehr dumm. Also ich glaube, dass er darüber nicht nachgedacht
hat und nicht darüber nachgedacht hat, dass er jetzt gerade auf der europäischen Ebene spricht.
Denn natürlich hat die neue Rechte sowohl in Frankreich wie auch in Italien
jetzt nicht den deutschen Faschismus aufgearbeitet, aber sie hat doch versucht
eine Distanz zu ihm einzunehmen.
Und auch die deutschen Neurechten importieren ja eigentlich dann französische
und italienische Faschismen, faschistische Theorien,
um auch selbst jetzt nicht zum Beispiel zu nah an die Nazis assoziiert zu werden.
Weil sie sich dann ja solchen Sachen wie dem Holocaust stellen müssen,
sie müssen sich auch, genau diese Sachen, also das ist nicht etwas, was so gut gesehen ist.
Ich glaube, dass man auf der europäischen Ebene zumindest so.
Im Hinterzimmer hat Marine Le Pen vielleicht gar nicht das größte Problem damit,
wenn da irgendwas mit SS oder so kommt, aber es gibt einen anderen Zusammenhang,
glaube ich, und das ist interessant.
Ich hatte den Sebastian Friedrich, den ich für den profundesten Kenner der AfD
halte, der hat im Freitag, wir sind befreundet, um das nur an dieser Stelle
zu sagen, also Compliance,
der hatte einen Text geschrieben jetzt über diese neue Sache da von KRA.
Und er sagt, naja, also Rassemblement National, also die Partei von Meloni,
die hatte schon früher Probleme mit Krah.
Krah ist da hemmsärmlich unterwegs und zwar hat er Guillaume Pradurois aufgenommen
bei sich als Mitarbeiter.
Der ist von den Identitären und der wurde aber vom RN rausgeworfen wegen Antisemitismus.
Und wir wissen ja, Le Pen ist eine Person, die bereit ist für die politische
Macht mit Leuten zu brechen, die ihr eigentlich nahestehen und zwar mit dem eigenen Vater.
Ja, sie sagt zu dem eigenen Vater, das geht gar nicht, du bist Antisemit und
so, das wollen wir hier nicht.
Sebastian Friedrich schreibt jetzt im Freitag, Krahs identitäre Fraktionsmitgliedschaft
wurde zeitweise sogar suspendiert, weil er den rechts von Le Pen stehenden Eric
Simour bei den französischen Präsidentschaftswahlen unterstützte.
Also Krah hat auch den schon unterstützt. Beschädigt war das Verhältnis zwischen
der AfD und den Krampen der europäischen Rechten schon länger.
Und jetzt geht es auf eine Ebene nochmal über Krah hinaus.
Der Europaparteitag im vergangenen Sommer musste mit Grußworten aus Frankreich und Italien auskommen.
Zu größeren europäischen Treffen der Rechten wurde die AfD in der letzten Zeit nicht eingeladen.
Und von den relevanten rechten Kräften hier zuletzt nur noch die österreichische FPÖ zu AfD.
Ja, dann heißt hier,
Giorgia Melonis Partei Fratelli d'Italia gehört im Europaparlament derweil der
anderen rechten Fraktion an den europäischen Konservativen und Reformern EKR,
ebenso wie Abgeordnete von PiS, Spanischer Box,
die Finnen und Schwedendemokraten.
Und nun stellt sich also hier die Frage, sagt er, wird also Melonis Weg einer sein, dem Le Pen folgt?
Und was bedeutet das dann auf europäischer Ebene? Wir haben alle schon die herzigen
Bilder gesehen, Meloni und Biden, Meloni und von der Leyen.
Es ist vollkommen klar, dass die deutschen Konservativen nichts mit der AfD
auf europäischer Ebene machen können.
Man kann nicht zum einen mit Margot Friedländer auftreten und zum anderen mit
jemandem koalieren, der sagt ja, die SS war ja gar nicht so wild.
Machen sie auch nicht.
Ist unmöglich. Aber mit Meloni ist das eine andere Geschichte.
Und Le Pen scheint ja in Anführungszeichen in die Mitte sich zu bewegen.
Also in die Mitte dieser Leute, wo man sagt, Antisemitismus nicht,
bitte keine SS und so weiter, aber sonst natürlich hat man sich nicht gemäßigt,
sondern man ist natürlich extrem gegen Migration, gegen all das.
Also hier sagt Sebastian Friedrich, innerhalb der AfD würde man schon,
also bei diesem Umfeld Höcke-Krar, schon von einer Melonisierung sprechen.
Der AfD, nämlich Weidel, scheint durchaus daran interessiert zu sein.
Und was ist nämlich jetzt interessant, dass sich man ganz anders verhalten hat, nämlich diese neuen,
die europäischen Rechten jetzt sind nicht mehr die, die fundamental die Europäische Union ablehnen.
Höcke tut das, deswegen kann er da nicht mitspielen.
Und jetzt die geopolitische Ebene, finde ich hochinteressant,
sagt Friedrich, auch bei den meisten großen Rechtsparteien in Europa orientiert
man sich gerade seit dem Ukraine-Krieg stärker in Richtung der NATO.
Selbst beim französischen RN hält man sich mit allzu großen Avancen in Richtung
Moskau inzwischen zurück.
Also das heißt, hier und weil wir jetzt eben über die Aufrüstung sprachen und Möglichkeiten,
wie das dann ginge, glaube ich, sehen wir eine ganz große neue bürgerlich CDU
bis eben dann rechtspostfaschistische Koalition drohen.
Und wenn wir Jens Spahn hören, der hat Euraktiv ein Interview gegeben,
da sagte er, die Brandmauer, das potenzielle Partner der EVP pro-europäisch,
pro-NATO, pro-Rechtsstaat und pro-Ukraine sein müssen,
verläuft im Europaparlament rechts von Melonis Partei.
Ja, also, dass es sehr erfolgsträchtig ist, außenpolitisch keine großen Aufhebens
zu machen und dass die EU nur als Geldlieferant gesehen wird.
Das hat man ja jetzt, also wir nicht, aber diejenigen, die das organisieren
müssen, die haben das ja gelernt am Falle Ungarn.
Wenn du zu sehr über die Stränge schlägst, kriegst du einfach von der EU kein
Geld. Was die EU sonst macht, kann dir egal sein. Also es geht wirklich nur um diesen Geldströme.
So, die Geldströme nicht abreißen zu lassen, das ist natürlich auf zwei Ebenen.
Zum einen die Rechtsstaatlichkeit, die jetzt ein bisschen fester ins Rule-Based-Politikgeschehen
eingraviert wurde durch die Erfahrung mit der PiS, nee nicht der PiS,
sondern der, wie heißt der, naja, also Ormans-Partei.
Und dann auf der anderen Ebene gibt es aber diese persönliche Ebene.
Wenn sich Meloni mit von der Leyen gut versteht und von der Leyen eine zweite
Amtszeit bekommt, dann droht Italien einfach weniger.
Ja.
So, auf der Ebene irgendwie. Wenn die am Tisch alle gute Stimmung haben und
niemand groß auffällt und nervt, passt das.
Deswegen wird dieses innenpolitische Programm von Meloni ja vorsichtig und langsam,
aber rigoros durchgezogen.
Also Angriffe auf die Juristerei, auf die Medien und so weiter,
das findet da alles statt.
Aber ohne Aufhebens in Europa.
Und wenn du jetzt Alice Weidel da, sehr interessant, also ich hab jetzt,
wenn man die Liste der AfD-Chefs nochmal durchgeht, Bernd Lucke,
Frauke Petry, Jörg Meuthen, jetzt Alice Weidel, die versuchen alle das,
nur denen wird eben von ihrem gärigen Haufen das immer wieder zerschossen.
Inklusive, dass der Erste auf der Liste für die Europawahl da,
also klar, sein Blödsinn macht die ganze Zeit.
Nummer zwei hat dann plötzlich gar keine meldefähige Adresse,
also kann gar nicht vorgeladen werden, stellt sich raus, da lebt irgendein Asylbewerber
in so einer viel zu kleinen Wohnung, die kann gar nicht ihm gehören und lauter solche Sachen.
Und diese Unprofessionalität ist natürlich ein echter Stolperstein.
Jaja, nur man muss jetzt sehr aufpassen, was jetzt gerade so in den deutschen
Medien und in der Rezeption dieser KRA-Affären stattfindet, ist,
dass man sagt, haha, jetzt besiegen wir die AfD.
Ich glaube, dass das bei den Wählern nicht allzu viel Unruhe verursacht und
das sieht man ja auch an den Umfragen.
Mag sein, dass die jetzt zwei Prozent verlieren. Wir werden aber in Thüringen
kommunalwahlend dies doch ein bisschen anders zeigen.
Was ich aber sagen will, der Rechtsruck kann auch ohne die AfD vollzogen werden.
Also ich habe jetzt einige Podcasts gehört, die dann mit sehr viel Emphase aufrufen,
dies ist die historische Wahl, bitte geht alle wählen.
Das machen wir hier nicht in dieser Weise mit so schrillen Tönen.
Und dann war immer direkt gleich daran angeknüpft, wir müssen endlich eine andere
Flüchtlingspolitik bekommen,
das Asylrecht muss humaner werden, wir müssen das stoppen und so weiter. Die Sache ist nur,
Diese Podcasts, wo ich das gehört habe, geben keinerlei Wahlempfehlungen,
weil da müsste man in die Programme gucken, wo steht das so.
Und da würde ich sagen, da wird man nur bei ganz, ganz wenigen überhaupt fündig.
Und dann sprechen sie auch nicht an, was eigentlich droht. Also eigentlich müssten
sie sagen, ja, also wählt bitte nicht die AfD.
Aber seid euch auch sicher, dass Meloni und Ursula von der Leyen sich gut verstehen.
Also ist sehr gut möglich, dass man eine neue Koalitionsbildung hat,
die so aussieht, dass mit deiner
Stimme für CDU, CSU du gleichzeitig die Postfaschistin Meloni unterstützt.
Das wäre eigentlich die ehrliche Kommunikation. Und die kann man ja jetzt auch
ableiten, ohne ganz tief in der Materie zu sein.
Wir können ja mal diesen einen Clip, vielleicht kannst du den mal anklicken, von Harte aber fair.
Da ist Julia Klöckner zu Gast und wird da auch befragt nach Brandmauer.
Wir werden...
Bei der Rechten eine Zusammenarbeit geben. Es wird mit Einzelnen,
und das muss man raussuchen, und da wird es konkret die Brandmauer.
Brandmauer schwebt hier oben.
Wer ist pro-europäisch? Wer nicht pro-europäisch ist, mit dem kann man überhaupt
zusammenarbeiten. Aber ist Frau Meloni pro-europäisch?
Zweitens, wer ist pro-Rechtsstaat? Und drittens, wer ist für die Ukraine?
Aber das ist doch aufschlussreich. Es reicht, gegen Putin zu sein,
und dann darf man wie Frau Meloni aus einer politischen Bewegung.
Die Kriterien würde ich lieber nicht ansetzen an Ihrer Stelle,
weil dann bekommen Sie keine Mehrheit für Frau Ponella.
Doch, das könnte man schon kriegen. Wir hätten ja hier ein Problem gar nicht, wenn nicht z.B.
Die Liberalen, die Grünen und auch die Sozialdemokraten genau das aufgekündigt
hätten, was wir in der Mitte hatten.
Nein, nein, nein, das hängt ja genau an der Frage.
Frau Klöckner? Alle drei sagen, sie unterstützen Frau von der Leyen.
Ja, die Brandmauer ist schwebend, die schwebt nämlich da oben und die setzen
wir dann dahin, wo wir sie brauchen und was hier auch nochmal von ihr gesagt
wird, also pro europäisch und das meint natürlich gleichzeitig pro NATO,
die entsprechende Haltung zum Ukraine-Krieg und auch dann mögliche Zölle gegen
China und sowas muss natürlich gewährleistet sein,
aber sonst ist da viel möglich und das ist tatsächlich beängstigend,
dass wir jetzt so einen Rechtsruck erleben, dass wir eine inhumanere Flüchtlingspolitik,
als sie ohnehin schon ist, bekommen werden, aber nicht durch die AfD.
Die AfD spielt in dem Sinne da keine Rolle, der Krah kann sehen,
ob er da noch lange es aushält in dieser Partei oder ob sie ihn dann irgendwann
rauskicken, ob irgendwann Alice Weidel sagt, na das ist eigentlich doch ganz begehrlich,
ganz schön, so wie Meloni und Le Pen dann irgendwann hofiert zu werden.
Das wird sich zeigen, aber man kann ja, wenn man über die Europawahl nachdenkt,
nicht nur über die AfD nachdenken, sondern ich glaube diese neuen Koalitionsbildungen,
die da entstehen könnten,
sind so gefährlich deshalb, weil man nicht mehr genau dieses hat,
ach ja, das sind jetzt irgendwie die Nachkommen der Nazis, die jetzt da nochmal
in die Politik gehen oder was, sondern man denkt, naja, die sind doch bürgerlich.
Das betont ja auch dann eine Julia Klöckner laufend.
Ja, da würde ich auch sagen, die Gefahr droht von der CDU. Man hat jetzt gesehen,
ich habe immer noch Florian Schröder im Ohr, wie er sagt, warum wir die AfD keinen Erfolg haben.
Sie ist zu doof und ehrlicherweise, sie ist zu doof.
Sie hat jetzt in Thüringen eigentlich so ein 32, 33, 34 Prozent Umfrageergebnis
gehabt. Dann sind diese Kommunalwahlen, wo es wirklich jetzt darum ging,
niemand kennt hier irgendeine Person, wer AfD wählen darf, will, macht es jetzt einfach.
Er hat jetzt die Möglichkeit und dann kamen sie aber nur so auf 25 Prozent.
Und bei 25 Prozent kann man sagen, okay, das ist ganz schön viel,
aber nach eigener Anschauung sage ich als Geburtstüringer, es haben offenbar
noch nicht alle gewählt.
Überzeugten Neonazis in Thüringen jetzt AfD gewählt.
Also sie schafft nicht mal das, ihr Klientel quasi auszubeuten,
weil sie einfach zu doof ist.
Okay, du würdest sagen, also das Potenzial ist eigentlich höher.
Ja, das liegt locker bei 30 Prozent. Ah ja. Und nicht bei 25.
Das ist ja erschreckend.
Aber das ist ja immer so eine Sache. Wir sehen europäische Zusammenarbeit und
ehrlicherweise ist es so,
wenn die Geldströme durch Europa Meloni so disziplinieren, dass sie im Europäischen
Parlament ihre eigenen Fraktionen dann, also ihre eigenen Leute nicht,
aufwiegeln da irgendwie so ein Trara, macht man hier nur YouTube-Videos und
so, wie die AfD im Bundestag, und auch in den Ministerräten Entscheidungen abfallen,
bei denen man irgendwie so ein Rational rausrechnen kann.
Dann bleibt es bei den faschistischen, neonazistischen, ausländerfeindlichen
Sachen regional begrenzt, Nämlich auf ihr Land.
Und dann müssen die Italiener das einfach selber entscheiden. Also da,
klar, man ist irgendwie immer angeleitet, da irgendwie irgendwo noch so Kontrapunkte
zu setzen und dann macht man eine Aktion auf der Straße hier und eine Veranstaltung
da und versucht irgendwelche Aufklärungssachen,
aber der Lauf der Dinge ist dann einfach,
die Italiener müssen es entscheiden, so wie wir das in Deutschland eben auch
selbst entscheiden müssen.
Wie viel Raumgewinn geben wir jetzt der CDU?
Welche Fernsehdiskussionen ermöglichen wir denn? Und nehmen sie auch einfach so hin als Publikum?
Du hast ja zuletzt, wie im Fernsehen diskutiert wird, also wir haben selten
so viele Zuschriften bekommen, auch aus den Reihen derjenigen,
die sie verantworten, dieser Sendung.
Und das ist ja ein haarsträubender Arbeitsbedarf, der da vorliegt.
Wir werden genau das nochmal ansprechen, inwieweit man dann sagen kann,
das sollen die Italiener entscheiden und dann ist das demokratisch,
wie ist das zu akzeptieren.
Ich verspreche da ein Buch, das sich gewaschen hat, das ich in den Salon mitbringe.
Lass uns noch einen Clip hören und zwar den darüber von Christoph Möllers.
Er war vor einigen Monaten bei Carolin Imke im Süddeutsche Zeitung Podcast zu
Gast und er ist derjenige, der beraten hat bei der Frage, kann man die NPD verbieten.
Und er sagt jetzt als Rechtsphilosoph, Staatsphilosoph etwas sehr Interessantes zur AfD.
Eine wirklich attraktive Sache an der AfD, das kann ich wirklich so sagen,
ist, dass sie ja tatsächlich an Politik glaubt.
Also dass die AfD-Politiker glauben, sie könnten das Land verändern mit politischen Mitteln.
Vielleicht nicht so, wie ich mir das vorstelle, aber sie haben schon diesen
Gestaltungsoptimismus in gewisser Weise.
Das mag man jetzt sagen. Wie gesagt, im Ergebnis kann man daran zweifeln.
Aber diesen Gestaltungsoptimismus sieht man ja bei der Politik.
Der repräsentativen demokratischen Politik auf der anderen Seite eigentlich
gar nicht mehr so richtig. Der ist ja oft sehr defensiv. Und das scheint mir zusammenzuhängen.
Ja und das würde ich total bestätigen. Ich habe die Wahlprogramme ja alle gelesen
jetzt für die Europawahl und es ist fast nur Defensive.
Ich würde schon sagen, bei Linke und BSW ist ein bisschen mehr,
das könnte man verändern, aber da geht es dann wieder um Mehrheiten.
Aber eigentlich ist auch da es sehr viel schwächer formuliert,
weil man schon so weiß an die Gebundenheiten, an die Sachzwänge,
während die AfD einfach mal drauf losschießt und sagt, dann binden wir das mal
wieder ans Gold, unsere Währung.
Also solche, jetzt kann man sagen, das ist ja reiner Irrsinn und das ist natürlich
auch Irrsinn und Möllers lehnt das natürlich genauso ab wie ich.
Nur ist es interessant, dass also da der Politik das noch zugestanden wird,
was die anderen alles nicht machen. Und wenn ich mir anhöre,
jetzt diese ganzen Aufrufe geht zur Wahl, dann ist es ja meistens nur aus der Defensive.
Also das heißt eigentlich nur, bitte verhindert die AfD, aber sonst gibt es
keinerlei irgendwie geartete positive Vision, die mit dieser Europawahl verbunden ist.
Das wird uns auf die Füße fallen, allen voran mit der Abwahl Joe Bidens,
weil das wird einfach eine Abwahl sein.
Und mit ihm kann man Trump verhindern, also das wird nicht ziehen.
Aladin El Mafalani war bei so einer Veranstaltung, da gibt es ein Video,
das er bei Twitter selbst geteilt hat, wie er zehn Minuten lang einfach mal
zahlenmäßig durchgeht, was bedeutet es, dieses Remigrationsding durchzuziehen.
Also wenn man das Programm der AfD nimmt und einfach mal ernsthaft kurz durchkalkuliert.
Und er kommt dann mit allen möglichen Zahlen, die die AfD ja sonst immer benutzt,
um Stress zu machen, wie zum Beispiel 40 Prozent der heute geborenen Kinder
in Deutschland haben Migrationshintergrund, ein der Elternteile hat gar keinen deutschen Pass oder so.
Oder man hat einen deutschen Pass, aber der kam erst so im Laufe des Lebens
dazu, dann zählt man ja auch schon nicht dazu. zu und er geht das dann so durch
und sagt, okay, 24 Millionen Leute, wer ist das eigentlich?
Und er sagt dann, ja, die Rentner sind es nicht. Also da ist der Auslandanteil
einfach nicht nennenswert. So, bei den Kindern, alle raus.
Ärzte, ja, 60% der Hausärzte auf dem Land raus.
So, was bedeutet das eigentlich? Und die Pointen liegen da auf dem Tisch.
Also man muss sie nicht aussprechen. Das ist einfach völlig selbstverständlich,
dass diese Programmatik einfach nicht funktioniert.
Und es ist erstaunlich, mit welcher Vehemenz das aber als ernsthaftes politisches
Angebot, also Goldpreisbindung wäre da noch das Mindeste, die das da einfach durchpauken.
Also es ist wirklich erstaunlich, das dann mal zu hören.
Wir nutzen jetzt die Gelegenheit, um auf den Salon hinzuweisen.
Wie schon angekündigt, will ich da ein Buch vorstellen, das mich wahnsinnig
begeistert hat und zwar von Philipp Mano.
Der beschäftigt sich damit, inwieweit die liberale Demokratie in die Krise geraten
ist und fragt sich, ob das überhaupt eine Krise der Demokratie ist.
Denn dieses Gerede von der liberalen Demokratie ist etwas relativ Neues und
das hängt zusammen mit den Verfassungsgerichten. Und die Aufwertung der Verfassungsgerichte
ist ein Phänomen, das wir auch erst in den letzten 30 Jahren so stark erlebt haben.
Und was bedeutet das eigentlich, wenn andere, und er nimmt die bösen Buben,
Erdogan, Orban etc., das Verfassungsgericht beschneiden.
Und wir haben ja gerade eben auch was besprochen, was das Verfassungsgericht tangiert.
Wir finden das ja eigentlich doof, dass wir so eine Schuldenbremse haben,
die uns so bindet, die also nicht den demokratischen Willen befreit,
sondern ihn domestiziert. Und er kommt da zu sehr vielen kontraintuitiven Schlüssen.
Ich bin sehr begeistert davon, muss das unbedingt dann vorstellen.
Worüber wir aber in aller Ausführlichkeit gemeinsam sprechen,
ist das neue Buch von Richard David Precht.
Das heißt, das Jahrhundert der Toleranz, Plädoyer für eine wertegeleitete Außenpolitik.
Brecht legt hier also das vor, was ihn jetzt in den vergangenen Jahren sehr
beschäftigt hat, nämlich die Frage ….
Muss man einfach diesen Baerbock-Weg folgen, aber irgendwie funktioniert das ja nicht.
Muss man sagen, wir gehen ganz weg von irgendwelchen Werten?
Nee, er nennt es ja Wertegeleitete Außenpolitik und er versucht uns jetzt aufzuzeigen,
was dann diese Toleranz meint.
Also ist das eine Toleranz im Sinne von, ist uns egal, was die anderen machen
oder ist da auch irgendetwas dabei, was vielleicht sogar missionieren sind?
Ich habe es noch nicht gelesen, bin aber sehr gespannt darauf und versuche auch
heute hier im Podcast eine Grundlage dafür zu legen, da ich diese andere Schule
vorstellen will mit den strukturellen Realisten. Mhm.
Ich habe geschaut, es gibt ein Buch, die Sprache des Kapitalismus.
Ich habe schon mal reingelesen. Ich finde, wir sollten es mal heuristisch durchgehen,
auch wenn ich nicht ganz so überzeugt bin, dass es eins zu eins jetzt als Lobgesang zu lesen ist.
Aber die Themensetzung ist natürlich sehr gut. Außerdem bei Gilda Sahebi bei
Lanz und hat dort dem CSU-Typen, der neben ihr saß, einfach gesagt,
ob die jetzt in Sylt, Ausländer raus,
Deutschland den Deutschen singen oder ob ihr sagt,
wenn jemand eine doppelte Staatsangehörigkeit hat und die Deutsche kam dann
eben erst nachträglich während der Biografie schon läuft dazu,
zu, dann können wir das einfach und sei es nur strafrechtlich,
du hast irgendwas getan, dann ist die wieder weg.
Und sie sagt, das ist auf Augenhöhe. Und sie sagt das aber ganz nüchtern,
ganz ruhig und ich fand das so überzeugend an der Methodik, wie sie das macht,
dass ich mir dachte, als ich bin dann so nachgegoogelt, habe ich gesehen,
ah ja, wie wir uns Rassismus beibringen.
Sie hat also ein Buch gerade so auf dem Markt zum Thema Rassismus und üblicherweise,
wenn irgendwo ein Aufklärungsbuch über Rassismus, weiß ich schon.
200 Seiten Präampel und dann nochmal drei interessante Seiten vielleicht.
Ich glaube, diesmal ist es anders. Also wir schauen da mal rein.
Ansonsten, Scott Galloways Buch. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Bücher ich schaffe,
weil jetzt auch gerade eine Veranstaltung nächste Woche geplatzt ist,
weil ich erfahren habe, dass ich da gar kein Honorar und nicht mal Reisekosten kriege.
Deswegen, ich habe viel Zeit zu lesen. Einen Tag mehr Zeit zu lesen.
Vielleicht dieses Buch von Scott Galloway. Ich habe ihn ja immer mal betont.
Aber das ist so ein Investmentbuch.
Ja, es ist so ein Buch über Lebensgestaltung und so weiter. Ich warte ja im
Grunde auf seine Ausarbeitung zum Thema die Jungen.
Ja, ich habe da reingelesen, aber es war eher so, dass ich dachte,
gut, ist bestimmt interessant, wenn ich mal so 10 Millionen gespart habe,
was ich da mit meinem Geld mache.
Also es ist ja so, wir haben ja häufiger hier Bücher, bei denen wir es den Autoren
anerkennen, aber nicht ganz durchgehen
lassen, dass sie auch mal was Populärwissenschaftliches schreiben,
einfach nur um dann mit ihrer Uniprofessur auch mal ein paar Bücher zu verkaufen.
Und das nicht nur für die eigentliche Legitimität zu schreiben.
Von daher, Scott Galloway hat gerade einen spektakulären, vielleicht einen der,
also wirklich der top spektakulärsten TED-Talks gehalten, wo es ja immer so
verdampft auf 15 Minuten ist zum Thema, lieben wir eigentlich unsere Kinder?
Und wenn ja, warum lassen wir ihnen ökonomisch gar keine Luft zum Atmen?
Also er ist eine Anklage gegen die eigene Klasse, die wirklich seinesgleichen
sucht in dieser Deutlichkeit.
Von daher würde ich mich von diesem Buch nochmal überraschen lassen.
Vielleicht schaffe ich es jetzt für diesen Salon, ansonsten liegt das weiterhin noch auf Halde.
Allein deswegen, ja, aber am meisten freue ich mich eigentlich auf Precht,
weil dieser Titel, also ein ganzes Jahrhundert unterzubringen,
mehr als eine Lebenszeit, ist schon mal viel Toleranz.
Eigentlich der größte Streitbegriff gerade, der so im Raum steht irgendwie.
Alle fühlen sich nur noch getriggert und wollen sich irgendwie abarbeiten.
Und wertegeleitet. Wir haben ja auch schon darüber gesprochen,
dass wir uns ja nicht da einreihen, wo sich die Leute lustig machen,
über eine feministische Außenpolitik.
Obwohl es so naheliegend ist, sich über diese feministische Außenpolitik nun
wirklich lustig zu machen. Aber wir vermuten ja, dahinter ist noch irgendwas.
Also vermuten wir ja hinter wertegeleiteter Außenpolitik, vermuten wir ja eigentlich
was. Also wollen wir mal wohlwollend da rangehen und die Sachen rauskramen, die da drin stehen.
Ja, ich bin sehr gespannt darauf. Man kann das dann alles hören.
In der nächsten Woche kommt dann der Salon, aber man kann natürlich jetzt schon ein Abo abschließen.
Und zwar empfehlen wir, dies über Steady zu tun.
Man geht auf unsere Seite neue20er.de, ist auch verlinkt. Und dann kommt man
dort auf den goldenen Salon-Button und kann sich dann eines der drei Pakete raussuchen.
Das ist nur die Frage, inwieweit man den Podcast bereit ist zu unterstützen.
Es gibt also nicht mit einer höheren Zahlung mehr Inhalte, sondern das ist alles
ganz demokratisch für alle gleich.
Also wenn man die teuerste, die dritte Variante nimmt, kann man auf seine Kosten nochmal drei weitere.
Für alle vier wird es dann insgesamt die billigste Option.
Also wenn ihr ein Lesefreundeskreis zu viert seid, dann könnt ihr das machen.
Oder man möchte das weiter verschenken oder Sponsor. Nein, keine Autogrammkarten von Stefan.
Und wir empfehlen also den Salon über Steady zu abonnieren.
Das kostet 2,50 Euro im Monat dann.
Es gibt aber auch noch andere Wege. Wer schon bei Patreon ist,
kann das darüber dann auch tun.
Wer bei Apple ist, kann auch darüber das buchen, ist aber dann etwas teurer,
weil Apple natürlich eine höhere Gebühr verlangt als Steady und Patreon,
aber wem das bequemer ist, der kann das gerne darüber tun.
Das ist die einzige Möglichkeit, den Podcast zu unterstützen und es ist auch
eine sehr gute Möglichkeit, weil es jetzt auch für alle, die jetzt neu abschließen,
natürlich wahnsinnig viele Salons noch zum Nachhören gibt.
Und man kann sich sehr gut, weil immer die Cover wechseln, Stefan macht immer ein neues Cover,
daran orientieren, also welche
Bücher wurden besprochen, also zum Beispiel kann man sich jetzt nochmal,
bevor wir den neuen Precht besprechen, nochmal die Besprechung anhören von dem
Buch, das Precht und Welser gemeinsam geschrieben haben.
Was immer noch aktuell ist.
Ja, das ist ja das Zauber dieses Rufes oder nein, das ist eigentlich das Traurige
unseres Diskurses, dass es immer noch so aktuell ist.
Wir springen jetzt zu einem Thema, das zugleich die Grundlage sein soll für
die Precht-Lektüre, nämlich immer wieder wurden wir auch gefragt,
wie halten wir das denn da mit diesen Realisten?
Du hast wahrscheinlich auch schon jetzt im Laufe der Zeit seit dem Krieg immer
wieder John Mersheimer Videos geschickt bekommen und nun war es tatsächlich
so, dass ich dachte, ja wir greifen das mal auf,
auch deshalb, weil im Deutschlandfunk darüber gesprochen wurde.
Oder also der Deutschlandfunk hat mit John Mörschheimer, einem dieser Vertreter,
ein längeres Interview geführt.
Ich glaube, das muss man nochmal einbetten, denn es ist der Deutschlandfunk-Politik-Podcast,
der ja üblicherweise als Redaktionsgespräch entweder bei einer Veranstaltung,
dann stehen sie in der Lobby des Bundestags und sagen die ganze Zeit,
dass sie jetzt in der Lobby des Bundestags stehen.
Oder sie treffen sich halt so kurz vor Feierabend, wo aber auch alle so im Stress
sind, weil sie ja schnell noch und so. Also es ist immer so eine Hektik.
Diesmal ist es so, dass Stefan Detjen in Amerika war und das Gespräch ja auch
einleitet mit so, ja, wir haben ja noch schnell sein Hotelzimmer umgebaut in
so eine Sitzecke, dass man da so ein Gespräch führen kann.
Also es ist nicht nur inhaltlich so ein bisschen Outer Space,
sondern es ist auch an den Deutschlandfunk herangetragen worden,
weil sich Stefan Detjen dachte...
Nach, was weiß ich, 300 Folgen oder so, müssen wir vielleicht auch mal ausbrechen
aus der einen oder anderen Denkschablone.
Ich fahre mal alleine, ich habe meinen Interviewpartner, ich nehme mal eine
Stunde Zeit, ich bin mal nicht in Berlin. Das merkt man dann auch.
Ja, man sollte sich das auch in Gänze vielleicht nochmal anhören.
Wir steigen aber jetzt erstmal ganz anders ein.
Wir gehen erstmal zu dem Clip zu Precht, nämlich der einen Menschenrechtsexperten
zu Gast hatte, Manfred Nowak und mit ihm diskutiert er darüber,
inwieweit denn das Versprechen, dass die Menschenrechte für alle gelten sollen,
eingelöst ist, was wäre zu tun und ist das nicht eigentlich alles eine große Krise.
Wir wollen uns erstmal über diese Frage der Werte an das Thema annähern.
Jetzt gibt es aus meiner Sicht, aber Sie werden mir erklären,
warum ich da falsch liege, einen Widerspruch zwischen auf der einen Seite gibt
es ein Recht der Staaten auf Nicht-Einmischung.
Gerade China sagt das bei jeder Gelegenheit, immer wenn es kritisiert wird.
Und auf der anderen Seite, wenn Menschenrechte universell gelten und wenn sie
von all diesen Ländern auch unterzeichnet worden sind, dann müssen sie ja doch
irgendwie auch einforderbar sein, auch von der internationalen Staatengemeinschaft.
Bringen Sie mal ein bisschen Licht in das Dunkel. Also wie verhält sich das
Recht auf Nicht-Einmischung der Staaten zum sozusagen normativen Zwang zur Einmischung,
wenn Menschenrechte verletzt werden?
Stimmt, das kennen wir alle. Wenn China sich äußert, dann meistens mit dem Verweis
darauf, dass man sich bitte nicht einmischen soll.
Jetzt wissen wir, in China geht es den Uiguren nicht gut.
Das ist also ein menschenrechtliches Problem. Und da will man sich also doch
einmischen und China versucht aber dann darauf zu verweisen.
China jetzt nun mal herausgegriffen, andere Länder machen das natürlich auch.
Jetzt kommt die Antwort.
Also das Recht auf Nicht-Einmischung ist eines von vielen Prinzipien des Völkerrechts.
Man soll sich nicht ohne irgendwelchen Grund in die Angelegenheiten anderer Staaten einmischen.
Die Menschenrechte sind eine Ausnahme davon.
Das heißt, der Schutz der Menschenrechte
bedeutet immer Einmischung in die innerstaatlichen Angelegenheiten.
Das heißt, was jetzt gerade passiert, dass beispielsweise die Hamas-Führer sowohl
wie auch Netanjahu vom Internationalen Strafgerichtshof angeklagt sind,
ist ja eine Einmischung von außen und ist aber auch gerechtfertigt,
wenn man also dort dringenden Verdacht hat, dass da irgendetwas falsch läuft.
Oder Gefahr im Vollzug ist und der ganze Apparat, der da mobilisiert wird.
Wir haben jetzt mal nicht dieses Thema hier aufgegriffen.
Ich glaube, du hast da auch keine Clips zu mitgebracht, wie das jetzt zu beurteilen
ist, dieser ganze Prozess.
Ich glaube aber, dass das, was wir uns jetzt hier anhören, auf jeden Fall vor
dem Hintergrund dieser Anklage zu sehen ist.
Vor allem, dass Netanjahu angeklagt ist und dass möglicherweise dann in den
nächsten Wochen oder Monaten so ein Haftbefehl rauskommt.
Und das würde ja auch bedeuten, dass Deutschland, wenn Netanjahu hier zu Besuch ist,
ihn verhaften müsste, weil eigentlich der internationale Strafgerichtshof wird
so hoch anerkannt, das ist Teil der wertgeleiteten Außenpolitik,
zugleich kann man sich natürlich die Frage stellen, würde Deutschland Netanjahu verhaften?
Meine Antwort darauf ist natürlich nicht.
Damit das nicht geschieht, gibt es also zwei Möglichkeiten.
Entweder hat man irgendeinen Sonderbeschluss, warum man das nicht macht oder
man sagt Netanjahu einfach, du kannst nicht hier zu uns kommen auf Staatsbesuch,
denn das würde dazu führen, dass wir dich verhaften müssen.
Wir kommen dann in die Bredouille. Wir kommen lieber bei dir vorbei.
Also die Details sind da wirklich wahnsinnig interessant, finde ich.
Aber das denke ich häufiger, wenn ich Ausarbeitungen im FAZ Einspruch Podcast
höre, wo es wirklich auf die juristischen, also in dem Fall ging es wirklich,
wo steht das Komma in diesem Text? Was bedeutet das jetzt?
Und meine kleine Vulgärverkürzung ist ja jetzt, wenn….
Netanyahu in Deutschland ist, bricht das Weltrecht über Deutschland herein und
dann werden Menschenrechte durchgesetzt und Deutschland hat,
also das üblicherweise vorhandene Immunitätsrecht für Staatspräsidenten,
Regierungschefs und so weiter gilt dann nicht.
Und Deutschland hat kein eigenes Gnadenrecht, dass da irgendwie auf Anweisungen
des Bundeskanzleramts reagiert die Polizei nicht oder sowas.
Also das gibt es dann einfach nicht.
Und faktisch gesehen, also juristisch faktisch gesehen, wird Deutschland dann tätig werden müssen.
Deutschland hat die Verträge unterschrieben. Netanjah muss dann ausgeliefert
festgehalten werden, damit er dann da vor Gericht gestellt werden kann.
Die Diskussion, die in Deutschland ja geführt wird, ist ja haarsträubend,
weil da nämlich genau diese Rule-Based-Ordnung aufgehoben wird.
Und am krassesten fand ich das bei Augstein. Augstein hat ein sehr interessantes
Gespräch über die möglichen Zukunft der Israels und des ganzen Raumes dort geführt.
Und referierte dann nur kurz, dass sein Kumpel Blume Blume? Blume. Blume.
Vom damals Spiegel, heute irgendwo. RTL.
Genau, RTL Chef beim Nachrichtenbetrieb. Dass der meinte, wenn es dazu kommt,
dass Netanyahu herkäme, dann wäre ihm dieses ganze Weltrechtszeug egal.
Dann gilt für ihn einfach nur die Lehren des Holocaust.
Wir dürfen Israel nicht beschädigen und da habe ich so gedacht,
jetzt beißen sich alle Paradoxien gegenseitig. Denn.
Es ist eine Folge der Aufarbeitung des Holocaust und so weiter,
dass man überhaupt so eine Weltordnung hat, in der das möglich ist,
ein lokales Recht auszusetzen oder Menschen von außerhalb, also sich in ein
Land einzumischen und zu sagen, ihr müsst ihn jetzt festnehmen.
Also gerade dieser Haftbefehl ist historisch wirklich sehr gut herleitbar aus
diesen Nürnberger Prozessen.
Dass man sagt, okay, ihr habt wirklich hier nicht nur Menschen,
sondern die Menschheit selbst ist euch zu Opfer gefallen und wir stellen euch
jetzt vor Gericht, wir richten jetzt hier ein Gericht ein.
Und dass Blume dann auf so eine Idee kommt, erstmal nur referiert von Augstein,
keine Ahnung, wie er das dann begründet, sowas. Aber da habe ich gedacht.
Okay.
Noch einmal anmahnen, dass es wichtig ist, sicherzustellen, dass und dann kommt irgendwann,
es sollten nicht so schlimme Dinge passieren und das ist so das Höchste der
Gefühle, wie weit man sich herauswagt und dann gleichzeitig zu denken,
dass Netanjau verhaftet wird, ist einfach so ein Kontrast dazu,
dass man sagen wird, ja man würde einen Weg finden,
damit eine solche Verhaftung nicht stattfinden muss und das Einfachste wäre
selbstverständlich, dass Netanjau nie wieder Deutschland besuchen würde.
Ja, zu diesem Pragmatismus würde ich auch sagen, selbst wenn es dieses Gericht
und die Anklage und was auch immer dieses Ersuchen nicht gäbe,
es wäre gerade nicht vorstellbar, dass Netanyahu überhaupt noch einen Staatsversuch
in Deutschland bekommt.
Also in der Hinsicht ist das so eine theoretische Diskussion,
die pragmatisch einfach eh schon abgeräumt war, aber es ist trotzdem erstaunlich,
dass allein weil die Theorie jetzt im Raum steht,
dass das passieren könnte, ganz viele Kommentatoren entweder die Frage aufwerfen,
was tun wir denn dann oder sich wie Blume direkt festlegen.
Und in der Hinsicht, das ist sehr lehrreich.
Vielleicht kommen wir heute noch dazu, zu diesem selektiven Universalismus.
Das ist auch gut, selektiver Universalismus.
Ja, immer dann, wenn man es gerade braucht. Also ich würde sagen,
dieser selektive Universalismus,
jetzt kommen wir schon ein bisschen ab vom Thema, aber der ist doch gerade bei
dem Nordkonflikt oder Krieg mit Händen zu greifen.
Einmal das, was du jetzt beschrieben hast, dass man sagt, nein,
dann internationale Kriegsverbrechen, UN,
was soll das überhaupt eigentlich alles, ja, wo man sich aber noch zwei Jahre
vorher bei Russlands Angriffe auf die Ukraine genau auf das die ganze Zeit bezogen hat.
Das sind alles Menschenrechtsverletzungen und alles Kriegsverbrechen.
Richtig, hat man da gemacht. Zugleich aber würde ich auch der Fairness halber
sagen wollen oder es ist mir ein Anliegen das zu sagen, dass auch der selektive
Universalismus bei einigen Protesten zu erleben ist.
Also es gibt Leute, die protestieren gegen das Leid in Gaza,
die protestieren dagegen, dass
Deutschland weiter Waffen liefert und das finde ich auch alles richtig.
Aber wir haben auch jetzt zum Beispiel an Universitäten gesehen,
dass dann an die Türen von jüdischen Dozenten Hamas-Zeichen geschmiert wurden.
Oder denk an den Eurovision Song Contest, das war sehr interessant.
Ich habe es natürlich auch nicht gesehen, weil ich die Veranstaltung,
die Musik schrecklich finde, aber ich war in Wiesbaden und habe dort Anna Netrebko
gesehen und ich kann sagen, es ist grandios, aber darauf würde ich jetzt nicht
eingehen, aber was fand da statt?
Also vor der Oper Wiesbaden demonstrierten laut dpa 400, ich würde sagen 200
Leute, haben Slava Ukraini gerufen, no Netrebko.
Ich habe mir sagen lassen, Netrebko muss entweder von der Polizei eskortiert
werden oder heimlich in Privatautos durch die Gegend gefahren werden,
damit sie überhaupt in dieses Theater gelangt, weil sonst die Wege blockiert
werden. Ich dachte, mein Gott, was ist das für eine Sache.
Wie falsch ist das, so etwas zu tun? Also was für ein Wahnsinn,
dass man seine Kritik an Putin jetzt an Netrebko raussetzt.
Oder dann muss man vor dem Kanzleramt stehen und sagen, wir demonstrieren hier,
der soll mehr Waffen liefern oder was auch immer. Aber Netrebko,
weil die da früher mal im Kreml aufgetreten ist und so, also das halte ich für völligen Nonsens.
Und dann, einen Tag später ist der ESC und dann demonstrieren Abertausende vor
dem Hotel der israelischen Sängerin und lassen ihre Wut über Gaza.
Über Netanyahus Politik an dieser Frau aus, so als sei die dafür verantwortlich.
Und da muss ich sagen, das hat dann schon eine ganz klar antisemitische Komponente,
wenn man jetzt plötzlich sucht, wer ist jetzt jüdisch oder wer ist israeli und
die müssen jetzt zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden.
Die eine singt, die anderen dozieren an der Uni, möglicherweise vertreten die
Position, die man nicht mag, dann kann man diskutieren und dass das aber dann
in so einer Weise stattfindet, finde ich so falsch.
Und zugleich ist es wieder so, dass die CDU ja und die Bild-Zeitung dann im
ganz Besonderen so tut, als seien alle, die an der Uni gerade demonstrieren,
in Wahrheit Hamas-Unterstützer.
Also das ist ein solcher Wahnsinn, der da stattfindet. Und da sieht man einfach,
dass dieses Prinzip selektiver Universalismus sich längst überall ausgebreitet hat.
Aber gehen wir mal zu diesen Fragen der Menschenrechte. Was ist denn,
wenn Menschenrechtsverstöße stattfinden?
Das war zur Zeit des Kalten Krieges sehr, sehr schwer möglich,
weil das einzige Organ der Vereinten Nationen, das Zwangsmittel hat,
der Sicherheitsrat ist und der war blockiert.
Deswegen hat sich das verändert nach Ende des Kalten Krieges und wir haben klare
Fälle, wo zugunsten von Menschenrechten eben auch der Sicherheitsrat tätig wurde.
In der Erfenbeinküste und in Libyen? Das war später dann mit der Responsibility to Protect.
Wir haben schon vorher, wenn Sie nur denken an Ost-Dima zum Beispiel,
wir haben auch die ganze Zeit nach dem Bosnienkrieg, also während des Bosnienkriegs
hat es leider noch nicht funktioniert, weil das Ganze noch ziemlich neu war
und die europäischen Staaten hier unterschiedliche Spiele gespielt haben.
Also wir merken jetzt schon, ja es gibt dieses internationale Recht,
aber Staaten können ihre eigenen Spiele spielen und dann gibt es so ein Vetorecht,
aber manchmal hat man dann auch tatsächlich diese Verstöße ahnden können.
Jetzt gibt es noch etwas, das verbunden ist mit den Menschenrechten,
nämlich das Gewaltverbot in der UNO-Satzung.
Zum ersten Mal in der Geschichte der Menschheit wurde der Krieg verboten.
Das Gewaltverbot der UNO-Satzung ist ein ganz was Wesentliches.
Und man gesagt hat, wenn ein Staat einen anderen angreift...
Dann ist der Sicherheitsrat gefordert, hier Frieden zu schaffen und wenn das
nicht anders geht, mit einem stehenden Heer der Vereinten Nationen.
Das ist aber nie geschaffen worden. Deswegen hat die NATO ja diese Funktion
übernommen. Da muss man sich auch die Frage stellen, wer finanziert dieses Heer,
wer befähigt dieses Heer?
Ja, da gibt es damals schon viele Überlegungen, ein stehendes Heer,
so wie es es auch ohne Polizei gibt, das kann man ohne Beamte geben.
Der oberste Befehlshaupt ist der Generalsekretär, dann gibt es einen Militärausschuss.
So, das klingt ja alles immer sehr plausibel, aber wir können uns ja jetzt mit
den strukturellen Realisten fragen, ist das realistisch?
Also ist es vorstellbar, dass man ein stehendes Heer hat, das eine solche Macht
ausüben kann, wo die einzelnen Nationalstaaten dann nicht sagen können,
das wollen wir aber jetzt gerade nicht.
Das heißt also, gibt es eine übergeordnete Instanz? Kann es die in dieser Weise
geben, wie das hier ausgemalt wird?
Wir behalten das jetzt also im Hinterkopf und widmen uns den strukturellen Realisten.
Wir tun das zunächst mit Susanne Weige, den Schwiedschrick.
Sie war bei Junge Naiv zu Gast und hat da über China gesprochen.
Sie erklärt erstmal, was struktureller Realismus ist.
Also ich bin ein sogenannter struktureller Realist.
Das heißt also, mich interessieren, wie Länder sich in einem von mir angenommenen
System von internationalen Beziehungen positionieren und wie sie ihre Beziehungen
zu anderen Ländern definieren.
Und zwar unabhängig davon, ob ich jetzt über Länder ähnlicher ideologischer
Ausrichtung nachdenke oder nicht oder ob ich über Länder nachdenke,
die sehr ähnliche Interessen haben oder nicht.
Könnte man eigentlich sagen, das sind einfach Spieltheoretiker?
In gewisser Weise ja. Sie sind Spieltheoretiker, beziehungsweise es sind Analytiker von Strukturen.
Spieltheorie ist ja sehr, sowas wird der andere machen, wenn der eine dies und das tut.
Aber ja, im Prinzip ist es eine Art der Spieltheorie und es ist damit losgelöst
von Werten, von normativen Grundlagen.
Bei mir ist das das erste Mal jetzt untergekommen, also dieses struktureller Realismus.
Klingt ja schon so, als hätte sich jemand Gedanken darüber gemacht,
so eine Schule zu formen, dass man weiß, wann man jetzt im Rahmen dessen ist oder nicht.
Ich habe mich jedenfalls, ich weiß das noch so als Schüler, als ich hörte,
ja, Hitler und Stalin haben dann so einen Pakt geschlossen, dass sie sich nicht angreifen.
Ja. Und ich dachte mir so, warum? Also wie?
Ja.
War da jemand mit im Raum? Wo klagt man das ein, wenn man dann doch überfallen würde, wie auch immer?
Also da liegt so eine gewisse Hanebüchigkeit drin irgendwie,
die so völlig bescheuert ist.
Und seitdem war ja eigentlich klar, ja,
Keine Ahnung, das ist, also ich frage mich, warum das jetzt erst kommt.
Haben wir, wir haben uns ja viel darüber unterhalten im letzten Salon,
Demokratie und ihre Theorie.
Und dann habe ich ja immer versucht, naja, aber diese Theorie ist doch immer
noch Quatsch gewesen. Also eine Demokratietheorie, ja, wir haben Sonntagsreden und der ganze Kram.
Also jetzt hat man so ein Label für strukturellen Realismus.
Und ich höre das gerade zum ersten Mal und denke mir, warum ist das nicht der Ausgangspunkt?
Das ist genau die richtige Frage und die würden sowohl John Mersheimer wie auch
Susanne Weiglin-Schwiedtrick stellen,
nämlich sie hat sich gedacht in den 70er Jahren, als sie studierte.
Habe ich irgendwann als relativ junger Mensch mir die Entscheidung abgerungen,
dass ich die Welt nicht so sehen will, wie ich sie gerne hätte,
sondern dass ich lernen möchte, die Welt zu sehen, wie sie ist.
Und dabei arbeitet sie, und das ist aber, also nur dies, also die Welt zu sehen, wie sie ist.
Und ich will hier deutlich, weil ich werde, also Mörschheimer hat tausende Interviews
jetzt gegeben in den letzten zwei Jahren.
Nicht, dass mir jetzt morgen jemand schreibt, ja, aber der hat das falsch gesehen,
das war mit Yeltsin damals so und der hat dann eine falsche Sicht auf Russland
oder so, das interessiert mich jetzt hier alles nicht.
Und ob ich hier nochmal eine andere Haltung zu China einnehmen würde,
als Weigelin Schwiedrich kann, ich weiß nicht richtig, wie ich den Namen ausspreche,
ist sicherlich zu finden.
Aber ich glaube, diese Haltung zu sagen, ich versuche mal nicht mit meiner Moral
und allem ranzugehen, sondern versuche erstmal zu beschreiben,
wie die Welt ist. Allein die Beschreibung.
Sorgt in einer deutschen Talkshow dafür, dass Strackzimmermann sagt,
ja da sind sie doch, sie Putin-Versteher.
Also da ist es einfach gar nicht möglich, nur zu sagen, ja so scheint es wohl zu sein.
Ich weiß, dass wir hier anfangs, als der Krieg begann, so eine Debatte abgebildet
haben über die Frage, ist das ein Stellvertreterkrieg?
Und dann haben die, die sich auch gerne jetzt in Deutschland so Realisten nennen,
ja, so aus der Masala-Sicherheits-Podcast-Ecke, die wollen natürlich von sowas dann gar nichts wissen.
Also die versuchen realistisch zu sein mit ja irgendwie, wir brauchen so eine
realistische alltägliche Härte, aber auch unsere Moral.
Aber dass man einfach sagt, ja natürlich ist das ein Stellvertreterkrieg,
wird natürlich von so Realisten viel eher erkannt und dann ist davon ja erstmal
gar nichts abzuleiten, außer die Frage,
wie geht man dann damit um, wenn das so ist.
Ja, also bevor du jetzt die Clips spielst und wir uns darauf einlassen,
will ich nochmal markieren, wie schräg und unverständlich ich es finde,
dass es überhaupt einen anderen Ansatz gibt, der, und hier hört man ja,
sie muss erstmal begründen, warum sie da so und so rangeht.
Ich war beim Gespräch von Michel Friedmann, der ja zu jeder Opernpremiere immer
so eine Talkrunde nochmal macht.
Mir ist ja egal, worüber und welcher Anlass. Ihm auch, erstaunlicherweise.
Ja, der Tannhäuser, der Tannhäuser, das war halt zur Premiere des Tannhäuser.
Ich habe ihren Namen gerade nicht parat, aber er hat sich das Thema Sexualität rausgesucht.
Und hatte eine wirklich sehr renommierte Wissenschaftlerin ihm gegenüber,
Die zum Thema Sexualität seit Jahrzehnten und auf allen Kontinenten forscht, lehrt, was auch immer.
Und ich habe selten jemanden akademisch so scheitern sehen am Alltag.
Also dass einfach Fragen kommen, ja aber warum mögen Menschen,
ich nehme jetzt mal mich als heterosexueller Mann, Schwule nicht?
Diese Frage, die hat Friedman so in den Raum gestellt.
Es ist ja eine schöne Provokation.
Und wäre es nicht besser, das.
Klar.
Und es war dann wieder so ein Moment, wo ich dachte, wenn jetzt die strukturellen
Realisten kommen und zwar gerade in so einer Zeit, in der Kriege toben,
Brauchen wir wirklich Kriege, damit vernünftige, mitdenkende Menschen wie Politikwissenschaftler
nicht einfach morgens ihr Haus verlassen und sagen, ich musste mich jetzt in
die Realität mit einem Kind rumschlagen, mit dem Berufsverkehr, mit was auch immer.
Jetzt sitze ich in meinem Büro und mache meine Arbeit und denke mir eine Welt
aus, ist mir doch scheißegal, was in der Realität vorliegt. Ja.
Ich möchte gern normativ durchprügeln, was ich hier als Idee habe.
Dann erinnert man sich irgendwie an Aristoteles und Hannah Arendt und deren
tollste Sinssprüche und schreibt Kalendersprüche auf 50 Seiten Länge.
Ja und du wirst jetzt als zynisch beschrieben, aber wir hatten diese Diskussion
ja auch schon im Salon, wenn wir solche DeGros-Ansätze beschäftigt haben und
dann stellt man sich die Frage, ist das wahrscheinlich,
dass wir, wie wir hier so sitzen, reden oder die,
die uns zuhören, auf 80 Prozent ihres Lohns verzichten, damit man eine Umverteilung
machen kann, damit alle auf der Welt auf einem Standard sind wie ein deutscher
Bürgergeldempfänger und dann sagt man nein. Nein.
Gibt es Beispiele von Ökonomien, die radikal geschrumpft wurden und wo die Menschen glücklich waren? Nein.
Ist es also politisch vorstellbar, dass sowas umgesetzt wird?
Nein.
Aber dann ist es doch vom Tisch. Wäre das irgendwie schön, wenn das dann dadurch alles ökologisch wäre?
Ja, kann sein. Nein, aber das ist doch, und das verstehe ich auch nicht,
dass man einfach, also man kann ja Fiktion schreiben, also es gibt ja tolle
Science-Fiction-Autorien.
Die ganze Zeit, ja. Also ich sehe sehr viele Mörschheimer Clips,
ich kenne nur die vom Deutschlandfunk und es ist nicht nur ein persönliches
Interesse von mir, jetzt mir noch mehr dazu anzuhören und du bietest es uns dankbarerweise da,
sondern ich will auch kurz schildern, dieses Deutschlandfunk-Gespräch gehört
zu haben, war für mich auch erlösend, befreiend.
Endlich hat mal einer irgendeinem vom Deutschlandfunk, und sie haben es dann
auch gesendet, mal den Kopf gewaschen.
Haben sofort auch welche vom Sicherheitspodcast geschrieben,
ja das sei ja unmöglich, hier würde man wieder sehen, wie Mörschheimer und so weiter ist.
Ich habe mir das Originalgespräch angehört, da kann man es in Englisch ganz
hören, es ist eine Stunde lang und daraus sind auch die Clips.
Aber wir gehen erst nochmal zu unserer China-Expertin, sie stellt ihr Dreieck vor.
Und sage, in unserer augenblicklichen Welt gibt es drei Länder,
die nenne ich das strategische Dreieck.
Und diese drei Länder bestimmen im Grunde genommen, so böse das klingt,
über unser Wohl und Wehe.
China, Russland und Amerika, das sind die drei größten Nuklearmächte.
Und die anderen spielen erstmal keine Rolle. Und dann vergleicht sie das jetzt
realitätsangebunden an folgende Konstellation.
Wenn man über ein Dreieck nachdenkt, dann sagt man normalerweise,
also ich bin eine Mutter von drei Kindern und ich weiß, die einfachste Lösung
für meine drei Kinder ist zwei gegen ein.
Also wenn die Kinder was durchsetzen wollen, muss man sich einen Verbündeten nehmen.
Und genau diese Dreierkonstellationen finden jetzt gerade statt.
Das wirkt jetzt wahnsinnig schlicht, aber man kommt damit, glaube ich,
wenn man so draufblickt, erstmal sehr weit.
Man wird nicht alles damit laufend erklären können. Und es gibt natürlich auch
Widerstreitendes und das habe ich jetzt nicht mitgebracht.
Zum Beispiel gibt es ja die, jetzt war ja so der Diskurs sehr stark,
China und Russland paktieren.
Und man würde erstmal sagen, ja klar, die machen jetzt gerade sehr viel und profitieren davon.
Zugleich wissen wir, die chinesische Seitenstraße sollte auch durch die Ukraine gehen.
Die Ukraine hat eine ganz wichtige Funktion. Dieses Projekt ist durch Russlands
Angriff erstmal auf Eis gelegt.
Aber wir haben da wieder eine Dreieckskonstellation, wo man dann sagen kann,
aha, aber was ergibt sich jetzt aus dieser neuen Konstellation des Krieges für die drei Akteure?
Vielleicht können wir ja bei den Clips, wo sie es anbietet, Schritt für Schritt
skeptische Hörer mitnehmen.
Denn ich habe ja eben schon gegrinst, bevor du den Clip gespielt hast,
weil du schon drei Kinder reingeschrieben hast, den Clip-Namen.
Und dieser Bogenschlag aus die drei großen globalen Atommächte,
die also grob überschlagen 1,8 Milliarden Menschen repräsentieren,
werden jetzt auf drei Kinder morgens am Frühstückstisch,
Und jetzt hört man schon die kritischen Stimmen, die sagen, das ist zu einfach
und das muss man differenzierter betrachten.
Und ich sage, nein, wir brauchen hier eine allgemein verständliche Heuristik,
wir brauchen eine Approximationshoffnung.
Und ein, nicht ein Verständnis, sondern eine Sensibilität dafür,
dass auch die Atommächte von 1,8 Milliarden Menschen von Menschen regiert werden.
So, wir haben es hier wirklich mit drei, keine Kinder, aber Menschen zu tun. Joe Biden, Xi, Putin.
Wenn jetzt jemand kommt, nee, wir brauchen eine ganz komplizierte Theorie,
wir müssen davon abstrahieren, dann sagen wir, ne, diese ganze Idee der,
wir haben hier drei Atommächte, wie sie sagt, kommt daraus geboren,
dass wir drei Atommächte haben.
Nicht vier und auch nicht eine andere Basis als Atommächte, sondern es sind drei Atommächte.
Und warum sollte man jetzt nicht einfach da ansetzen und sagen,
es ist wie in der guten alten Gesellschaft, also die gute Gesellschaft,
am Hofe kommt es darauf an, ob die Interaktion gelingt.
Wenn ja, ist alles gut. Wenn nicht, ist Krieg.
Ja, so, aber drei Leute dahin reiten einander. Oder nicht.
Die deutsch-französische Freundschaft beruht sehr stark darauf,
dass sich die beiden Staatsoberhäupter gut verstehen.
Und wenn sie sich nicht gut verstehen, dann ist das ganze Gefüge in Gefahr.
Ja, wir haben das Buch von Patrick gelesen. Die Autobranchen,
die jeweils wichtigen Branchen des Landes, schlagen sich kurz und klein und
stehen in einem echten Krieg.
Ja.
Aber für uns ist nur entscheidend, ob sich Chirac und Kohl die Hand geben.
Das ist alles.
Ja. Wir hören weiter.
Der Herr Putin, nach meiner Analyse, hat unter anderem auch deshalb zum Mittel des Krieges gegriffen,
weil er gemerkt hat, oh, das ist ja interessant, diese Amerikaner und die Chinesen,
die stehen zwar in starker Konkurrenz miteinander, aber die überlegen gerade,
ob sie sich nicht die Welt so ein bisschen teilen können.
Die eine Hälfte für China, die andere Hälfte für Amerika. Und wo sitze ich dann
mit meinen ganzen Nuklearwaffen?
Ich bin doch die größte Nuklearmacht der ganzen Welt.
Und die reden gar nicht über mich.
Und seitdem der Herr Putin diesen Krieg gegen die Ukraine begonnen hat,
ist interessanterweise ja so, dass niemand wagen würde zu sagen,
ja eine zukünftige Welt, da brauchen wir doch über Russland nicht nachzudenken.
Wir hören ja jetzt aus einem dreistündigen, sehr hörenswerten Gespräch nur einzelne
Clips, aber wir bekommen Verständnis für diese Art des strategischen Denkens.
Sie buchstabiert das dann noch weiter aus.
Nach meiner Auffassung ist die Veränderung der Weltordnung eine ganz wichtige
Zielsetzung, die er interessanterweise mit dem Mittel des Krieges herbeiführen will.
Da würde man sagen, warum eigentlich, wieso kann man das nicht anders lösen?
Das ist immer so, dass Länder, die sich im Hinterhalt fühlen,
zum Beispiel auch Japan im 19.
Jahrhundert, zu dem Schluss kommen, dass es keinen anderen Weg gibt,
die anderen Länder dieser Welt
davon zu überzeugen, dass man ihnen zuhören muss als den militärischen.
Das ist natürlich eine fatale Logik, die hier beschrieben wird und wir,
bei allem Respekt für diesen Blick auf die Geopolitik, ist es natürlich etwas
sehr Trauriges, dem man so beiwohnt.
Denn auch wenn das ein schönes Bild ist mit den Kindern, also man ist quasi
launenausgesetzt, aber man selbst ist ja machtlos in dem Sinne.
Also ich kann nicht sagen, wir machen es jetzt folgendermaßen,
sondern man ist dem ausgesetzt, diesem Gefüge und deswegen muss natürlich immer
diese Utopie und das negiert sie im Übrigen auch nicht da sein,
gäbe es denn noch eine ganz andere Möglichkeit.
Also könnte man doch irgendwas jenseits dieser nationalstaatlichen Dreiecks organisieren oder so.
Aber das ist etwas, was jetzt nicht die strukturellen Realisten beschäftigt,
was uns aber natürlich beschäftigen sollte, weil man natürlich sagen kann,
also dann kann man immer nur hoffen.
Also dann kann man jeden Abend beten, dass die Herrscher sich auch morgen noch gut vertragen werden.
Ja, aber das ist nun mal die Logik.
Wir sind denen ausgeliefert. Das ist die Logik, genau. Und das ist aber,
verschließt jetzt nicht alles Utopische, aber ich glaube, wenn man das heute
und auch noch das morgen besprechen will, dann kann man das nur so sehen,
dass man denen ausgeliefert ist.
Jetzt gibt es ja diese Rede davon, dass Putin Imperialist ist,
ein neuer Imperialist, Scholz gebraucht das Wort, aber auch viele andere,
will also Putin sehr viel mehr erobern, steht der jetzt bald vor Berlin,
wie das ja jetzt gerade in der Aufrüstung ist.
Was die deutsche Hysterie ja so treibt. Ganz richtig. Wenn diese Gefahr als,
ach nee, doch nicht, dann sieht alles ganz anders aus.
Also dann werden Corona-Maßnahmen von heute auf morgen fein gelassen und dann
gibt es auch doch keine Impfpflicht, obwohl doch alle so dafür waren und so.
Du hast ja eben schon uns von Truppenstärken und Demografie einiges gesagt, wir hören jetzt mal her.
Diese Logik wird, glaube ich, bei uns im Augenblick ein bisschen wenig diskutiert.
Sondern man denkt immer, Russland will die ganze Welt erobern und solche Sachen.
Das ist meiner Meinung nach nicht der Fall. Zumindest in Europa, ja.
Ja, also es gibt ja Leute, die haben gar nicht die Kapazität.
Die müssen ja nicht nur uns erobern, die müssen uns ja auch besetzen.
Und wenn man jetzt mal überlegt, dass die Chinesen meinen, dass sie 500.000
Soldaten brauchen, um so einen kleinen Ort wie Taiwan zu besetzen.
Wie viele Soldaten braucht Herr Putin, um uns alle zu besetzen?
Also für Frankfurt alleine würde ich sagen 100.000. Darunter wäre das nicht
zu machen. Man muss ja jede Straßenecke irgendwie sagen, ich bin der neue Landesherr und so.
Sonst geht hier einfach weiter Berufsverkehr und es interessiert niemanden.
So wie auch so niemanden interessiert, was die Politik hier gerade macht.
Wir springen jetzt schon einmal vor zum Mörschheimer, der kommt nämlich auch
auf die Truppenstärke zu sprechen.
Weil die Sowjetunion die oberste Seite Polens fangen würde.
Also kamen die Deutschen in Polen am 1. September 1939, um es zu überwinden
und es in eine größere Deutschland zu inkorporieren, mit 1,5 Millionen Truppen.
Ja und daraus schlussfolgert er dann auch, dass es also nicht sehr wahrscheinlich
ist, dass Putin bald in Deutschland auf der Matte steht. Nun gehen wir noch einmal.
Da finde ich übrigens, also demografisch, man kann ja mal alle Kategorien,
also das ist jetzt erstmal nur Truppenstärke.
Beim Thema, was ist, wenn jetzt, so wie vorhin beschrieben, dieser Ukraine-Krieg
überwunden ist. Ich will nicht sagen beendet irgendwann.
Einfach nur so überwunden im Sinne von, ja, das ist jetzt so eingehegt wie nach 2014.
Wenn wir jetzt sagen, 1,5 Millionen, so viel haben ja die Chinesen.
Ja, aber die Chinesen sind auch tausende Kilometer weit weg.
Also es sind auch wieder so Kategorien, wo man auch wieder von ihnen so einen Spruch hätte.
Also die können sich gar nicht in Bewegung setzen, ohne dass man das sieht.
Und so weiter. Also lauter solche Sachen. Dass mal eine Rakete die ukrainische
Grenze nach Polen, da haben wir gesehen, was das schon bedeutet und so.
Wie dann alle miteinander erstmal telefonieren müssen. Also es gibt hier ganz
viele Kategorien, zu denen man nichts anderes sagen kann, als einfach mal realistisch drauf geguckt.
Bei Arte, mit offenen Karten. Das ist so erstaunlich, wenn man sich die Weltkarte
anschaut und mal nicht dieses mega lang gezogene Russland, sondern einfach mal
so groß, wie es wirklich ist.
Und dann sieht man, ach so, Afrika.
Afrika, wir sollten eigentlich nur über Afrika nachdenken, weil das einfach
zehnmal so groß ist wie Europa und wir immer die ganze Zeit dieses eurozentrische Weltbild und so.
Also es gibt so ganz viele Kategorien in diesem strukturellen Realismus,
hoffe ich, die man da einfach mal mobilisieren könnte, wo es dann jedem wie
dem Schuppen von den Augen fällt, der jetzt so eine Hysterie die ganze Zeit fährt.
Gehen wir nochmal zu Frank Nowak, dem Menschenrechtsexperten bei Precht.
Der wird auf den Nahostkrieg angesprochen und sieht durchaus die Möglichkeit,
dass aus der UNO so ein Weltschiedsrichter werden könnte.
Also halten Sie tatsächlich für denkbar, dass wir in den nächsten Jahrzehnten
in eine solche Entwicklung gehen können, die die UNO wirklich zu einem ernstzunehmenden
Weltschiedsrichter machen könnte?
Ich glaube nicht in Jahrzehnten, ich glaube schon viel früher.
Ich glaube zum Beispiel, dass der derzeitige Krieg Israels gegen die Hamas in
Gaza eine große Chance für die UNO wäre,
hier wirklich wieder aktiv zu werden, wenn die USA bereit sind,
ihr Vetorecht aufzugeben.
Sie haben das bei der letzten Sicherheitsratsresolution schon getan.
Sie haben damit ein deutliches Zeichen gesetzt.
Aber sind die USA oder ist irgendein Land aus diesem Dreieck,
können wir auch fragen, bereit, sich zurückzunehmen?
Also wenn wir jetzt in dieser Dreieckslogik bleiben, dann ist das der absolute
Kontrast dazu und deswegen spiele ich es natürlich auch.
Also das wäre ja wünschenswert, was jetzt Manfred Nowak uns hier schildert und
Precht kann das auch nur nochmal so bestätigen, er fasst das gesamte Gespräch mit ihm zusammen.
Also Ihre Vorstellung, dass die UNO als Phönix aus der Asche aus dem Nahostkonflikt
aufsteigen könnte und dass sie eine wichtige und unverzichtbare Rolle dabei spielen könnte,
den Übergang hin zur multipolaren Weltordnung friedlich statt durch Kriege zu
lösen, ist eine so schöne Vorstellung,
dass ich sie gerne mit Ihnen teilen würde. Ja.
Also, was wir hier übersehen ist, die deutsche Blickrichtung auf die UN,
so wie wir gerade an der Seite Israels stehen,
kann gar nicht in den Blick nehmen, erstens, wie sehr dieser Gaza-Krieg gerade
die nicht nur muslimische Welt, die allein schon zwei Milliarden Menschen sind,
sondern darüber hinaus aufwühlt, also wirklich bewegt einfach,
schon allein, weil man da andere Reports kriegt von vor Ort,
man sieht einfach anderes.
Von Gaza und vor allem Rafa. Und.
Alles, was daraus erwachsen würde, also dass sich Länder zusammenschließen und
dann auch miteinander schon vereinbaren, so du nimmst jetzt diese Menschenrechtsklage,
du nimmst die und so weiter und dann baut sich das alles so zusammen.
Dass das gegen die deutsche Sichtweise organisiert wird.
Also dass gerade die, wie nennen wir es, den globalen Süden und so,
dass der globale Süden sich gerade politisch gegen uns da mobilisiert.
In welche Richtung, keine Ahnung. Aber diese Idee, warum nicht?
Europa könnte ja noch eine Rolle spielen.
Macron hat es ja jetzt ganz deutlich gemacht. Er hat ja wirklich explizit gesagt,
ich bin bereit, die französische Atomabwehrkraft auf europäischem Niveau neu zu denken.
So, dann kam natürlich wieder Pistorius und so weiter, nee, wir haben doch die
Amerikaner und so, ja, das wurde wieder runtergespielt.
Aber angenommen, das würde wirklich verknüpft mit so einem ganz großen,
Europa spielt sich jetzt weltweit mal wieder ein bisschen auf,
denn ich habe mir jetzt die Tage mit meinem kleinen Sohn die Weltkarte angeschaut
und so und dann war echt die Frage, warum ist Europa ein eigener Kontinent? nennen.
Also man sieht das so und denkt, ja, ich kann es ja nicht erklären.
Die ganz fundamentalen Säulen angerissen.
Naja, aber da ist so eine kleine Landzunge, die halb so groß ist wie Indien
oder so und die sagt dann, ich bin Europa.
Warum? Also es ist, wenn du sagst, guck mal, das ist Afrika,
das ist Südamerika, das ist Nordamerika, das ist Europa.
Verstehe ich nicht. Warum? Also es ist doch nur so eine kleine Ecke an Asien
oder so. Ja, also da sind so große Fragen.
Und wenn wir jetzt so eine Mobilisierung im Geiste, weil es einfach so viele
Leute bewegt, was da in Gaza passiert und dass es aber getrieben ist.
Von so einem eurozentrischen Denken, dass man die UN da irgendwie mal so marginalisiert
und dann mal so über dem Recht steht und es einfach so zulässt,
obwohl man doch Errungenschaft hätte.
Und wenn Europa jetzt so einen Schritt ginge zu sagen, okay,
also diese Abwehrsache wegen Putin machen wir jetzt mal europäisch und im Zuge
dieser Diskussion wird aber auch dieser französische Sitz im Sicherheitsrat
mal so europäisiert, so eine Rule-Based-Sache unterworfen.
Da macht sich Europa wieder adressierbar für Anliegen, dass nicht Südafrika
über den Umweg irgendwelche Rechts und so,
sondern nee, dass einfach mal ein südafrikanischer Präsident vielleicht mal
in Europa eine Adresse hat zum Vorsprechen und dann einfach solche Fragen mal diskutiert.
Ja, das wäre ja alles möglich, wenn Europa als Kontinent das erste Mal dieses
Prinzip aufhebt, dass in der UN so Länder gegeneinander,
sondern nee, es kommt jetzt mit Europa auch ein europäischer Ideenraum,
der die ganze Zeit diskutiert wird oder wie auch immer.
Also wäre schon möglich, dass jetzt viel Bewegung da ist, vielleicht wirklich wünschenswerter als,
und man hört ja auch an mir, wie ich es sage, so wie Precht,
dass man sagt, die Idee alleine ist so gut, dass wir sie jetzt nicht verteufeln,
weil irgendwer wieder mal ein Schlaumeier sein will. mit einem besseren politischen Argument.
Wir halten dem zwar jetzt gleich den harten Realismus entgegen,
wollen aber sagen, ja, das ist eine sympathische Idee, wenn gleich ich noch
eine weitere Gefahr sehe.
Und ich möchte nicht missverstanden werden, ich bin absolut für eine Waffenruhe
und war das auch schon vor vielen Monaten.
Und auch schon vor, dass andere Leute jetzt plötzlich auch mal fordern.
Aber was ich auch sagen würde, oder was mein Verdacht ein bisschen ist,
Heißt, dass sich einige Länder jetzt gerade auf Israel und auch einige Menschen
sehr auf Israel einschießen,
was nicht nur jetzt mit dem realen Leid, das die israelische Regierung verursacht,
zu tun hat, sondern auch darüber hinaus, dass man sagt,
naja, wir mögen die eh nicht.
Und ich will das jetzt gar nicht mit all den großen Begriffen versehen,
aber ich sehe da gewisse Doppelstandards.
Und ich habe ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass wenn das mit Israel jetzt meinetwegen
alles mal so vollzogen wird und Netanyahu einen Haftbefehl bekommt,
dass es nicht unbedingt dazu führen wird, dass man mit anderen Ländern dann
auch entsprechend umgeht.
Also ob daraus, aus diesem, ich sehe das Leid in Gaza, protestiere dagegen,
ob daraus ein Universalismus per se erwächst, da bin ich mir zumindest bei vielen
Ländern, naja, wie soll ich es ausdrücken, also ich bleibe skeptisch da.
Und würde sagen, dass man eher sagt, na Gott sei Dank, jetzt haben wir hier
unseren Sündenbock und es ist auch so, dass Israel da ja ganz falsch handelt,
das will ich hier nochmal unterstreichen, aber ich.
Sehe auch sehr viel Wegschauen bei anderem und bin skeptisch.
Also meine Tendenz wäre eher, dass es sein kann, dass der Eurozentrismus geschwächt wird.
Und er hat es auch eigentlich verdient, weil es wirklich so eine verquere Situation
und Diskussion in Deutschland ist und sowas.
Aber ich glaube nicht unbedingt, dass daraus etwas so viel Besseres erwächst.
Ja, aber so wie du jetzt sagst, manche leben jetzt einfach einen Antisemitismus
aus und den gibt es ja auch staatlich organisiert, also nicht nur Iran, würde ich sagen.
Aber vielleicht ist allein, dass der Vorwurf im Raum stehen kann,
hier antisemitisch zu handeln, ein Katalysator dafür, umso mehr zu betonen,
nein, ich will auf die Rule-Based-Ordnung abstellen.
Das wäre gut.
Und damit stärkt man sich dann wieder.
Ja, das wäre gut und zu wünschen.
Wir gucken uns aber jetzt mal ganz kurz an, was Multipolarität,
weil das war ja jetzt gerade so diese Idee, Multipolarität funktioniert so,
dass man da so einen Weltschiedsrichter hat in Form der UNO.
Multipolarität wird von China anders verstanden.
Also die chinesische Position ist meiner Meinung nach folgende.
Einigen wir uns doch mit den Amerikanern darauf, dass wir im Augenblick keinen
Krieg gegeneinander führen wollen.
Damit haben wir ein bipolares System an der Spitze unserer Weltordnung geschaffen.
Das sind zwei sehr starke Mächte, die auch sehr unterschiedlich sind,
sehr unterschiedliche Verbündete haben.
Die einen gehen zu den Chinesen ins Bett, die anderen gehen zu den Amerikanern
ins Bett und die achten darauf, dass die Mäuse nicht auf dem Tisch tanzen.
Ja, so, aber eine Etage drunter, da können wir jetzt die vielen Länder,
die auch so gerne mitregieren wollen, die könnten wir da aufnehmen.
Wir könnten Indien aufnehmen, Japan, wir könnten die EU oder vielleicht sogar
Deutschland aufnehmen und so weiter.
Ja, und dann ist das aber so, dass diese Volatilität dieser Länder,
die wir da auf dem, ich sag immer, am Platz der Multipolarität aufnehmen,
diese Multipolarität,
die können wir dadurch sozusagen regieren, dass wir ja die zwei da oben haben,
die immer acht geben, dass es da unten an diesem Tisch nicht zu viel Krach gibt.
Das heißt, diese zwei entmachten sich nicht und das ist immer diese Kernthese
von den Realisten, Menschenrechte, alles gut und schön, aber wer setzt sie durch,
wer kann sie auch übertreten und wer entscheidet dann, wo was geahndet wird.
Es sind die, die am mächtigsten sind.
Es ist das Dreieck oder es wäre dann in dieser Idee, die den Chinesen vorschwebt, wären es zwei.
Und ähnlich sehen das eigentlich auch die USA mit so einer Bipolarität,
aber eigentlich mit dem langfristigen Ziel, dass es wieder eine Unipolarität
gibt, nämlich dann eine amerikanisch geführte Welt.
Wir hören nochmal zum Sicherheitsrat was.
Und das ist meiner Meinung nach das Bild, was der Xi Jinping sich vorgestellt hat.
Und das ist so ein bisschen ähnlich, wie auch der Völkerbund sich die Welt vorgestellt hat.
Dass man eben sozusagen diese Organisationen der Multilateralität,
wie jetzt die UNO, dass man die hierarchisch organisiert.
Und wenn man sich die UNO im Augenblick anschaut, dann weiß man ja ganz genau,
dass der UNO-Sicherheitsrat zum Beispiel Dinge entscheiden kann,
die die Generalversammlung nicht entscheiden kann.
Und dass es innerhalb des UNO-Sicherheitsrates zum Beispiel Länder gibt mit
Vetorecht, die entscheiden können, was andere nicht entscheiden können.
Also die Frage ist, wird dieses Dreieck, das sie anfangs beschrieben hat,
jetzt möglicherweise aufgelöst, wie das Frank Nowak möchte, dass da eine höhere Instanz da ist?
Oder bleibt dieses Dreieck, oder wird es eine Bipolarität, aber eigentlich bleiben
die Machtverhältnisse an den Nationalstaat verquickt?
Ja, das ist so, würde John Mersheimer sagen.
Und jetzt hören wir dieses Interview, das Stefan Däthchen im Deutschlandfunk
geführt hat. Erstmal die Frage, was ist denn so ein Realist?
Und diese Balance hat jetzt ja eben schon die China-Expertin beschrieben, indem sie sagt,
ja, dieses Dreieck, die müssen schon mal rivalisieren, Aber die sind sich jetzt
gerade zumindest einig, dass zwischen ihnen direkt kein Krieg ausmacht.
Ist eigentlich ganz interessant. Hier wird ein bisschen deutlich,
warum man überhaupt so einen strukturellen Realismus, ich bleibe mal bei diesem
Grundbegriff, braucht.
Und vor allem für die Beobachtung von außen.
Also hier gibt es ja, klar sind Amerikaner, aber wir hören ja schon,
es wird über China gesprochen und so weiter. Weil wenn du nur eine Hegemonie
hast, also einer regiert die ganze Welt, dann kann der sich selbst verherrlichen.
Und dann wäre auch völlig erklärbar oder verständlich, warum der sich die ganze
Zeit so Bücher schreiben lässt, in denen er nochmal und so weiter und ich bin der große Xerxes,
ich bin der große Xi und dann gibt es eine App mit einer KI,
die einem nochmal das rote Buch aufschlüsst oder wie auch immer.
Da kann man alles verherrlichen.
Aber wenn es darum geht, dass zwei oder drei,
bei vier wird es auch schon wieder kritisch und dann hat er eben gesagt, eine Balance finden,
und dann ist es die Macht, die muss immer neu ausgehandelt werden,
Macht auch als Drohmacht und die rote Linie ist dann Gewalt,
also man droht nur und da,
also dieser Denkraum, dass der in Deutschland so gar nicht offen ist,
dass man zum Beispiel sich auch nicht fragt.
Okay, China schlägt in seiner Region über die Stränge. Da werden Militärübungen in Taiwan abgehalten.
Da wird dieses südchinesische Meer erstmals oben benannt, das südchinesische
Meer. Dann fahren da so Boote, dann bauen da irgendwelche Inseln.
Und immer denkt man, ja, die sind auf dem Weg, sich selbst zum Hegemon zu machen.
Die wollen Amerika überflügeln.
Während gleichzeitig in so einer Denke, wie er das sich vorstellt,
Amerika ein Interesse daran hat, dass es einen Adressaten gibt.
Also wenn wir schon nicht der Hickelmann der ganzen Welt sind,
Amerika, dann noch wenigstens nur ein Adressaten.
Also könnte man sogar eine amerikanische Politik verstehen, die sagt,
wir lassen China insoweit diese Region dort kontrollieren, dass wir uns nicht
auch noch mit Indien rumschlagen müssen, sondern das soll China regeln.
So, während in Deutschland dann kommentiert wird, also die Chinesen,
die schlagen jetzt völlig über die Stränge und dann müssen auch die Amerikaner
mal aufpassen und das wird die nächste große, wie dann Tu sagt,
schießende Auseinandersetzung, China gegen Amerika,
obwohl es eigentlich auch im amerikanischen Interesse ist, dass wenn man Apple
da irgendwie, man braucht eine Million Mitarbeiter und so weiter und dann gibt
es plötzlich einen Konflikt zwischen, sollten die jetzt nicht besser in Indien arbeiten?
Nee, das will man ja gar nicht. Also man will es ja da auch verständlich,
einfach, überschaubar. das ist ja wie bei allen kleinen, kleinen Diskussionen.
Das Wichtigste ist nicht, dass alle irgendwie Geld haben oder so oder möglichst
viel, sondern dass es so eine Perspektive gibt, dass es geregelt ist,
dass man eine Adresse hat, wenn man mal ein Problem hat und so weiter und so fort.
Also auf das mal so runtergedampft, nimmt man mit diesem strukturellen Realismus
schon ganz schön viel Dampf, der ansonsten durch so Verherrlichungs- und Verklärungs...
Ich würde jetzt sagen, Historien statt Heuristiken. und dann plötzlich ist Putin
der, der die ganze Zeit die ganze Welt erobern möchte.
Dann kommt dieser um die Ecke und kann sagen, locker. Das ist eigentlich super gut.
Er sieht aber auch ein großes Problem jetzt in der amerikanischen Politik.
Also Biden ist jemand, der auch idealistisch arbeitet und nicht realistisch arbeitet.
Wir hören uns jetzt mal an, also wie sieht denn die Welt eigentlich aus?
Also wenn man jetzt mal aus den nationalstaatlichen Logiken rausgeht,
wenn man jetzt von außen drauf blickt.
Between what happens inside a society
or in domestic politics on one hand and the international system on the other
hand is that inside a society you have a higher authority that you can turn to for protection.
It's called the state. You have hierarchy inside states.
In the international system You do not have hierarchy. You have no higher authority.
Und wir können jetzt nicht sagen, ja, wenn das jetzt um die Welt geht oder um
Nationalstaaten, die bestraft werden müssen, dann geht es nicht so leicht,
dass man sagt, Manfred Nowak soll sich bitte darum kümmern. Schlussfolgerung?
Authority that can rescue them, what is the best way to guarantee that you survive?
And the best way to survive is to be powerful, to be more specific,
to be more powerful than all your neighbors.
Because the more powerful you are, the less likely it is that another state
will attack you and threaten your survival.
Das ist eigentlich wahnsinnig interessant, weil wir ja den Krieg immer unter
Eroberungsgesichtspunkten gesehen haben. Also jemand erweitert seinen Handlungsspielraum
durch eine Eroberung und wie macht er das? Naja, militärisch.
Und wenn man sich jetzt fragt, was gibt es denn zu erobern?
Die Chip-Fabriken, ne, die gibt es nicht zu erobern. Also die werden nur zerstört.
Krieg erobert nicht mehr, Krieg zerstört einfach nur noch.
Und seine Frage, wie garantiert man jetzt, ich würde sagen, so ein friedliches Zusammenleben?
Naja, alle haben so viel.
Werte, die einfach nur zerstört würden durch Kriege und nicht erobert,
also die kriegt man nicht zurückerobert oder so, die sind dann einfach zerstört,
dass darüber einfach so eine Kostenkalkulation anfängt.
Und das hat man ja jetzt immer durchkalkuliert. Also es gibt ja wirklich diese,
ab wann im Vergleich zu was kostet ein Krieg, würde es sich rechnen,
Taiwan einfach softpowermäßig zu übernehmen.
Durch hier mal die Wahl beeinflussen, da mal irgendwie und dann wird halt in
30 Jahren einfach der Stadthalter oder wie auch immer der Ortsbürgermeister
chinesischer Herkunft sein oder sowas.
Und dass das ernsthaft durchkalkuliert wird und es da so Jahreszahlen in der
Diskussion gibt, ich glaube, ich habe eine bei Lanz und Brecht da im Podcast
gehört, das finde ich schon erstaunlich.
Und es ist so ein bisschen, wie wir es eigentlich in vielen Diskussionen haben beim Thema Klima,
manche Länder der Welt gehen so richtig unter, wenn sich die Welt da nicht einigt,
dass man über den letzten Hierarchien der Staaten nochmal was regelt.
Nur Deutschland ist trotz allem mehr betroffen vom Klimawandel,
weil hier einfach mehr kaputt gehen kann. Und das ist ja jetzt auch eingesickert in die Diskussion.
Nur haben wir ja nicht diese Hierarchie darüber.
Also die Hierarchie ist innerhalb der Nationalstaaten und dann vielleicht noch in diesen Verbündeten.
Die haben auch nochmal eine Hierarchie. Also sicherlich kommen erst die USA
in der NATO und dann kommen die anderen Länder.
Aber es gibt nicht noch mal eine Hierarchie darüber.
Nur in Europa.
In Europa, genau. Aber über Europa dann nicht noch mal was Eigenes. Und das bedeutet...
Ja, da kommt jetzt so langsam der Einspruch. Wie ist denn das jetzt mit dem Naturzustand?
Der herrscht also vor, da gibt es keinen Leviathan.
Wenn man jetzt einen Weltschiedsrichter hätte, wie Manfred Nowak das gerne hätte,
dann könnte man sagen, doch, da ist ja einer.
Ist aber nicht da, würde auch bedeuten, dass die Nationalstaaten freiwillig
sich selbst binden, festbinden und Souveränität abgeben.
Ist das wahrscheinlich hier wieder jetzt die Frage, die sich Realisten stellen?
Realisten sagen nein. Er sagt jetzt zu den internationalen Institutionen.
Ja, wir haben ja jetzt immer so häufig gehört, der völkerrechtswidrige Angriffskrieg,
wo da sind wir nochmal betont, dass
Putin sich nicht an Rechnung Gesetz gehalten hat. Ja, weil er es kann.
Und Irakkrieg hat stattgefunden, weil sie es können.
Und nicht, weil man erst nochmal sich irgendwo was einholen muss oder so.
Man macht es dann einfach, wenn man das auch noch bekommt, wenn dann auch noch
irgendein Sicherheitsrat oder so noch ein Okay gibt, auch geht es gut.
Aber eigentlich macht man, was man kann, wozu man die Macht hat.
Ich finde es ganz wichtig, dass die strukturellen Realisten, um bei mir,
den ja, wie ich eben schon darstellte, etwas höheren, ich erkenne das sehr an
als Theorie und Grundlagenbasis, nur dann will ich das auch realistisch in der
Gegenwart verortet haben.
Ich will da nicht sowas hören mit Hobbes und Leviathan und was in alten Büchern steht.
Ich will das bei den einen nicht hören mit Hannah Arendt und hier und so weiter.
Aber er bringt eine schöne Metapher.
Es ist so.
Ja, es ist eine tolle Metapher.
Nein, es ist ein Naturzustand.
Ja, aber er hat ja gerade in diesen Clips zwei Möglichkeiten gehabt.
Entweder uns nochmal was von Hobbes Naturzustand Leviathan zu erzählen oder
die UN hat einfach keine Zähne.
Warum bleiben wir nicht einfach bei die UN hat keine Zähne?
Naja, weil der Begriff des Naturzustandes glaube ich schon sehr wichtig ist, um zu begreifen.
Also natürlich ist das ja auch eine Fiktion der Politologie, die es aber braucht,
damit man beschreiben kann, wie ist also ein Zustand ohne Staat und wir sind
im zwischenstaatlichen Bereich,
weil es keinen übergeordneten Staat gibt, eigentlich wieder in einem Art Naturzustand,
wo der Stärkere gewinnt.
And the Russians and the Chinese all agree.
Es gab aber mal so einen Moment, wo man unipolar agieren konnte.
Und das war zwischen 1990 und 1990.
Und 2017. Da war Ende der Sowjetunion und man konnte jetzt schalten und walten.
China war noch nicht stark genug und dann hatte man diesen unipolaren Moment.
Dieser Punkt, der kommt so versteckt, aber jetzt wo du die Zeitmark nennst,
ja, vor 1990 haben sich einfach zwei Hegemons gesehen, die sich die ganze Zeit verherrlicht haben.
Und wir machen uns so lustig darüber, wie diese Geschichtsbücher aus dem Sozialismus
aussehen. Dass sie erstmal zehn Seiten Präabel und so weiter und so fort,
Ja, und es ist auf der anderen Seite genauso.
Ja, klar.
Wir schleppen diese Erben der, die Demokratietheorie und hier und die Grundgesetzfeier.
Und das ist das Beste, was Deutschland je hervorgebracht hat. O-Ton Steinmeier.
Das sind auch diese Hegemons-Verherrlichungen. Wir sind gar kein Hegemon,
wir machen das trotzdem immer noch die ganze Zeit.
Ja, und auch diese Bekenntniskultur finde ich so wahnsinnig.
Also, dass man auch nicht gleich ins Gespräch gehen kann.
Ich stelle mir jetzt vor, wir müssten bei jedem Podcast nochmal vorab sagen,
dass wir den Krieg von Putin verurteilen, dass wir zwar beide geimpft sind,
aber durchaus manche Corona-Maßnahmen nicht so gut fanden,
dass wir auf dem Boden des Grundgesetzes stehen und trotzdem sagen,
gibt man den Vermietern kein Geld mehr.
Also, dass wir für erstmal mal alles, alles auftischen, was wir so, wofür wir so stehen.
Und du sagst dann nochmal, du bist Vater und bist an sich auch für eine anti-autoritäre
Erziehung, aber manchmal braucht es auch ein ernstes Wort. Das können wir alles nochmal auflösen.
Wir sollten so eine Fanfare für Artikel 5 Meinungsfreiheit, der uns ermöglicht,
dass wir den Podcast machen.
Ja, und vielleicht haben wir dann noch fünf Minuten Zeit und können über was Vernünftiges reden.
Das finde ich übrigens bei Friedmann so gut, der ja auch immer diese Vorwürfe
kriegt, so, ja, wie erklären Sie jetzt Israel?
Also, wieso soll ich jetzt Israel erklären?
Freuen Sie sich nicht, dass Juden jetzt wieder unterscheiden?
Nee, das halte ich für eine Selbstverständlichkeit.
Also, er kann das immer ganz explizit machen, weil er das, was du jetzt sozusagen
humorisch vorgetragen wirst, das kriegt er die ganze Zeit serviert.
Und dann macht er sich darüber lustig.
Wir hören jetzt mal, wie Detjen nach der internationalen Ordnung fragt.
But your opponents, like for example John Eikenberry,
the advocates of international liberalism, they would say, of course,
no, the international liberal order was never perfect.
Aber wir müssen akzeptieren, dass es etwas gibt, dass Nationen,
dass Staaten, die für etwas streiten.
Und warum sollten wir akzeptieren, dass es immer Fehler gab?
Wir sollten weiter streiten für das, was sie als liberalen internationalen Ordnung nennen.
Punkt.
Und sonst kann man über das andere reden, das für wünschenswert halten oder
auch nicht. aber es war nicht da und wird auch nicht sein.
Jetzt schätzt Moschai Mama die Lage zu China ein.
Also er spricht jetzt so Opiumkriege und alles, was danach folgte.
Das ist eine andere Art von sagen, sie haben jede Intention,
ihre Relativmacht zu maximieren. Sie wollen wirklich mächtig sein.
Sie wollen das dominante Staat in Asien sein. Und ich blame nicht die Chinesen überhaupt.
Wenn ich die Nationalverdienung in Beijing runte, würde ich Asien dominieren.
Ich würde das mächtigste Staat in Asien sein. Und ich würde die Vereinigten
Staaten aus Asien drücken, so schnell wie ich es könnte.
Da sind wir also wieder in diesem Dreieck. Jetzt hören wir nochmal als Kontrast
Frank Nowak, der sagt folgendes.
Wir brauchen keinen Dritten Weltkrieg, weil der wird höchstwahrscheinlich ein Atomarer sein.
Das heißt, wir müssen vorher die Notbremse ziehen und daher die UNO nicht näher
finden. Die UNO ist im Prinzip eine sehr, sehr gute Organisation.
Sie hat nur gewisse Geburtsschwierigkeiten, die damals halt notwendig waren,
um sie zu schaffen, aber die man mit einem Willen zur Reform auch durchaus reformieren kann.
Die Frage ist jetzt, ob hier Klugheit der richtige Begriff ist,
beziehungsweise kommt man mit Klugheit weiter, wenn wir sehen,
es gibt taktisches Kalkül.
Eigentlich geht es nur darum, wie dieses Dreieck zueinander steht und dann all
die Akteure in den Ebenen darunter.
Und da ist also die Frage der Klugheit sicherlich eine im Sinne von,
ja, es ist klug, dass es keinen Dritten Weltkrieg gibt, aber diese Logik,
die Mörschheimer da aufzeichnet, bedeutet natürlich auch,
dass also das Eskalationspotenzial wächst.
Und wenn wir jetzt sehen, die Aufrüstung wächst, du hast es zwar vorgerechnet,
aber schnell kann es eine Scharmütze geben und das kann sich dann auf etwas
ausweiten. Und ökonomisch vernünftig waren Kriege ja in der Vergangenheit auch nicht.
Und trotzdem hat man sie dann geführt, Kriege geführt, die ruinös waren.
Und wenn man jetzt auch nochmal überlegt.
Also das sagst du jetzt so, aber so wie er jetzt sagt, die Klugheit,
es wäre doch wünschenswert, wenn die Leute klug sind und sich darüber verständigen,
keinen dritten Weltkrieg zu haben.
Also ich finde, realistisch gesehen, wir haben gerade keinen dritten Weltkrieg,
also scheint es irgendwo diese kluge Verständigung gerade zu geben.
Eben. Da bist du ja auch wieder in so einem Normativitätsparadox drin,
dass so die ganze Zeit, wir hatten es ja immer wieder, das Präventionsparadox
hier, jetzt wünscht er sich keinen dritten Weltkrieg und sagt,
wir bräuchten dafür kluge Leute und ich sage aber rückwärts gedacht heißt das
ja, wir haben gerade keinen dritten Weltkrieg, also sind wir ganz schön klug
und so und das sind schwere Diskussionen.
Er würde sagen, naja, also wir haben keinen dritten Weltkrieg,
aber er könnte jeden Tag kommen und das bedeutet ….
Das wirst du immer sagen können.
Genau und das würde er aber sagen, das kann man aushebeln, dass man immer in dieser Gefahr schwebt,
wenn man eine übergeordnete Instanz etabliert, das heißt man würde die Souveränität
der Weltmächte und dann auch der anderen Staaten einschränken,
die würden etwas abgeben.
Also, wir haben ja...
Also wir können ja Dinge zum Beispiel in Deutschland nicht mehr selbst entscheiden,
weil wir das an Europa delegiert haben.
Das sind nicht so viele Sachen, am Ende sind doch die Nationalstaaten wieder
sehr entscheidend, aber so ein paar Sachen gibt es.
So und diese, jetzt gibt es aber nicht nochmal eine übergeordnete Instanz und
damit könnte man natürlich, hätte man eine solche Weltpolizei oder so und das
ist ja auch so eine Idee von internationalen Strafgerichtshof und all das,
wenn man dies hätte und das wäre auch so, dass die was durchsetzen könnten,
dann würde man ja gar nicht jetzt warten,
darauf kommt irgendein Präsident zu Besuch, den man dann verhaften müsste,
sondern man würde jemanden losschicken und sagen, der muss verhaftet werden.
In Deutschland kann man das, wenn du jetzt irgendwas klaust,
dann wirst du verhaftet.
Da sagt man nicht, muss man mal gucken, wenn Herr Schulz das nächste Mal verreist
nach Frankreich, dann können wir ihn verhaften.
Und diesen Punkt zu machen, zu sagen, also da hofft man auf Klugheit,
ist aber, finde ich, sehr schön, aber sehr illusorisch.
Weil wenn ich die Realisten ernst nehme, ich dieses Dreieck mir angucke und
niemand wird von denen bereit sein, Macht abzugeben an eine höhere Instanz,
wo ja auch die Frage ist, wer ist denn diese höhere Instanz?
Dann wird die gewählt, wird die ernannt.
Wer ist diese höhere Distanz? Ich versuche jetzt mal einen ganz abwegigen Argumentationsversuch.
Also die Heuristik ist ein bisschen durchgeknallt und ich werde es über Bande spielen.
Ich habe gestern wieder diese Reportagen geguckt, die gucke ich immer mal gerne,
wie Hans Zimmer Filmmusik macht.
Oh je, was kommt jetzt?
So, und es kamen dann Beispiele, wie klingen Filme, die im Weltraum spielen.
Star Trek, Star Wars und so weiter. Es sitzt ein Beethoven-Orchester da und
spielt irgendwas durch.
Melodien, kennt man ja. Vier Viertel Takt, was auch immer.
Wie gehabt. Dann kriegt Hans Zimmer diese Aufträge mit Christopher Nolan und
so weiter, Musik zu machen.
Und Christopher Nolan schreibt noch so rein in das Skript selber,
wie das klingen soll. Ja.
Inception zum Beispiel. Also Bläser, aber irgendwie mehr als Bläser.
Ich möchte gerne diesen Rhythmus der Zeit und so weiter über Akustik darstellen in dem Film.
Also ich bin ein Regisseur, ich kümmere mich ums Bild, schreibe aber Anweisungen,
wie es klingen soll mit rein.
Das ist ja schon mal abwegig. Also so wie wir jetzt auch bei politischen Diskussionen,
okay, ich bin ein Politiker, ich bin ein Politikberater, ich bin irgendein Nachdenker,
ich habe es mit Politikern zu tun, Politiker sind Menschen,
Menschen ordnen sich in Hierarchien, bei Staaten hört es auf,
was kommt denn als nächstes, als höhere Instanz?
Und dann sagt Hans Zimmer, wir können ja mal jenseits des Menschen denken oder
gerade den Menschen mal ins Zentrum setzen, aber irgendwie anders.
Und dann hat er Dune bekommen und bei Inception war halt noch klar,
okay, dann nehmen wir einfach Bläser und dann machen wir so einen Flügel auf
und dann hauen die aber ihr Gebläse so krass auf die Seiten des Flügels,
dass einfach dieses Klavier, das gar nicht gespielt wird, sondern einfach nur
so als Resonanzraum. Und dann hat man so einen anderen Sound.
Und plötzlich hört man den über Jahrzehnte in allen Trailern.
Über all diesen Getute und so.
So, und dann bekommt er Dune und fragt sich, okay, was mache ich jetzt hier?
Das ist ein Universum, in dem gibt es verschiedene Fraktionen,
Familien, wie auch immer, aber es sind alles Menschen.
Was eint diese Menschen? Im Grunde gar nichts mehr. Die sind vor Jahrtausenden,
wurden die ausdifferenziert, haben sich angepasst und so weiter.
Eigentlich eint die gar nichts mehr.
Und dann sagte ich Hans Zimmer, okay, um diese Idee jetzt in die Gegenwart zu
holen, in einen Film, sage ich, okay, alle Geräusche, die wir hören, kommen von Menschen.
Aber es gibt keinen Rhythmus mehr. Nichts für Vierteltakt. Es gibt kein Beethoven-Orchester
mehr. Keine Streicher, kein, die ganze Kram.
Wir gehen in den Baumarkt, wir holen uns Sachen, wir pusten irgendwo rein und
nehmen den Equalizer und machen da irgendwas mit und so.
Also der Mensch ist sozusagen omnipräsent, aber er kennt sich nicht wieder.
Er hört diesen Film und fragt sich, was ist das für ein Instrument?
Dann heißt es einfach, das ist eine menschliche Stimme, aber ich hab die halt
so viel mit Kompressor und zerhackt und hier und da und Hall und so.
Also der Mensch ist im Mittelpunkt, aber er erkennt sich nicht wieder.
Und ich würde jetzt sagen, bei dieser höheren Instanz, die man hier braucht
und die sich alle wünschen, also Nowak sitzt da und sagt,
ich wünsche mir hier jemanden, der das Zepter in der Hand und dann kommt der
Mörschheimer und sagt, die UN und irgendwas und der Richter hier,
der Generalsekretär da.
Und ich würde jetzt sagen, soziologisch ist es doch, wir können uns doch jetzt
mal diesen Hans-Zimmer-Wege gehen und sagen, wir setzen den Mensch in den Mittelpunkt.
Der Mensch hat einen Körper, der hat Bedürfnisse, der möchte gerne Gewalt vermeiden,
er möchte Hunger vermeiden, ganz viele Sachen.
So und die abstrahieren wir jetzt raus. Und jetzt denken wir nicht mal,
also wir denken jetzt einfach nicht weiter in diese Politikrichtung, sondern Wirtschaft.
Die höhere Instanz ist eine Marktlogik, auf die sich alle einigen.
Der kleine Farmer in Minnesota, der gerade in die Großstadt umgezogene,
400 Kilometer von seinen Eltern weggezogene junge Chinese, der irgendwie auf
drei Quadratmetern und so weiter lebt.
So, die eint alle ein was.
Und das kann man durchaus als eine höhere Instanz sehen, die,
und ich habe das ja auch versucht bei der alten Republik zu sagen,
die Demografie selbst ist der politische Akteur.
Nicht die Politiker, die mal zur Demografie was machen, sondern die Demografie selbst.
Und hier ist es einfach die wirtschaftliche Logik. Und wenn wir jetzt sagen Klugheit.
Nun ja, es ist nicht besonders klug, wie wir Wirtschaft organisieren.
Also da fällt ganz schön viel ab, wo wir sagen, das ist so doof,
aber wir verstehen doch eins, dass es nach Profitlogik funktioniert.
Also Amerika macht jetzt Zölle auf chinesische Autos, die das Klima schützen.
Das Problem der Welt ist gerade zu viele klimaschützende Autos.
Klimaschädliche Autos. Nein, das Problem ist gerade, zu viele klimafreundliche Autos.
Das ist das Problem nicht.
Für die Welt, sondern für Amerika.
Ja genau, aber es ist doch irre, dass wir die ganze Zeit in Deutschland eine
Investition nach der anderen, damit irgendeine Uni und irgendwie da und überall
Klimaschutz, Klimaschutz, Klimaschutz.
Aber das Problem ist eigentlich, wir haben zu viele klimaschützende Autos im
Vergleich zu den Autos, die wir vorher haben. Nur wir können sie auf diesem Markt nicht zulassen.
Das ist politisch ganz dumm.
Wirtschaftlich ist das total erklärbar. Wir kennen diese Rationalität.
Wir wissen, der amerikanische Präsident möchte gerne seine Leute in Brot und
Lohn haben und so weiter. Ich würde es genau umdrehen.
Ich würde es genau umdrehen und sagen, politisch ist das total klug,
im Sinne des Dreiecks gedacht.
Wirtschaftlich ist es total dumm.
Ja, weil es viel kostet und so. Ja, aber mir geht es ja... Also die Vorzeichen
kann man drehen, wie man will, ich will nur sagen… Nein.
Nein, nein, weil du hast eigentlich jetzt doch die beste Grundlage gelegt.
Also eigentlich müsste es, ich hatte jetzt eigentlich erwartet,
und jetzt kommt dein großes Plädoyer für den Freihandel und ich wäre gewillt
gewesen, heute damit einzustimmen.
Denn ich würde schon sagen, also bei allem, was die Globalisierung am falschen
gebracht hat, ist eigentlich diese Art der Vernetzung, die über Wirtschaft stattfindet
und wo es tatsächlich um Profitlogik geht, immerhin noch eine Möglichkeit,
dass man nicht kriegerisch tätig ist.
Es gibt Leute, die jetzt gerade sagen, man sieht jetzt gerade,
wie der Kapitalismus dazu führt, dass wir in den nächsten Krieg reinschüttern.
Und ja, natürlich gibt es Partikularinteressen, Rheinmetall wurde heute schon
erwähnt, die sehr befriedigt werden dadurch, dass man jetzt aufrüstet.
Aber wenn wir uns jetzt mal ansehen, was man gerade tut, dann ist es ja eine
politische Ideologie über die ökonomische Logik zu stellen.
Es ist für die deutsche Autoindustrie wichtig, mit China zusammenzuarbeiten.
Für BASF ist China wichtig.
Die Außenministerin sagt, Xi ist ein Diktator. Also da können die bei BASF,
bei BASF sind die dann stinksauer.
Biden sagt, China ist unser Problem.
Apple funktioniert nur dank China. Das heißt, wir haben die ganze Zeit eigentlich
eine politische Ideologie, die die ökonomische, realistische Logik torpediert.
Und von daher würde ich auch sagen, nochmal ganz stark auf dieses Ökonomische
zu gehen, dann ist nicht Ungleichheit und alles besiegt.
Also da sind nochmal ganz andere Themen, aber ich würde deutlich machen,
dass wir momentan bei all den Dingen,
die wir erleben in Bezug auf Krieg und Aufrüstung, sehen, dass sich das Politische
über das Ökonomische stellt und damit das Nationalstaatliche über das Ökonomische,
weshalb auch viele jetzt, die den Neoliberalismus so lange kritisiert haben,
die die Globalisierung kritisiert haben, gerade einen Fehlschluss machen, wie schon bei Corona.
Dass sie sagen, endlich wieder Staat.
Endlich nicht die Konzerne, sondern jetzt entscheidet der Staat über Investitionen.
Und dann geht das bis hin zu Ulrike Herrmanns Kriegswirtschaft.
Also ich weiß, wie du das denkst. Und ja, es wäre jetzt logisch gewesen,
dass ich direkt anschließe mit, dann lassen wir doch die Ökonomie gewähren,
so wie wir auch festgestellt haben beim Klimaschutz.
Ganz schön lange hat das unter politischen Doktrinen gar nicht funktioniert.
Aber jetzt wo einfach ein Marktmechanismus der ist, der sagt,
Mit Solaranlagen 4 Cent die Kilowattstunde ist es vorbei mit der Kohle,
weil es einfach sich nicht mehr rechnet.
Aber und jetzt kommen wir ja in diese brenzlige Lage, warum man hier so viel
Denkarbeit dieser strukturellen Realisten braucht.
Diese Arbeitsteilung, die daraus folgt, dass man sagt, okay,
dann kommt unser medizinisches Zeug einfach nur noch aus China,
greift ja nur so lange, bis wir ein medizinisches Problem haben und dann sind
plötzlich zu wenig Masken da und wir haben keine eigene Produktion.
Und dann fällt man zurück in diese, wir brauchen die Hierarchie,
wir können es nur innerstaatlich organisieren, weil zwischenstaatlich werden
dann irgendwelche LKWs aufgehalten, wie auch immer und da haben wir ja keine
Handhabe, weil die Polizeiarbeit endet halt an den deutschen Grenzen.
So und Christian Kern hat ja damals dieses Wort geprägt von Freihandelsverträgen
neueren Typs, die also nicht nur regeln, was an der Grenze passiert,
sondern auch, was in Konfliktfällen passiert.
Wir haben dann diese CETA-Diskussion, aber die haben da so ein Schiedsgericht,
das passt gar nicht in unsere Hierarchie, also es passt gar nicht in unsere Denkgewohnheit.
Natürlich immer mit diesem politischen, würde ich sagen, noch mehr historischen
Problem, dass die Leute, die diese Freihandels-Schiedsgerichte dann konzipieren,
natürlich erstmal komplett partikularistische Interessen da reinschreiben,
obwohl die Idee ja genau richtig ist.
Eine WHO, eine Welthandelsorganisation. Ja. Und so weiter und so fort.
Also in der Hinsicht, ja, das Plädoyer für Freihandel liegt dann auf der Hand.
Ist ja WHO.
Zum Beispiel, genau. Aber man müsste
es halt wieder verknüpfen mit so Notfallmechanismen, Konfliktlösungen.
Also eigentlich würde man über längere Sicht dann doch die staatliche Regie wieder nachbauen.
So wäre die Europäische Union sich Schritt für Schritt, jetzt haben wir so eine
Europawahl, bei der alle so das Gefühl haben, die ist schon irgendwie wichtig.
Gestartet ist das vor 40 Jahren als Redeparlament. Da sind deutsche Bundestagsabgeordnete
nach Brüssel gefahren und haben halt mal geredet.
Und dann sind sie wieder nach Hause gefahren.
Irgendwann sind die dauerhaft da geblieben. Dann haben die da eigene Rechte
bekommen, dürfen jetzt plötzlich die EU-Kommission mit einem Veto einfach nicht
bestellen und solche Sachen.
Also man hätte über die Ökonomie nach Wehend dann doch wieder so eine Etablierung von Hierarchie.
Deswegen würde ich sagen, nee, es ist eben nicht so dieser reine Freihandel.
Aber der Akteur, der den Freihandel, der ist überall derselbe den erkennen wir
überall wieder und den kann man ruhig mal als politischen Akteur,
auch wenn er kein keine Person ist mit einem Namen und so weiter,
aber der auf dem Markt tätige und zwar kognitiv lernende wirtschaftliche Akteur,
ist tatsächlich einer der gerade ganz schön viel strukturiert ganz schön viele
Erwartungen orientiert.
Nur ist es am Ende So zumindest jetzt der Staat oder sind es die Staaten,
die entscheiden darüber, was gemacht wird.
Ja.
Solange man in dieser Logik ist, ist man natürlich in einer Logik der Aufrüstung,
der Eskalation, ist man auch in einer Logik von Eroberung, nicht im Sinne von
Hauptsache ganz viel Land gewinnen.
Das ist ja auch ein ganz anderes Konzept noch gewesen, aber welche Strategie
verfolgt man mit einer kleineren Eroberung?
Jetzt haben wir eben von Mörscher immer gehört, der Putin hat jetzt gar nichts
darauf angelegt, die gesamte Ukraine zu bekommen, aber doch einige Teile sind
für ihn strategisch wichtig. Er will da so eine Pufferzone haben.
Und jetzt hören wir mal nochmal unsere China-Expertin, was sie sagt zu China
und den Begehrlichkeiten hin zu Taiwan.
Taiwan ist eine ganz kleine Insel und an der Südseite dieser Insel gibt es lauter Tiefseehäfen.
Diese Tiefseehäfen braucht die Volksrepublik China, um von dort aus,
ohne dass die Satelliten das sofort bemerken, die U-Boote auslaufen zu lassen,
die man braucht, um so ein riesiges Meer beherrschen zu können.
Das ist das strategische Interesse.
Jetzt ist die offensichtliche und letzte Frage dann, warum bauen sie dann keine
eigenen Tiefseehäfen? Ja, weil das geht aus rein geologischen Gründen nicht.
Weil die Landmasse, auf der die Volksrepublik China sitzt, ist eine Landmasse,
die ganz langsam ins Meer eingleitet.
Und da kann man nicht einfach eine kleine Bombe hinlegen und sagen,
okay, jetzt machen wir mal die Landmasse kaputt, damit wir da einen Tiefseehafen
haben. Es geht leider nicht.
Tiefseehafen hat man da, wo die Natur es einem gibt.
Und Geografie ist hier Schicksal. Das finde ich einen sehr interessanten Gedanken,
weil wir so viel über die Chip-Fabriken sprechen, aber diese Perspektive nochmal.
Und jetzt können wir mal so weit gehen und sagen, wir lassen uns mal von Mörschheim
erklären, wie ist das mit Putin und ist er denn rational oder irrational?
Und ich denke, wie du sagst, glauben die meisten Menschen im Westen,
dass Putin irrational war, als er die Ukraine invadiert hat.
Und der Grund ist, dass sie denken...
Dass Putin ein Imperialist war, der sich auf eine größere Russland,
oder sogar auf die Reestablishment der Sowjetunion konzentriert hat.
Und der Argument ist, dass das verursacht war. Und jeder, der diese Art von
Zielen hatte und diese Art von Politik in der Jahre 2022 beobachtete,
aber es gab einige Argumente dafür.
Er hatte geschrieben über diese Idee eines großen russischen Empire.
Ja, also er geht so weit zu sagen, im Prinzip ist das an den Haaren herbeigezogen.
Ich habe mir dafür nochmal so ein paar Ausschnitte aus dem Tucker Carlson Video
angeguckt und hatte so bei mir gedacht, kann das sein, dass Putin einfach Tucker
Carlson so anderthalb Stunden lang verarscht?
Also, dass der da einfach sitzt
und dem da irgendwas entrollt und 1700 war das so und 1900 war das so.
Also, dass man dann so denkt, ja, der erzählt dem da irgendwas,
aber eigentlich müsste Putin sagen, ja, wissen Sie, es gibt ja dieses Dreieck
und es gibt ja da Pufferzonen und so.
Also, eigentlich müsste er so mit dem darüber reden und erzählt dem dann irgendwas
von der großen russischen Historie.
Oder wir folgen Christoph Heusgrimm, der eben sagt, nee, der hat sich wirklich
so radikalisiert. Der glaubt diese Geschichte.
Und Putin fühlt sich da bedroht, ob er das dann ist oder nicht,
spielt ja gar keine Rolle, fühlt sich bedroht von der NATO-Osterweiterung,
er will da eine Pufferzone haben, das ist der Grund, warum er das gemacht hat.
Ja, ich denke mir jetzt, also gerade bei dieser Frage, ist Putin jetzt rational
oder nicht? Wie sieht so ein Gremium aus, das so zu Fragen kommt?
Jetzt ist Christoph Heuskens Meinung, der hat sich da radikalisiert durch Vereinsamung
in so einem kleinen Kreis.
Das haben wir ja im Westen spürbar nicht. Und so wie wir jetzt schon,
oder ich versucht habe, okay, vielleicht geht es nicht immer nur um die Politiker.
Wie sähe es jetzt mal dieses wirtschaftliche Argument runtergebrochen auf,
wenn wir sagen, okay, bei G7 sitzen immer auch die wichtigen CEOs mit?
Das prägt ja auch, also vielleicht ist nicht immer nur alles Politik,
sondern so wie du jetzt sagst, Geologie ist Schicksal, also auch ein prächtiger
Akteur, welcher Wissenschaftler da was so sagt, welches Gebiet sich wie eignet
und so und vielleicht sollte man auch die Wirtschaft,
also nicht nur die Staaten, sondern jetzt auch die Nationen mal in so einen
strukturellen Realismus, Das ist ja kein politischer Realismus,
das ist ja ein struktureller Realismus, der sollte ja durchaus offen sein für
die Realität, dass ganz schön viele Wirtschaftsbosse auch mit in der politischen Arena sind.
Aber was hätten die eigentlich Putin gesagt, ja?
Jaja.
Also, dass es keinen Krieg zwischen China und Amerika gibt, das scheint ja sehr
viel von, jaja, also man sieht sich das halt an und sagt, 30 Milliarden extra
für Sojabohnen, also das macht jetzt gar keinen Sinn, das ist uns hier zu teuer,
lieber Xi. Mach's mal wieder vernünftiger.
Jetzt bei dem Ukraine-Überfall würde ich sagen, ja, da fehlt vielleicht der
ein oder andere Konzernlenker mit im Raum, der Putin es nochmal ausgeredet hat.
Möglich, ja. Jedenfalls war
Mörschheimer dafür, dass die Ukraine die Atombombe behält in den 90ern.
Ukraine will need those nuclear weapons, not to use them, but for deterrence purposes.
Remember, nuclear weapons are the ultimate deterrent. And my basic view,
by the way, was at the time, this is before NATO expansion, so NATO expansion was not the issue here.
My point was that you had Russians and Ukrainians who were intermingled.
And if you looked at what was happening in the Balkans at that point in time,
an intermingled population of Russians and Ukrainians could lead to big trouble down the road.
In which case the Russians might
think about invading to deal with the so-called near abroad in Ukraine.
So I said if Ukraine had nuclear weapons, that would facilitate stability.
Nun hat die Ukraine keine Waffen, keine Atomwaffen mehr.
Aber ich weiß auch nicht, war nicht die Erklärung auch, das sind russische Atomwaffen,
mit denen der Ukraine gar nichts anfangen kann, sondern das ist mehr so ein
nukleare Teilhabe, ohne dass da noch jemand teilhat, sondern die lagern da einfach nur.
Na, also wie ich das jetzt so.
Hätten die die selber irgendwie.
Wahrscheinlich schon.
Im Sinne von, ich schieße die morgen ab und so.
Da fragst du mich jetzt nach Details. Das ist ganz schwierig.
Ich halte das eher für, ich hatte es eher so verstanden, dass ich schon möglich war.
Wir hören jetzt nochmal Weigelin Swizik, die beschreibt nochmal jetzt,
was das eigentlich bedeutet, wenn man dieses Dreieck hat, dass wir nicht direkt in einen Krieg gehen.
Jetzt hat man eine Ukraine, die ist keine Atommacht mehr, aber ist da in einer
besonderen Lage zwischen dem Westen und Russland.
Und innerhalb des strategischen Dreiecks Russland, China, USA gibt es bisher,
ich sage ausdrücklich bisher, eine Grundregel. Wir gehen nicht gegeneinander in den Krieg.
Warum? Weil alles drei Nuklearmächte sind und weil die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass wenn die gegeneinander in
den Krieg gehen, sie auch Nuklearwaffen einsetzen, leider sehr groß ist.
Deshalb sind sie brav in der Hinsicht, dass sie sagen, also gegeneinander nicht.
Das bedeutet aber nicht, dass sie ja nicht ständig in Konkurrenz zueinander stehen.
Und das bedeutet zum Beispiel, dass sie sich Territorien suchen,
auf denen der Krieg stattfindet, aber immer nur einer von den drei Mächten involviert ist direkt.
Siehe Ukraine. Also Ukraine ist bedauerlicherweise das Territorium,
auf dem dieser Krieg stattfindet, weil wir sehen, solche Kriege sind schreckliche.
Und jetzt wird wahrscheinlich mancher sagen, ja, aber die ukrainische Bevölkerung,
die tendiert doch auch nach Europa und Detjen fragt dann auch Mörsheimer,
ob er das dann völlig ignoriert. Seine Antwort darauf?
Our self-determination. And that's part of an international rules-based order
that protects self-determination of states.
You can make that argument, but it's a foolish argument.
And the fact is that in international politics, if you're a small state,
and you live next door to a great power,
you have to pay very careful attention not to alienate or anger that great power.
Because if you Wenn du das tust, kann diese große Macht dich zerstören.
Das ist hier im Westen der Hemisphäre der Fall. Die Vereinigten Staaten haben das Monroedoctrin.
Und die Vereinigten Staaten sagen im Grunde, dass die Westen der Hemisphäre
unser Nachbarland sind.
Und keine große Macht, keine weitgehende große Macht kann die militärischen
Kräfte in die Westen der Hemisphäre bewegen.
Kuba zum Beispiel, immer noch Mittelalter.
Das ist etwas, was er zum Beispiel auch erwähnt und als Beispiel sagt auch folgendes.
Jetzt klingt das alles so, als sei ihm eigentlich die Ukraine egal.
Er schlägt dann auch einen Deal vor. Wir hören uns das auch noch an.
Sie haben die Ukrainer gezwungen, einen Deal zu schließen, den besten möglichen
Deal, den sie bekommen können.
Und das Deal würde, glaube ich, die Ukrainer direkt sagen, dass sie keine Intention
haben, NATO zu beziehen.
Sein Ziel ist es, ein wirklich neutrales Staat zu werden, das die russischen
Sicherheitsinteressen in Ordnung nimmt.
Und im Rückgang werden sie den Russen ermöglichen, die meisten der Territorien,
wenn nicht alle Territorien, zu kontrollieren. Das wäre der Deal.
Wird jemand diesen Deal in der Ukraine oder in den Vereinigten Staaten oder in Europa akzeptieren?
So a realist like me who makes that recommendation is whistling in the wind. It's all a waste of time.
Und wir sehen, dass der Krieg weitergeht. Viele tausende Menschen sterben weiterhin.
Und das klingt jetzt so, als sei er fast zynisch.
Und jetzt kommt aber so eine interessante Wendung am Ende dieses Gesprächs,
dass er, nachdem er jetzt diesen Deal davor gestangen hat und damit sind sicherlich
viele in der Ukraine nicht glücklich, wenn es so käme.
Andererseits könnte damit der Krieg aufhören, dass er sagt, jetzt muss ich als
der Realist auf die Moral zurückgreifen.
I would much prefer to work out a negotiated settlement and have the United
States stay there and do everything it can to get as good a deal as possible for the Ukrainians.
And this is going to sound funny coming from a realist, but there is an important
moral dimension to my argument here.
But anyway, as I said to you before, I don't think anybody is going to listen
to me and I think we are going to continue the fight.
Ja, also es wäre eigentlich jetzt ein moralisches,
Gebot, das jetzt zu machen, weil man,
Ja, von westlicher Seite gern verkündet hat, ihr werdet mit unserer Hilfe diesen Krieg gewinnen.
Das findet jetzt so nicht statt. Das haben viele schon früher gesagt,
dass das so nicht stattfinden wird.
Und jetzt hat man da natürlich sehr viele Leute dazu gebracht zu kämpfen,
weil sie glaubten, dass sie diesen Worten trauen können.
Und jetzt steht man vor diesem Dilemma, viele sind tot. Und jetzt wird es eigentlich
eine moralische Verpflichtung, da was halbwegs Gescheites noch hinzubekommen.
Und das ist schon so fatal, wenn man das hört und auch so traurig.
Ja, aber ich verstehe nicht genau, wo er da, also das kommt ja wirklich aus
heiterem Himmel, wenn ich höre, der strukturelle Realismus als Paradigma für sein Denken.
Warum ist dann jetzt plötzlich wieder Moral?
Den Menschen gegenüber. Also ich glaube, wenn ich den strukturellen Realismus
richtig verstanden habe,
dann schaut der ohne diese ganzen normativen und metaphysischen Konzepte auf die Konstellation,
in der sich Staaten befinden.
Aber der strukturelle Realist hat auch eine Sicht auf die Menschen.
Und ich glaube, dass viele strukturelle Realisten sehr stark auch davon geprägt
sind, dass sie sagen, wir müssen Leid verhindern.
Und können das vielleicht auch besser tun, weil wir von diesen ganzen normativen Dingen absehen.
Also wenn wir natürlich sagen, die Demokratie Europas steht und fällt damit,
ob die Ukraine den Krieg gewinnt oder nicht,
dann muss ich das Leid der einzelnen Menschen, die dort sterben,
hinteranstellen, weil ich sage, dies ist das höhere Prinzip.
Wenn ich aber gar nicht normativ, wie das ja die Realisten machen,
wenn ich da gar nicht normativ reingehe Und als Realist sage,
wie sind die Konstellationen, aber ich will das Leid verhindern,
dann habe ich diesen metaphysischen Überbau nicht und kann vielleicht zu schnelleren
Deals gelangen, die mögen nicht dem Idealismus verpflichtet sein,
aber die werden dem Gedanken der Leidverhinderung verpflichtet sein.
Und ich glaube, das ist eine grundsätzliche Moral, die man schon so artikulieren kann.
Also Moral gibt es ja nicht mehr im Singular. Das ist ja eines der größten Probleme
und du hast ja den Witz schon gemacht mit selektivem Universalismus.
Aber wir sind uns ja, ich glaube, es gibt ja schon noch die universelle Moral,
dass man sagt, Menschen sollen nicht leiden. Wir wollen das Leid von Menschen.
Ja, aber die teilt ja Putin nicht. Der holt sich ja irgendwelche Inder,
die er irgendwie rekrutieren lässt und die da verfeuert werden. Dem ist das ja egal.
Putin ja, aber dem.
Naja, auch einem ganz schön großen Teil des Apparates, sonst wäre das ja gar nicht möglich.
Ja natürlich, aber Mersheimers Vorwurf ist ja hier ziemlich explizit,
dass er sagt, dem Westen war das jetzt auch egal.
Er sagt, naja, so 100.000 Ukrainer können ja für den Kampf schon opfern, das macht ja nichts.
Und wenn ich jetzt einpreise, dass die Moral bisher egal war,
kann ich nicht plötzlich ein Plädoyer machen, dass sie jetzt aber was zählen sollte.
Für ihn zählt sie.
Ja gut, für ihn.
Also für ihn zählt sie. Also ich glaube, dass diese Perspektive ist ja glaube
ich nicht nur eine, die sagt, so stehen die sich Macht voll gegenüber und dann
sollen sie mal sehen, sondern ich glaube, es geht ja schon darum,
Schlimmeres zu vermeiden.
Und das würde dann hier bedeuten, dass man sagt, also wie kann das Leid beendet
werden und ich glaube, das ist auch so eine Perspektive,
ich weiß nicht, ob man den Oberst Reisner jetzt zu den Realisten zählen kann,
er ist jedenfalls jemand, der,
oft ähnliche Einschätzungen hat und für ihn ist ja immer da,
dass man sagt, also entweder sagt man, das ist so das Wichtigste für uns überhaupt
mit der Ukraine, da muss man all in gehen oder man sagt,
nee, dann darf man den aber nicht so weiter köcheln lassen, denn das produziert
unendlich Leid Dann muss man sagen, jetzt ist Schluss mit dem Leid,
dann brauchen wir irgendeinen Deal.
Ja, das reißen dann diese Frage auf.
Mark Milley ist ja auch jemand, der da sehr früh schon darauf hingewiesen hat,
dass man nicht davon ausgehen kann, dass das militärisch zu gewinnen ist.
Zumindest nicht, wenn man so vorgeht, dann müsste man auch all in gehen.
Oder man sagt jetzt, das wird ein endloser Stellungskrieg, das produziert endloses
Leid, deswegen muss das jetzt verhindert werden.
Und da würde ich sagen, hat man eine Moral. Und das Interessante ist,
dass Mörschheimer das dann jetzt am Ende des Interviews dann nochmal auf die
USA bezieht, denn er wird von Dädchen, ja?
Bevor wir das hören, er hat jetzt sowohl den Deal als auch die Moral da so reingeholt.
Und jetzt hast du ja schon gesagt, ja, genau, wir haben das ja in Deutschland
so gar nicht geklärt, weshalb der Reisner uns immer wieder darauf,
also der kommt ja so mit so einem österreichischen Blick, die haben ja nochmal
eine andere Neutralität, durch keine NATO-Mitgliedschaft und so.
Und sagt dann, ja, man muss sich da entscheiden. Also entweder geht man jetzt
moralisch all in und sagt dann aber auch, koste es, was es wolle,
Putin muss jetzt besiegt werden. Oder,
Aber man lässt es nicht köcheln. Die amerikanische Sicht, und ich habe dann
immer wieder diesen Clip vor Augen, wie heißt der jetzt, der Minority Leader im Senat.
Nee, nicht Lindsay, sondern der Alte hier.
Aber der englische Außenminister war jetzt auch in Amerika, hat das dann nochmal
ähnlich formuliert. Vielleicht finde ich den Clip nochmal mit.
Ich meine jetzt konkret.
Die Amerikaner sterben hier, sterben nicht in dem Krieg, er ist relativ günstig.
Ja genau, es kostet einfach 10 Milliarden im Monat und man hat Russland da,
wo man es haben will. Also wird ja knallhart, nicht moralisch nachgedacht,
sondern einfach ökonomisch kalkuliert.
Da ist das Leid der Ukrainer völlig egal.
Genau. Und für mich ist überhaupt nur ein, in Anführungszeichen,
Friedensvertrag, also der die Kriegssituation ablöst, möglich,
indem wirklich seitenweise aufgedröselt wird, wem jetzt was zusteht,
wie was zu regeln ist und so weiter.
Der Rasmussen hat diesen ersten Vorschlag gemacht und gesagt,
also die Linien bleiben, wie sie jetzt sind.
Russland annektiert diese Gebiete, dafür kann die Westukraine und der Westukraine
sind, also manchen Westukrainern ist der Osten auch egal.
Es ist so ein bisschen Dirk Oschmann, es ist der Osten.
Uns wäre Thüringen auch egal, wenn da jetzt die Polen einmarschieren.
Also so in dieser Gesichtspunkt.
Dafür zieht aber die Hauptstadt, Kiew,
die ganze Region, ganz West, Mittelukraine, was auch immer, alles ohne diese
Gebiete, die ziehen einfach in den Westen ein, werden in der NATO aufgenommen,
EU-Mitgliedschaft vielleicht und so weiter und so fort. Und dann wird aber richtig knallhart.
Aber hältst du das für wahrscheinlich? Also Hörscheimer würde ja genau sagen, dass das nicht kommt.
Ja und deswegen fand ich es überraschend, Ich hätte unter den strukturellen
Realisten gerade gedacht, dass die schon mal durchspielen, wie so eine Pendel-Diplomatie
aussähe, bei der so ein Vertrag nach und nach wächst.
Und dann einfach unterschrieben wird.
Ja, wir lassen es mal offen. Wir hören mal noch, was Mörschheimer sagt zu seinem eigenen Land.
Denn er wird von Dating darauf angesprochen, dass er doch auch Sanders unterstützt hat.
The United States is in deep trouble at home. I think in particular the huge
economic inequality that we have and all the problems that we have in terms
of the opioid crisis and race relations and so forth and so on,
mandated a fundamental change in how we did business inside the United States.
I mean, I want to be clear, one of the reasons I was in favor of pulling out
of Europe and putting an end to NATO early on, was I agreed with Barack Obama's
famous saying that what we needed to do was nation building at home.
Und wir haben einen Altbundespräsidenten und einen neuen Bundespräsidenten,
die sagen, Deutschland muss sich mehr in der Welt engagieren.
Und vielleicht sollte man auch mal über Nation Building at Home nachdenken.
Du bringst uns jetzt gleich das Bauen und da muss auch vieles aufgebaut werden.
Wir geben aber die letzten Worte noch Susanna Weigel.
Ich finde das ja interessant, dass er als Realist sagt, ich habe Senders unterstützt
wegen Problemen an der Heimat, zu Hause, wenn ich Heimatfront sage, zu Hause.
Das ist ja wirklich diese Semsrott-Idee, man entscheidet über sich selbst,
10.000 Euro im Monat Gehalt, jeden Tag, den man zur Arbeit geht,
gibt es ein Sitzungsgeld, man ist unterwegs, Reisegeld, man hat eh schon eine
Bankart 100, kommt noch oben drauf.
Der ganze Kram, ich brauche jemanden an meiner Seite, hier kannst du ein Sekretariat
bezahlen und so weiter und so fort.
Also für sich selber geht man genau den realistischen Weg und macht sich so
angenehm wie möglich. Für alle anderen nicht.
Also ist jemand wie Senders, der kommt und sagt, Leute, denkt doch mal nach.
Klar müssen wir davon ausgehen, dass alle realistischerweise so leben möchten
wie wir. und wir können es uns leisten.
Also sollten wir es auch machen, dann geht es nämlich allen bessern und es zahlt
sich als Win-Win für alle aus.
So, also das liegt finde ich dann wieder auf der Hand, da einfach kurz zur Besinnung
zu kommen und zu sagen, nee, da brauche ich auch keine Moral oder so,
sondern das ist einfach logisch, dass Regeln, die ich für mich schon gefunden habe,
für alle gelten sollten.
Punkt. Das ist der strukturelle Realismus in der Innenpolitik.
Richtig und jetzt stütze ich noch die Frage, Was ist auf europäischer Ebene notwendig?
Denn wir haben jetzt über China, Russland, USA geredet, aber Europa kommt da gar nicht so vor.
Thilo, frag mal, wie denn Baerbock einzuschätzen ist?
Baerbock für eine gute Diplomatin.
Muss ich die Frage beantworten? Ich habe sie dir gestellt. Nein.
Und sie führt das jetzt aus, denn Baerbock sagt, Xi ist ein Diktator und das
sagt sie ja auch, Weigelin Schwiezek.
Nein, ich sage das übrigens auch. Aber ich bin eine Wissenschaftlerin und eine
China-Beobachterin und ich analysiere die Situation in China.
Sie ist eine Diplomatin, sie ist die oberste Diplomatin der Bundesrepublik Deutschland.
Und es tut mir leid, nach meiner Verständnis von Diplomatie gehört deshalb das
Wort Diktatur nicht in ihr Vokabular.
Auch wenn es wissenschaftlich richtig ist. Ja, es ist eben was ganz anderes.
Ja, es sind die zwei Arenen, die hier durcheinander gebracht werden,
nämlich Wissenschaft und Politik.
Und was bedeutet das denn jetzt eigentlich für Europa?
Während in Amerika es immer sozusagen zwei gegen einen ist, ist es in Europa
eher so, dass man sagt, okay, eigentlich können wir jetzt nicht uns mit den
Chinesen gegen die Russen verbinden.
Wir können uns nicht mit den Amerikanern gegen die Chinesen und die Russen verbünden
und wir können uns auch nicht mit den Russen gegen die Chinesen verbünden.
Sondern wir haben so eine Position im System der internationalen Beziehung,
das eigentlich verlangt, dass wir uns mit allen dreien ins Benehmen setzen.
Ja, das ist aber nicht nur ein außenpolitisches Problem in Europa,
sondern wir haben jetzt eine Europawahl und niemand kann die Frage antworten,
mit wem muss ich mich jetzt eigentlich wie verbünden, damit der und der irgendeinen Posten bekommt.
Es ist undurchschaubar. Es sind irgendwelche anderen Regeln, die da gelten.
In deren Sicht, ja, sehr gut. Ich glaube, wir sind jetzt alle so ein bisschen
strukturelle Realisten, oder?
Vielleicht, wir sind gespannt, was Precht uns dazu zu sagen hat,
vielleicht gibt es doch nochmal eine andere Perspektive, er sagt Werte geleitet,
das klingt schon nach doch etwas anderem.
Wir lassen das Tor offen, doch nochmal die Wertegeleitetheit berechtigtermaßen zuzulassen.
Je nach Argumentationslage entscheiden wir das dann nächste Woche.
Ein Thema, das uns alle eint. Du wohnst, ich wohne. Meine Oma wohnt, mein Vater wohnt.
Alle Leute, die ich nicht kenne in Deutschland, wohnen auch.
Also wir sind bei einem Thema mal richtig Schicksalsgemeinschaft. Wir wohnen alle.
Und Wohnen ist aber gleichzeitig eigentlich, obwohl es so selbstverständlich
ist, eins der größten Probleme, wenn nicht das Größte.
Also ich weiß, sehr viele haben jetzt gerade gute Laune. Sie waren irgendwie
auf der Republika, auf der OMR, da wurde irgendwie die Welt gerettet, wie auch immer.
Jetzt ist Monatsende, es ist leider, wir holen uns jetzt auf den Realitätsboden zurück.
Wir sind jetzt wohnende Realisten, es geht nicht, so wie es in Deutschland gerade ist, geht es nicht.
Trotzdem will ich mit einer positiven oder sagen wir mal einer,
naja, eine Heuristik, die so ein bisschen vom absoluten Abgrund abführt, beginnen.
Und zwar mit Tweets von Marc Schieritz. Wir kennen ihn ja von der Zeit.
Der hat sich jetzt nochmal die Rente vorgeknüpft und gesagt,
das ist eigentlich alles gar nicht so schlimm.
Und ich als Rentenexperte würde auch sagen, es stimmt irgendwie,
weil seine Argumentation lautet, angenommen es würde sich alles ändern,
keine Ahnung, also alles wäre komplizierter.
Und er schreibt dann in einem siebten Tweet von so einem Thread,
wenn sich das ändern sollte, also die Konstellation aus,
was auch immer, wir haben zu wenig Geld, weil zu viele Rentner,
zu wenig Nachwuchs, zu wenig Zuzug, wie auch immer, also es sind Sachen in Bewegung
und sie verschärfen sich, dann gibt es jede Menge Stellschrauben,
um etwas zu ändern. Ändern.
Und es wird jetzt sehr düster und ich will, dass das immer im Hintergrund bleibt als Wissen.
Wir haben ganz viele Stellschrauben in einer 4 Billionen Euro pro Jahr Volkswirtschaft
mit 20 Billionen Vermögen, da ganz viel zu ändern.
Aber man müsste eben auch alles ändern. Aber man könnte.
Also wir haben es hier nicht mit echten realistischen Knappheitsdiskussionen,
sondern mal wieder mit Verteilungsfragen zu tun.
Also es gibt kein Schicksal wie bei China und Taiwan mit der Geografie,
dass man sagt, wenn man Häfen haben will, dann muss man die da machen,
sondern hier kann man sagen, wir haben verschiedene Möglichkeiten.
Hierüber befindet ein Bundestag und verschiedene Landtage, die wir wählen dürfen.
Wir sind nicht einer Diktatur, einer fremden Macht ausgeliefert,
sondern wir sind es wirklich selbst, aber müssten es dann auch in die Hand nehmen.
Na gut, wir haben ja letztes Jahr schon mal reingeschaut. Der Wohnbautag beginnt
in ähnlicher Weise stimmungsvoll.
Hier ist der Wohnungsbautag mit der Pressekonferenz jetzt live aus Berlin.
Moderiert von Anke Plättner.
Man nimmt sich wieder Manfred Lehmann, der im Hintergrund immer diese Moderationsautomatismen liefert.
Ich will nur erinnern an die Pointe, letztes Jahr stand die.
Und Ricarda Lange von den Grünen da meinte, diese Stimme bräuchte ich auch mal
für den Wahlkampf, weil sie schon nicht mehr Bruce Willis Filme synchronisiert hört.
Ja. So, und irgendwann ist hier ein Generationenabriss, liebe Fernsehleute.
Niemand denkt hier, och, das ist aber der Gerard Thébaudieu,
den fand ich ja damals schon nett oder so, sondern es ist ganz peinlich,
hier Manfred Lehmann zu buchen für diese Aufgaben.
Gut, es gibt dann noch eine andere Veranstaltung, die ist auch ganz interessant.
Also das ist die Eröffnung des Wohnbautags der Pressekonferenz.
Letztes Jahr haben wir die Veranstaltung in voller Länge gehört,
mit Habeck auf der Bühne, wie er sagte, verarschen Sie uns nicht,
wenn Sie Ehe nach Standards bauen, die subventioniert werden,
machen Sie es bitte ohne die Subventionen und so weiter und so fort.
Es gab in diesem Monat noch eine andere Veranstaltung, das Verfassungsgespräch.
Das ist eine Veranstaltung, die findet direkt im Sitzungssaal des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
in Karlsruhe statt. Also man sitzt vor der Richterbank, zwischen Richterbank
und Kläger und Verteidigung und so.
Da ist dann eine kleine Bühne aufgebaut. Jörg Schönborn moderiert.
Er hat das Thema gleich ein bisschen anders gesetzt, nämlich nicht über Stimmlage, sondern Inhalte.
Wir haben uns ein Thema ausgewählt, das Deutschland ehrlicherweise eher teilt als verbindet.
Millionen Menschen wohnen sorglos und bezahlbar in ihrem Zuhause.
Millionen andere haben entweder eine Wohnung, die sie sich kaum leisten können
oder sind auf der Suche, weil sie eine Familie gründen oder woanders arbeiten
wollen oder überhaupt zum ersten Mal eine Wohnung suchen.
Wer auf den Wohnungsmarkt stößt, für den gilt häufig die 3G-Regel.
Man braucht Geduld, Glück und vor allem.
Die 3G-Regel. Nicht mehr geimpft, genesen, gedingst, sondern Glück,
Geduld und Geld. Finde ich nicht schlecht.
Wir brauchen hier eine andere 3G-Politik.
Gut, wir gucken vor allem auch, also hauptsächlich den Wohnbautag,
aber dann immer wieder dieses Verfassungsgespräch, weil da Politiker sitzen.
Zum Beispiel Marco Buschmann, unser Justizminister Bund, der also im Grunde
die Initiativrechte zum Thema, wir verändern mal das bürgerliche Gesetzbuch,
in dem geregelt wird, wie so Verträge miteinander gehandelt werden.
Ich habe ja schon häufiger gesagt, Mietverträge, dass Länder und Kommunen da
gar keine Handhabe haben, sondern immer auf den Bundestag warten müssen,
indem die FDP alles wegvetoisiert.
Das geht natürlich nicht.
Gut, erste Stimme vom Wohnbautag, Lukas Siebenkotten, Mieterbund.
Der Bedarf auf dem Wohnungsmarkt hat sich weiter erhöht.
Das heißt, wir haben in diesem einen Jahr keine Fortschritte erzielt,
was den notwendigen bezahlbaren zusätzlichen Wohnungsraum betrifft.
Wir haben es mit erheblichen Mietsteigerungen zu tun, die mit der Verknappung
des Wohnungsangebots natürlich zusammenhängen.
Und wir müssen davon ausgehen, dass von den deutlich weniger Wohnungen,
die gebaut werden, dann auch noch der größere Teil für Menschen ist, die viel Geld haben.
Das sind ja richtig gute Nachrichten.
Ja, das sind sehr gute Nachrichten und wir denken jetzt, okay,
das ist ja nur der Mieterbund, das ist also eine Einrichtung,
die steht ja auf der Seite der Armen, natürlich jammern die rum und so weiter.
Also auf der Bühne stehen nachher auch noch die Bauwirtschaft,
die Immobilienwirtschaft und so weiter.
Noch können wir Hoffnung haben, dass die anders klingen.
Ähm...
Statt 100.000 Sozialwohnungen nur 25.000, das ist natürlich blöd.
Und die Bundesregierung hatte sich beispielsweise vorgenommen,
pro Jahr 100.000 Sozialwohnungen an den Staat zu kriegen und tatsächlich waren
es zuletzt nur knapp 25.000.
Wie kann das denn sein? Jetzt können wir natürlich sagen, ja,
da gibt es eine ökonomische Schieflage, aber das wollen wir gleich mal.
Es gibt bei keinem Gut mehr Nachfrage.
Also dass hier kein Angebot da ist, liegt nicht an der Nachfrage.
Also nach ökonomischen Regeln müsste hier gebaut werden wie blöd.
Irgendwelche anderen Sachen.
Ja, ja. Also das muss man glaube ich auch nochmal deutlich machen in Bezug auf Schuldenbremse.
Also es ist jetzt nicht nur eine Frage von, kann man sich so eine völlig verrückte
Ausgabe leisten, sondern die Ausgabe ist nicht verrückt. Die Ausgabe rechnet Das eignet sich total.
Absolut. Wir haben ganz viele Investitionen, bei denen der FDP wichtig ist,
dass sie privat gemacht werden, damit die Renditen privat sind.
Wenn es die Privaten nicht schaffen, darf es trotzdem nicht der Staat machen.
Das ist deren Ideologie.
So, beim Thema Wohnen, 8.025.000 Sozialwohnungen und von den 400.000 auch gar nicht so viel.
Egal, dann wird halt nicht gebaut. Ist doch gut für die Vermieter,
weil knappes Angebot, hohe Miete. Also das ist die FDP-Logik.
Denn die Sozialwohnungen sind ja auch in privater Hand. Also diese Sozialwohnungen
baut ja nicht der Staat in dem Sinne, dass die Geiwitz jetzt da die Vermieterin ist.
Auf öffentlichem Bauen sind wir ganz weit weg, wenn wir sozial bauen.
Manche verbinden das noch, deswegen sage ich es dir nochmal sehr deutlich.
Und da gibt es also auch viele, die damit eigentlich gutes Geld verdienen könnten.
Absolut. So, wir gucken kurz hart aber fair. Kevin Kühnert wird gefragt,
warum es jetzt so wenig bezahlbaren Wohnraum gibt.
Die strukturellen Mehrheiten im Deutschen Bundestag sind so,
dass die Parteien, die von einem stärkeren Mietrecht, darauf spielt das Plakat
ja an, etwas halten, dass die keine gemeinsame Mehrheit haben.
Egal wie man das Blatt dreht und wendet.
Und so war es in der letzten Regierung mit der Union schwierig,
was für das Mietrecht zu tun.
Und jetzt haben wir die FDP vor der Brust. Ich habe selber den Bereich damals
verhandelt in den Koalitionsverhandlungen. Ich weiß, was ich dort rein verhandelt habe.
Konkrete Dinge, die Absenkung der Kappungsgrenze beispielsweise,
in angespannten Wohnlagen, auch Verbesserungen bei Mietspiegeln.
Ich weiß aber auch, dass wir einen dafür zuständigen FDP-Justizminister haben,
Herrn Buschmann, von dem wir seit mittlerweile über zwei Jahren auf Gesetzentwürfe
warten für das, was seine Partei unterschrieben hat an Kompromissen.
Und ich nutze auch diese Gelegenheit hier, um die Kollegen der FDP anzumahnen, vertragstreu zu sein.
So, also die Aufforderung von der Kanzlerpartei an die Vizekanzlerpartei, jetzt macht doch mal.
Buschmann war ja bei diesem Verfassungsgespräch, ist ja gut für uns,
da können wir ja hören, wie er sich zum Thema Wohnen, den 3Gs äußert.
Buschmann kommt mit einer ganz alten Geschichte, ich meine die ist schon nicht
mehr aktuell, da war er selbst im Kindesalter, hat man ihm das wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr als Märchen erzählt, aber gut.
Viel zu lange die Überzeugung, dass wir weniger Wohnraum brauchen,
weil es Projektionen gab, auch was die Bevölkerungsentwicklung anging,
die von einer schrumpfenden Bevölkerung ausging.
Und deshalb haben natürlich die Planer, die sich auf diese Zahlen verlassen haben, gesagt,
dass das Thema vielleicht gar nicht ist, mehr Bauland auszuweisen,
sondern dass man eher über Steigerung von Lebensqualität, über Probleme bei
der Versiegelung gesprochen hat.
Ja, also da stecken zwei Ausreden drin. Zum einen, achso, mehr bauen,
ja, sollten wir mal machen.
Sorry, wir haben uns jetzt zuletzt um die Qualität des Wohnens gekümmert.
Fragen wir uns nicht so, wo denn?
Und grundsätzlich dieses, ja, die Demografen haben uns gesagt,
Deutschland schrumpft. Ja, vor 30 Jahren vielleicht.
Ja, auch nicht.
Also 2024 plötzlich zu sagen, ach so, ja, es sind zu viele Nachfragen in den großen Städten.
Ganz überraschend, neu. Also es ist wirklich nicht neu.
Neun Jahre nach 2015 sagt er das und wo ja auch in den letzten Jahren dieser
Entwicklung, auch davor, nicht in dem Sinne abzusehen war, dass man sagt,
naja, es wird so ein Drittel weniger, dann wird es mit dem Wohnraum klappen.
Also das sind ja auch nie Prognosen gewesen, die sagten und bald wird in Deutschland
alles so schrumpfen, dass nur noch 60 Millionen hier leben.
Genau, du sagst jetzt 2015, ist neun Jahre her,
das ist also das große Schicksalsjahr Einwanderung, wir hatten jetzt 22 nochmal
ein Kriegsjahr, damals Syrien, jetzt Ukraine,
ich würde sagen 2008 eine Vermögenspreisinflation, Bankenunsicherheit und so weiter,
quantitativ easing, also dass relativ viel Geld in die Gesellschaft kommt,
um die Wirtschaft anzukurbeln und dann aber nicht wieder abgesogen wird über
Steuern, Abgaben, wie auch immer, sondern einfach so, ach ja,
der reichste Mann der Welt hat jetzt 10 Milliarden.
Jetzt hat er 80 Milliarden, jetzt hat er 200 Milliarden und so.
Also das bläst natürlich dieses, ich brauche ein Investitionsgut,
was nehme ich mir denn, was ist denn so nachgefragt?
Ah ja, Häuser in der Großstadt, also werden die erstmal alle für Fremdnutzung weggekauft.
So, Buschmann ist noch mehr im Märchenmodus.
Juristen verstehen ja von allem ein bisschen was, aber vom Bauen eben dann auch dann nicht so viel.
Aber ich glaube, das Problem, dass wir Boden nicht vermehren können, ist ja nicht neu.
Aber wenn wir feststellen, dass es Urbanisierungstrends gibt,
Dann wachsen Städte eben vielleicht nicht in die Breite, sondern in die Höhe.
Sehr gute Idee. Wir stellen die Häuser einfach aufeinander. Wir bauen einfach
mehrere Häuser übereinander.
Dann bleibt meine Klientel, kann dann sogar noch ein bisschen was drauflegen,
so, weil der Boden und so.
Jetzt sitzt ihm gegenüber Ole Scheren.
Also zunächst mal ist es ja eine gute Idee, in die Höhe zu bauen.
Da bist du ja auch sehr dafür.
Also es klingt logisch.
Aber es ist natürlich schwer machbar da, wo schon Häuser da sind.
Also man kann jetzt nicht ins Frankfurter Westend gehen und sagen,
wir verdreifachen jetzt mal die Höhe.
Das kann man nur, wenn man erst abreißt und dann neu baut.
Ja und man muss auch sagen, wenn er vorher so viel Wert darauf legte,
dass man ja ganz viel für die Qualität des Wohnens gemacht hat,
dann nützt es einem wenig im 37.
Stock zu wohnen mit drei Nachbarn auf Augenhöhe und den Rest kriegt man gar nicht mit.
Man kriegt das Fenster nicht auf, weil da oben einem das gar nicht ermöglicht
wurde, dass man da nochmal ein Fenster kippt.
Niemand hat einen Garten und so und alle leben nur noch in irgendwelchen Wohntüren.
Ja beziehungsweise man könnte es ja als Anreiz nehmen und sagen,
dann muss irgendwo Flächenversiegelung nochmal in größerem Stil stattfinden,
also dass man einen neuen Bezirk hier in Frankfurt beispielsweise eröffnet und
dort müsste dann in die Höhe gebaut werden und dann aber mit Qualitätsstandards,
die es einem auch ermöglichen, dass man oben gut leben kann.
Das gibt ja Städte, in denen Leute sehr sehr hoch leben und jetzt nicht unglücklich darüber sind.
Ja, es gibt in Frankfurt natürlich auch Wohntürme, nur die zeichnen sich dadurch
aus, dass sie nicht mehr in Millionen, sondern in Milliarden Euro Wert gerechnet werden.
Also billiger wird es nicht pro Wohneinheit, nur weil die Wohnung jetzt im 37. Stock ist.
Ole Scheren sitzt ihm gegenüber, ein recht junger und wohl weltweit gefeierter
Architekt, der sich seine Projekte so ein bisschen aussuchen und selbst gestalten kann.
Er schildert Erfahrungen aus Singapur und wir hören mal, was ihm besonders wichtig ist,
Marco Buschmann zu sagen.
Wie könnte man anders wohnen? Und das war eben ein Thema, das mich dort in Singapur
besonders interessiert hatte.
Das war eben ein Projekt, da ging es darum, 1030 Wohneinheiten zu bauen in einer
ziemlich hohen Verdichtung und dann eben ein Modell zu entwickeln,
das ganz anders war als das, was dort. Dort wurden eigentlich immer Türme gebaut.
Und ich habe dann eine Struktur entwickelt, die komplett horizontal ineinander
verflochten ist, in denen offene Räume entstehen, große Gärten.
Und in denen es eben nicht nur den Privatraum gibt, sondern auch den Gemeinschaftsraum
und eine große Staffelung der Räume dazwischen.
Also ein Gedanke von Freiheit, den man mit umsetzt in einer räumlichen Struktur,
in denen Menschen auch entscheiden können,
sind sie viel zu Hause, sind sie miteinander und damit der Wohnung selbst oder
der Zelle der Wohnung, wenn man so will, eine ganz andere Wichtigkeit geben,
weil man sie in einem größeren Kontext schafft.
Und ich glaube, darin können andere Ansätze liegen.
So etwas möchte natürlich Marco Buschmann nicht haben.
Das ist ja gegen jede Logik.
Die FDP möchte die Verkapselung der einzelnen Individuen, die dann sagen,
nur die FDP kann mir diese Verkapselung sicherstellen und alles,
was der da vorschlägt, ist für Buschmann wahrscheinlich schon blanker Sozialismus. muss.
Buschmanns Idee ist, du wohnst im 37. Stock, du trittst aus deiner Wohnung in
einen 5 Quadratmeter Gemeinschaftstreppenhaus, steigst in den Fahrstuhl,
fährst direkt bis in die Tiefgarage, steigst in dein privates Auto, fährst durch die Stadt.
Diese Idee von ich komme aus der Tür und sehe erstmal ein bisschen Weite,
Menschen, Gemeinschaft, ist nicht.
Also er war hier, da hat man eigentlich Wohntürme gebaut, lernt davon, macht das jetzt nicht.
Nee, also wenn er in die Höhe, er denkt jetzt an diese Luxushäuser mit Concierge-Dienst
da unten, wo man den Concierge vielleicht noch mit Namen kennt und sonst weiß
man überhaupt nicht, wer da mit einem lebt.
Ja. So, zurück zum Wohnbautag, nachdem wir jetzt den Mieterbund hatten, der schon gesagt hat,
Schlimm, letztes Jahr war es schon schlimm, jetzt ist es auch schlimm.
Katharina Metzger, Verbandschefin Baustofffachhandel.
Frau Metzger, wir hören, der Bedarf ist klar da, aber wie stellt sich das denn
auch für die Baubranche an sich dar, also für die Prozesskette?
Sie sprechen ja für den Baustofffachhandel. Im letzten Jahr war viel davon die
Rede, dass man den Kipppunkt befürchtet, dass es dann noch schlechter wird. Wo stehen wir jetzt?
Ja, wir stehen jetzt in einer Situation, wo der Kipppunkt stattgefunden hat.
Wir sind nach dem Kipppunkt. Die Situation ist absurd.
800.000 Wohnungen fehlen und wir haben den dramatischsten Einbruch,
den wir je verzeichnen konnten.
Der Kipppunkt ist überschritten. 800.000 Wohnungen fehlen und die ganze Branche wickelt sich gerade ab.
Also die wissen, die kriegen ihr Zeug nicht mehr los. Da kommt keiner,
kauft irgendwas. Hier dämmt niemand. Also es ist einfach nichts mehr.
Findet nichts mehr statt.
Also für sie ist die Branche einfach einmal vor die Wand gefallen.
Weil aktuell brechen die Baugenehmigungen und die Baugebinde dramatisch ein.
Die liegen seit 2023 mit 25 bis 40 Prozent unter dem Vorjahr.
Der Kipppunkt ist erreicht. Ich habe es gesagt, das wollte vor einem Jahr keiner
so wirklich hören. Jetzt haben wir ihn.
Im Herbst letzten Jahres wurden die ersten Werke geschlossen.
Unternehmungen sind in Kurzarbeit. Die Insolvenzwelle rollt bei Projektentwicklern,
bei Bauunternehmungen. und wir erfahren keinerlei positiven Signale.
Also die FDP sonnt sich in dem Lichte der angedichteten Wirtschaftskompetenz.
Es gibt kein Gut, das so hoch nachgefragt ist.
Die Leute sind bereit, die Hälfte ihres monatlichen Einkommens dafür auszugeben.
Und die Branche wird abgewickelt.
Und wenn du jetzt sagst, die Branche, muss man eigentlich sagen,
die deutsche Wirtschaft.
Denn wir wissen, dass Bauwirtschaft und die Wirtschaftsleistung einer Volkswirtschaft,
nahezu gleich betrachten sind.
Entweder guckt man aufs BIP oder man guckt auf die Bauwirtschaft. Das ist egal.
Also ist auch anteilsmäßig aufzuliegen.
Also so muss ich sagen, Wirtschaftswachstum und Wachstum in der Baubranche verlaufen parallel.
Eins zu eins, ja. Also wir hören jetzt einen Forscher von DIW, der das mal aufdröselt.
Wir wollen jetzt wissen, wie hoch ist denn der Anteil des Wohnbaus an der deutschen Wirtschaft?
Er vergleicht es mit der Autobranche. Wir können jetzt schon mal überlegen,
ist es höher, ist es weniger?
Ich will dazu sagen, wir reden hier nur über das Wohnbauen, Wohnungen bauen.
Es gibt noch das industrielle Bauen, es gibt die Infrastruktur und so weiter.
Es gibt private Investoren, die große Werkshallen, was auch immer,
brummt, Infrastruktur, so langsam kommt es ja aus dem Knick,
Windräder müssen gebaut werden, da wird viel gebaut.
Also wir hören jetzt nicht die ganze Baubranche, wir hören nur die Wohnbaubranche
und fragen uns trotzdem, wirklich so groß?
Und Sie sehen hier eine Grafik, ja das sind doch sage und schreibe gut 4 Millionen
Beschäftigte, die unmittelbar mit der Produktion und der Reparatur von Autos beschäftigt.
Ja, wie sieht es nun mit dem Wohnungsbau aus? Ja, im Wohnungsbau sind es dann
noch mal gut eine halbe Million mehr Beschäftigte, die man dem Wohnungsbau zuordnen kann.
Sie sehen, hier ist sozusagen der dunkle Balken der direkten Beschäftigung größer.
Also insbesondere das, was wir in der Bauwirtschaft sehen.
Aber eben auch hier gibt es indirekte Effekte, beispielsweise bei den Baustoffzulieferern
oder eben auch bei den Architekten und Planern.
Also die erste Idee ist zu sagen, oh, also der Wohnungsbau, der ist schon ziemlich groß.
Aber wenn man das sozusagen die gesamtwirtschaftliche Bedeutung jetzt einordnen
will und nicht nur sagen will, okay, das ist ein bisschen mehr,
als wir allein das Auto bei uns bedeutet,
haben wir versucht, das in so einem Modell wirklich umfassend zu erfassen und
haben neben den direkten Effekten bei den Baufirmen,
den indirekten Effekten bei den Zulieferern eben auch berücksichtigt,
dass diese Produktion von Wohnbauten natürlich Einkommen generiert,
also diese Einkommen auch nochmal neu verausgabt werden.
Und diese sogenannten Kreislaufeffekte oder induzierten Effekte,
die sind durchaus von großer Bedeutung.
Wenn Sie das jetzt hier mal insgesamt schauen, dann kommt zu den sozusagen 4,5
Millionen Beschäftigten,
die wir direkt und indirekt durch den Wohnungsbau generieren,
nochmal gut 2 Millionen dazu, die man den Kreislaufeffekten zuordnen kann.
Insgesamt kommen wir also auf eine Zahl von 6,5 Millionen Beschäftigten.
Das ist so unglaublich.
Das ist die Hälfte mehr als die Autobranche.
Kann man einfach mal vor die Wand fahren lassen, gar kein Problem,
da braucht man auch keinen bayerischen Ministerpräsidenten, der dann nochmal,
keine Ahnung, hier doch nochmal eine Verirrung, es wird gar nicht thematisiert, nirgendwo.
Macht dann hart, aber fair, dankenswerterweise, so meine Sendung oder so.
Und das war es. Also es ist wirklich erstaunlich. Dieses Verfassungsgespräch
da, was einmal im Jahr, also als ich das runtergeladen habe,
hatte das 2000 Views oder so.
Es ist jetzt nicht, dass das Deutschland bewegt, auch wenn da Jörg Schönborn
an und so und alle dahin und ein Bundesminister, das ist irgendwie ganz komisch.
So, jetzt haben wir hier 6,5 Millionen Menschen in einer, keine Ahnung,
45 Millionen Menschen arbeiten. Also das ist.
Wirklich Ein Wort noch dazu sagen, weil du jetzt sagst, dass es die Leute dann
merkwürdigerweise nicht so interessiert, obwohl alle so sehr betroffen sind.
Alle wohnen, 6,5 Millionen Menschen arbeiten direkt oder indirekt in der Wohnungsbaubranche.
Also eigentlich müssten alle Leute die ganze Zeit davon reden.
Warum tun sie das in Bezug auf Migration und andere Themen? Nun…,
Die Sache ist, glaube ich, dass das Bauen nochmal etwas ist und auch das Wohnen,
das zum einen so abstrakt gefasst werden kann und dann ist es ganz stark von
individualistischen Dingen geprägt.
Also jeder, der was bauen will, hat seine ganz eigenen Sorgen,
jeder, der eine Wohnung sucht, hat seine ganz eigenen Sorgen.
Also es geht nicht allgemein nur um bezahlbaren Wohnraum, sondern auch,
wo liegt das, ist da Kita in der Nähe, gibt es da einen Kita-Platz.
Und dadurch, dass das so sehr auch mit ganz vielen individuellen Problemen zu tun hat,
kommt man ganz selten auf so eine abstrakte Ebene, dass man sagt,
also da müsste jetzt eigentlich die Diskussion entlang gehen,
weil es dann doch wieder so ausdifferenziert ist.
Und ich glaube, das macht es so schwierig, das auch so im Großen und Ganzen zu politisieren.
Denn eigentlich müsste man ja sofort mit einem Aufruf Millionen auf die Straße bringen.
Ja, also die Dimensionen sind so riesig, sie könnten uns wirklich übermannen.
Und sie sind ja auch für die Betroffenen selbst so groß, dass man sich gar nicht
vorstellen kann, dass man noch mit 10 Millionen anderen Menschen in derselben
Schicksalsgemeinschaft ist.
Das wäre ja irre. Also das würde ja alles.
Ja, es müsste so eine Vernetzung geben. Ich habe gestern eine sehr schöne Sache
über Vernetzung gehört.
Ich weiß, das wird jetzt viele verärgern, aber ich verwende das ja nicht,
da ich ja bekanntermaßen kein Smartphone habe. Also es gibt ja…,
Apps oder ich glaube ein, zwei sind besonders beliebt, die einen davor warnen,
wenn irgendwo geblitzt wird.
Diese zu verwenden ist verboten, gibt es verschiedene Urteile,
aber ja, manche machen dann so eine Rechnung, wem wird es auffallen und bevor
ich den Führerschein verliere, lieber irgendwie eine Strafe zahlen für die App,
irgendwelche Dinge, will ich hier gar nicht beurteilen.
Mir geht es um was anderes, weil wir so gerade über dieses Individualistische gesprochen haben.
Du hast ja auch geschildert, man fährt mit seinem eigenen Auto rum.
Interessanterweise, diese Apps funktionieren ja ganz einfach durch Solidarität.
Das heißt, weil ich dann sagte, aber wie werden die denn so schnell aktualisiert?
Naja, ganz viele Menschen haben diese Apps runtergeladen. Dann fahren die los.
Ich bin heute Morgen hierher gefahren und sah, wie da gerade so ein Radargerät
aufgebaut wurde. Und wenn man jetzt so eine App hat, dann drückt man da irgendetwas
und dann wird das sofort verzeichnet.
Und dadurch sind die vollkommen individualisierten Autofahrer plötzlich solidarisch
miteinander, ohne einander zu kennen, weil jeder davon profitiert,
dass der andere ein Auge drauf hat und warnt.
Und das finde ich interessant und habe darüber nachgedacht, wie man aus so einer
App-Idee, und ich betone nochmal hier, das ist nicht erlaubt,
wie man daraus vielleicht auch was Politisches machen könnte.
Also wie man eigentlich individualisierte, und das ist ja eine atomisierte Gesellschaft,
sagt man oft, wie man die eigentlich zusammenbringen kann, ohne dass man sagt,
ja, das müsste über Gewerkschaften und so laufen, weil vieles kann man über
diese Art des Gemeinschaftlichen, wie das in den 70er Jahren mal möglich war,
nicht mehr organisieren. Nur mal so in den Raum gestellt.
Cancel Culture.
Du willst hier Leute zum Mob organisieren.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Ich finde eher, dass man sagen kann.
Ich verstehe den Gedanken und der ist ja auch gut.
Also zum Beispiel gibt es, wo kann man zum Beispiel, wo Arbeitsunrecht passiert oder so.
Wo kann man gemeinschaftlich darüber etwas organisieren?
Weil an sich ist der Einzelne ziemlich machtlos gegenüber Dingen.
Ich habe zum Beispiel jetzt von jemandem gehört, der plötzlich aus der Wohnung
aussieht und ganz viel zahlen soll für Renovierung, was gar nicht vertraglich
vorgesehen ist. Der als Einzelner sich zu wehren ist schwierig.
Wie soll der jetzt, weil das ganz viele Mieter sind, Kontakt zu Leuten aufnehmen, die ähnlich waren?
Und da glaube ich gibt es über diese Komponente, die ja immer auch impliziert,
es hilft allen, also du hast auch einen Nutzen davon, wenn du da mitmachst,
glaube ich gäbe es da nochmal gewisse Möglichkeiten.
Ich will jetzt hier nicht so ein Propagandist von Smart Revolution sein,
aber ein bisschen was hängt da schon auch, ist schon möglich.
Wir behalten den Gedanken fürs
Wohnen spezifisch im Hintergrund und kommen nachher nochmal kurz drauf.
Ansonsten würde ich sagen, Google Maps und dieses ganze, ja,
Meda, ich bewerte meinen Arzt, meinen Lehrer und so, es gibt schon genug Denunzierungsplattformen.
Ich meine nicht Denunzierung, ich meine wirklich, wie könnten Leute gemeinsam
etwas auf die Beine bringen.
Vielleicht sollten wir das auch heute als Idee, wenn jemand aufgrund,
und wir haben nachher nochmal eine Zuspitzung zu dieser Frage,
dann kann man ja gerne mal was entwickeln. Wir propagieren das doch.
Ja, ja, ich meine nicht einen Pranger bauen.
Also ich bin hier nicht nur für Pranger, sondern auch für Galgen, ehrlich gesagt.
Gott, bitte nicht, das wissen wir sofort.
Warte, wie dieses Thema weitergeht.
Das ist natürlich von Stefan ganz ironisch gemeint.
Wir hören nochmal die Dimensionen.
Also niemand, der irgendwie denkt, ich bin doch so fleißig, ich bin doch ein
ehrbarer Mann, der Kanzler hat mir Respekt versprochen, trotzdem kriege ich
keine Wohnung. Liegt es an mir?
Nein, es liegt nicht an dir. Hier kriegst du Aufklärung, es ist ein volkswirtschaftliches Versagen.
Die Branche, die hier gerade vor die Hunde geht und dir deine Lebenschancen raubt, ist so groß.
Wir haben ja mal versucht, die Steuereffekte des Wohnungsbaus zu berechnen.
Und insbesondere die Umsatzsteuer und die Lohnsteuer spielen hier eine große
Rolle, wo durch die Produktion von Wohnbauten, durch die Modernisierung,
Instandhaltung und den Neubau entsprechende Steuereinnahmen generiert werden.
Insgesamt sind das 140 Milliarden Euro.
Auch wieder eine große Summe. Der Anteil an der Gesamtsteueraufkommen sind 17
Prozent. Also Sie sehen, wie wichtig das Bauen auch für die Steuereinnahmen ist.
Das heißt also, ein Bundeshaushalt ist größer, wenn es der Bauwirtschaft gut geht.
Also wir könnten uns ganz viele Diskussionen sparen, wo wir wo sparen,
wenn wir hier dem Bedarf und der Nachfrage, die wir haben, einfach mal nachkämmen
mit einer klugen Wirtschaftspolitik. Ja.
Weil derzeit 140 Milliarden Steueraufkommen, Bund, Länder und Gemeinden in diesem Thema.
Also hier könnten wir auf jeden Fall uns Spielräume erarbeiten und Lebensträume
erfüllen. Es wäre Win-Win.
Also wirklich dramatisch, mit was wir es hier zu tun haben.
Derzeitige Entwicklung. Hier wird mal gegenübergestellt Bevölkerungsgröße und Neubau.
Wohnungsbau bedarf und da nochmal auch deutlich eine Warnung an die Frage,
dass man das nicht mit der Nachfrage verwechseln darf.
Eine Nachfrage ist Kaufkraft, eine Nachfrage ist das Leistungsvermögen von Käuferinnen
und Käufern und Mietern, sich eine Wohnung zu leisten.
Bedarf ist das, was wir brauchen, um in Deutschland die Menschen,
die Haushalte mit einer angemessenen Zahl von guten und standardmäßig zukunftsfähigen
Wohnungen auszustatten.
Und dieser Bedarf wird von Bevölkerungsentwicklung eben charakterisiert.
Und das ist zum einen Demografie, die schon seit langer Zeit Deutschland nicht
mehr wachsen lässt, sondern Sterbefälle und Geburten sind eben eher negativ.
Aber die Zuwanderungsrate, das Wanderungssaldo ist das, was Deutschland auszeichnet.
Über die letzten Jahrzehnte etwa 330.000 Menschen bis zu 375.000 Menschen,
zuletzt im Durchschnitt im ersten Jahrzehnt dieses Jahrhunderts 115.000 und
im letzten über 550.000 Menschen.
Und wenn man sieht, wie sich die Bevölkerung entwickelt, sieht man eben die
rote Kurve ist der Wohnungszuwachs in Deutschland, die Bevölkerungszuwachs.
Die Balken sind der Wohnungsbau zur jeweiligen Zeit,
wie weit das mittlerweile auseinander geht und am Anfang der Betrachtung da
links, 1990 waren es noch 34 Millionen Haushalte in Deutschland und jetzt sind
wir mittlerweile auf deutlich über 42 Millionen Haushalten angewachsen.
Ja, also wir sehen hier zwei Linien, Bevölkerung steil nach oben,
Bau pro Jahr rückläufig.
Also immer mehr Menschen und nee, dieses Jahr baut man noch weniger als letztes Jahr.
Und dann dieses Jahr noch mal
weniger. Also wir haben hier fünf Jahre in Folge, die es rückläufig ist.
Die Leute wollen Milch im Supermarkt? Ne, heute verkaufen wir nur noch 3 Liter.
Jetzt verkaufen wir nur noch 1,5.
Jetzt gibt es nicht mal mehr einen.
Ja, aber es kommen noch 4 Leute mehr an, wollen Milch kaufen. Ne, ist egal.
Also das mal übertragen, also man kann sich das gar nicht vorstellen,
in welchen Turbulenzen das hier ist. So, das sind ja gesamtdeutsche Zahlen.
Und wir haben ja im Hinterkopf, im Osten, in der Eifel, wo auch immer,
wird jetzt höfeweise werden Straßenzüge verkauft für den symbolischen Euro,
damit dann nochmal was passiert.
Wir haben also in Deutschland 2 Millionen freie Wohnungen.
Selbst die eingepreist, solche Schieflagen. Was bedeutet das jetzt für diese,
regionalen Sonderzentren, die wir immer so als urbane Zentren,
Metropolen, da wo die Zuwanderung nicht nur aus dem Ausland,
sondern auch aus den Familien hin, also wo wollen 22-jährige Leute hinziehen?
So, jetzt haben wir hier gesehen, okay, die Linien aufeinander.
Und das bedeutet eben jetzt schon,
wir haben einen komplett heterogenen Wohnungsmarkt, da wo wir diese blauen Flächen,
das sind die Bereiche in Deutschland, wo wir eher entspanntere Märkte haben, Überschuss,
aber der größte Teil Deutschlands ist eben gekennzeichnet durch eine deutliche
Knappheit eben bis hin zu einer kompletten Überlastung von Wohnungsmärkten.
Und das sieht man eben an mehreren Zahlen.
Hier mal 39 Regionen in Deutschland rausgegriffen, in denen man vergleichen
kann, wie die Bevölkerung sich entwickelt hat und wie gleichzeitig der Wohnungsbau gewachsen ist.
Und das Verhältnis dazwischen ist zwischen anderthalb bis zum zwanzigfachen.
Aber das Produkt, und das ist eben viel entscheidender, am Ende ist,
dass die Menschen sich eben zusammen ruckeln und dann eben in den Wohnungen
wohnen, die ihnen zur Verfügung stehen. Und die sind nicht mehr angemessen.
Faktor 20. Gehst in den Supermarkt, willst Klopapier kaufen.
20 Leute mit dir. Und einer kriegt die eine Packung, die da liegt.
Das ist der Wohnungsbaumarkt in Deutschland.
Naja, du siehst es doch in den Großstädten schon sehr stark,
dass da der beengte Wohnraum sich auch so ausdrückt, dass die Leute versuchen
möglichst viel Zeit draußen zu verbringen, weil sie einfach dauerhaft den beengten Verhältnis nehmen.
Das war ja auch sowas, was während der ganzen Lockdowns weitgehend ignoriert wurde,
dass man mit vier Leuten auf 50 Quadratmetern halt nicht so gerne ruft, wir bleiben zu Hause,
sondern eher gerne raus möchte und das ist etwas, was glaube ich jetzt immer
stärker zu beobachten ist, also einfach im Stadtbild, dass einfach die Leute mehr draußen leben,
weil drinnen nicht mehr viel ist.
Genau, dem gehen wir jetzt mal nach. Wir haben ja junge Zuhörer in urbanen Zentren
gerade hingezogen, also diesen
Wohnungsmarkt, der in den letzten fünf bis zehn Jahren so mitgekriegt.
Die denken sich jetzt, ja, 40 Quadratmeter für meine Freundin,
die schon zwei Kinder hat und so weiter, das ist ganz schön eng.
Wir leben hier, glaube ich, nennt man das, in überbelegten Wohnungen.
Betrifft nur uns, hoffentlich gibt es da bald Abhilfe und jetzt kriegen wir
Zahlen, wie viele Menschen das betrifft.
9,3 Millionen Menschen im letzten Jahr lebten in überbelegten Wohnungen in Deutschland.
Nur falls ihr es nicht richtig, er hat nicht 0,3, sondern er hat 9,3 Millionen Menschen gesagt.
Die europäische Sozialstatistik, die Zahl ist mittlerweile abgedatet worden,
weil die Folie eine Woche alt ist.
Das ist eine Anfrage aus dem Bundestag, 9,5 Millionen sind es mittlerweile.
Das heißt also innerhalb von drei Jahren allein, denn wir haben 2020 die Zahl
zum letzten Mal auch hier auf dem Wohnungsbautag erhoben, ist die Zahl der Menschen,
die in Deutschland in überbelegten Wohnungen leben, um gut eine Million angewachsen.
Das heißt, die Wohnungsmärkte sind überlastet.
Das heißt eigentlich, wenn Pistorius jetzt mehr Leute in die Kaserne holen will,
muss man sagen, ganz viele sind eigentlich jetzt schon in so einer Kaserne.
Ja, so was heißt überbelegte Wohnungen?
Wir haben hier reportagige Einblicke über Hart aber Fair bekommen,
die wirklich gruselig sind.
Und gerade mit dieser Zahl, es betrifft einfach 10 Millionen Menschen in Deutschland.
Wir sind Familie Lewert, sind jetzt zu viert und seit vier Jahren auf der Suche
nach einer größeren Wohnung.
Momentan wohnen wir auf 65 Quadratmetern. Das verteilt sich auf zwei Räume.
Von der Miete liegen wir so bei 900 Euro kalt, sind also bei 1100 warm.
Das ist dann unser Schlafzimmer für uns alle vier. Also in dem Sinne hat es
ein bisschen Hostelcharakter. die Kinder hier im Doppelstockbett,
wir direkt daneben und der Platz irgendwie ideal genutzt. Zumindest mehr Platz haben wir nicht.
Bei vier Leuten gibt es immer andere Schlafrhythmen und das natürlich für die
Situation allgemein belastend.
Der größte Störfaktor ist gerade, dass wir einfach keine Rückzugsorte haben
und dass es auch gerade, wenn jemand krank ist,
schwierig ist. Das ist das sogenannte Wohnzimmer, was eigentlich der Aufenthaltsraum
für uns alle vier ist, wo irgendwie der Platz maximal genutzt ist.
Das heißt, wir alle vier verbringen hier unsere Freizeit auf diesen 15 Quadratmetern.
Ja, Sie finden schon gar keine Worte mehr dafür. Es ist halt,
und der ganze Körper redet in dem Moment schwierig.
Also es ist wirklich dramatisch. Wie viele Anfragen, wie viele Versuche haben
die jetzt unternommen in diesen vier Jahren, da mal auszuziehen?
Wir suchen seit vier Jahren, waren es dann über 300 Anfragen bei einem Portal.
Maximal 10% kriegt man irgendwie eine Antwort, vielleicht dann bei 3% kriegt
man einen Besichtigungstermin.
Wir wären bereit, eine relativ hohe Miete zu bezahlen, aber die Wohnungen,
die wir suchen, sind halt nicht auf dem Markt oder stehen aus irgendwelchen
Gründen dem Markt nicht zur Verfügung.
Also Sie sind sogar bereit, 1.700 Euro zu zahlen, was ja richtig viel ist.
Ja. 300 Anfragen in vier Jahren, ein Jahr hat 365 Tage.
Jede Woche befassen die sich ein- oder zweimal damit, eine neue Wohnung zu suchen.
Durch Forsten ist Internet, die gehen dann dahin, schreiben die an.
Das ist quasi der Nebenberuf, solche Sachen zu machen.
Eine Frau saß im Studio beim Klamrot und dann kam die Frage auf,
die du eben auch schon aufgeworfen hast.
Was machen sie dann, wenn Besuch kommt? Wir haben keinen Besuch.
Also wenn nur eine Person, das war's.
Und wenn sie Freunde sehen wollen, mehr Freunde, was machen sie dann?
Wir treffen uns draußen, also woanders.
Ja, das ist exakt das.
So, wir haben keinen Besuch. Zehn Millionen Deutsche sagen, wir haben keinen
Besuch. Wo soll ich denn hinsetzen? Da passt nicht mal ein Stuhl in die Ecke.
Jetzt dieses große Problem. Du hast ja eben diese Apps angesprochen.
Angenommen, du kommst in eine
Verkehrskontrolle und der Polizist sieht diese App. Was passiert dann?
Dann kriegst du Mahnungen.
Sprichst irgendwelche Strafgelder aus.
Ich bin da jetzt kein Experte, aber was man mir sagte, ist, dass die offenbar
das Recht haben, das Gerät auch einzuziehen. Das scheint aber noch nicht vorgekommen zu sein.
Man bekommt eine Strafe, möglicherweise auch einen Punkt.
Aber frag mich jetzt nicht nach den Details. Ich habe ja nicht mal ein Gerät,
womit man das machen kann.
Aber selbst wenn wir jetzt nicht wissen, was passiert. Es ist denkbar,
dass ein Polizist einfach an der Straße steht und sagt, halten Sie mal kurz
an. Mann, ich will mir mal was angucken.
Egal, was du jetzt machst, also eine Verkehrskontrolle ist immer möglich.
Eine Verkehrskontrolle ist sowieso immer möglich, ja klar.
Verkehrskontrollen sind also immer möglich. So, du bist im Freibad und machst irgendwas.
Was macht der Bademeister? Er pfeift dich an und ruft dich zur Fasson oder wie das auch immer heißt.
Zur Raison. Raison. Ich würde jetzt gerne noch so zehn andere Beispiele.
Promptet sie euch bitte selber. Man darf nicht machen, was man Man will.
Es gibt Verkehrspolizisten, Stadtpolizei, Landespolizei, Bundeskriminalamt,
das Finanzamt hat irgendwelche Ansprüche. Die ganze Zeit, irgendwer will was von einem.
So, wie ist das jetzt beim Wohnen?
Kommt da irgendwann die Polizei vorbei und fragt, das sieht aber klein aus,
soll ich dem Vermieter mal eine Notiz stecken? Soll ich hier mal ein Gerät einziehen?
Soll ich mal eine Strafe aussprechen?
Irgendwie nicht so, ne? Also beim Wohnen ist irgendwie alles möglich.
Du sagst als Vermieter, das ist die Wohnung, das ist der Preis.
Ob das dann gegen irgendwelche Gesetze verstößt oder Mietpreisbremsen oder was
auch immer, da kommt niemals die Polizei von sich und sagt, wir machen mal eine
allgemeine Verkehrskontrolle.
Nein, du hast die Möglichkeit, ich habe ja eben gesagt, ich kenne da jemanden,
der jetzt da ein paar tausend Euro für Renovierung zahlen muss,
für die er gar nicht zuständig ist,
er hat nur die Möglichkeit jetzt zum Anwalt zu gehen, das heißt er braucht schon
mal eine Rechtsschutzversicherung, um sich das leisten zu können,
die deckt auch nicht alles ab und dann kann er überlegen, gehe ich dieses Risiko ein,
könnte ich aber dann auf 2000 Euro Anwaltskosten sitzen bleiben oder sage ich,
okay, ich zahle einfach das Geld, zahle diese 2000 Euro, Habe dann meine Ruhe,
bin ja eh jetzt aus der Wohnung raus.
Das ist die Situation, in der man sich befindet. Das heißt, man ist freiwillig für den Vermieter.
Deswegen glaube ich, ist es schon sehr ratsam, in den Mieterbund zu gehen,
um dort ein bisschen mehr Handhabe zu haben.
Aber auch da wird es nicht so einfach sein.
Nehmen wir mal den Vater von eben. Also der sucht seit vier Jahren eine Wohnung.
Hat sich schon 300 angeschaut.
Er hat ein Budget von 1700 Euro. Dann kommt einer und sagt, ich biete dir ein Kinderzimmer.
Also statt 65 dann einfach, keine Ahnung, 80 Quadratmeter, 15 Quadratmeter mehr.
Bedingung ist kein Mieterbund.
Mietpreisbremse gilt hier nicht. Und es ist ein bisschen laut.
Was macht man dann? Geht man dann zur Polizei und sagt irgendwie, keine Ahnung.
Nee, man zieht dann erstmal da ein und denkt sich, ich muss jetzt nicht mehr
drei Tage die Woche abends noch zwei Stunden arbeiten, daran eine neue Wohnung
zu finden, sondern man hat dann irgendwie eine gefunden.
Dieser Anlagenschützer oder wie auch immer heißt Tenhaus, der auch diese ganzen
Beratungssachen, also der immer mal so, ich kenne jetzt seinen Namen leider
nicht in voller Länge, aber der saß hier mit in der Harter-Buffer-Sendung.
Wenn sich Leute nicht ans Gesetz halten, dann geht der Staat irgendwie vor.
Das ist so wie der Verkehrspolizist, wenn ich bei Tempo 30 mit Tempo 50 durchrausche,
dann kriege ich ein Knöllchen.
Das ist in dem Fall nicht so. Ich muss mich als Person darum kümmern,
dass sich andere an geltende Gesetze halten.
Und das bei dem Thema Wohnraum. Wie beim Mietwucherparagraphen übrigens auch.
So, das ist eines der größten Probleme überhaupt, finde ich.
Und wäre doch cool, wenn man hier eine Ministerin hätten, die sich mal drum kümmert.
Bauminister, wie wird gebaut, dass das alles seinen Regeln, dass man nicht da
die ganze Zeit selber seine Schicksalsgemeinschaft finden muss und dann noch
einen Anwalt und das ist alles Arbeit und wir wissen, das schützt im Grunde das Kapital.
So, jetzt kriegt, es ist ein Einblick in eine Reportage, die mit dieser Sendung
weniger zu tun hatte. Die gucken das da auch nur als Clip.
Klara Geiwitz als Bauministerin mal diese Frage vorgelegt. Könnten sie gar nicht
mal und so weiter. Sie äußert sich wie folgt.
Interessante Stelle. Da fragt meine Kollegin, die Bauministerin,
Geiwitz nach genau diesem Problem.
Und die Stelle können wir uns nochmal angucken. Also in einem Rechtsstaat setzt
der Gesetzgeber die Rahmenbedingungen, in denen man die Gesetze erlässt.
Wir haben den Rechtsstaat, das heißt man kann vor Gericht gehen,
wenn diese Gesetze verletzt sind.
Aber wir haben natürlich keinen Babysitter-Nanny-Staat, der sich in Vertragsbeziehungen
zwischen zwei Privatpersonen mischt.
Herr Kündert, würden Sie das auch als Babysitter-Nanny-Staat bezeichnen,
wenn der Staat darauf achtet, dass der Vermieter nicht gegen die Mietpreisbremse verstößt?
Nein, das würde ich nicht so bezeichnen.
Ja, ich kann sagen, das ist eine gute Argumentation.
Also bei der nächsten Verkehrskontrolle haben sie Alkohol getrunken,
sind sie zu schnell gefahren, haben sie dann Warn-Dreieck dabei,
dann sage ich sind sie beim Babysitter
oder was, wird dann noch selbst wissen, ob ich Auto fahren kann.
Also man kann es nicht glauben, wie dumm das ist. Das sozusagen.
Vor allem als Zuständige in diesem Metier. Das ist so unfassbar.
Ich meine, Geiwitz hat mir das ja extra so geschaffen, dass sie da irgendwas machen kann.
Das ist ja eine solche Fehlbesetzung. Und hier muss man auch wirklich mal ganz
klar sagen, weil wir so oft gegen FDP und alles wettern und das ist ja auch alles richtig.
Aber genau so etwas kostet kein Geld, das zu verändern.
Das könnte Geiwitz angehen, statt in der Welt rumzufahren und sich mal schöne
Bauprojekte anzusehen.
Das könnte sie alles machen, da ist jetzt nicht der böse Christian Lindner,
der das der SPD verhindert und dass die anderen SPD-Abgeordneten auch nicht
entsprechend Druck ausüben.
Ja, das ist nicht die Schuld der FDP.
Also klarer Geiwitz, ist ein echtes Problem.
Es ist keine moderne Politik.
Wenn es nicht da wäre, wäre es eher besser. Wenn das Amt nicht besetzt wäre,
könnte man davon ausgehen.
Dass es besser liefe. Zurück zum Wohnbautag. Einer nach dem anderen erklärt
uns hier, dass der Kipppunkt hinter uns liegt.
An der Stelle, wo wir jetzt im letzten Jahr noch sagen mussten,
wir starten vor einem Kipppunkt,
ist es jetzt eben tatsächlich ein Kipppunkt, der überschritten ist und deswegen
ist es nachgerade notwendig, dass wir jetzt tatsächlich ernsthaft reflektieren,
was können wir eigentlich überhaupt noch bauen und was ist eben für die Menschen
noch angemessen zu bauen.
Ja, was können wir überhaupt noch bauen? Wenn man heute baut, wird es teuer.
Ja, ans letzte Jahr, da haben wir ausgerechnet, was es eben bedeutet,
wenn man Wohnraum, der über 5000 Euro kostet, dann eben runtersubventioniert
auf eine Bezahlbarkeit in der Größenordnung sozialer Wohnraumförderung,
die irgendwo sich unterhalb von 7 Euro Kaltmeter abspielt.
Und das bedeutet, wir reden über einen Subventionsbarwert von gut 2.900 Euro
pro Quadratmeter, der eben notwendig ist.
Das schaffen nur noch wirklich super gut ausgestattete Wohnraumförderprogramme
der Länder, aber nur noch wenige.
Und was sie eben vor allem nicht tun können, den ganzen Markt abfedern.
Ja, man muss für 5.000 Euro bauen und bräuchte 2.900 Euro Subventionen,
also pro Quadratmeter, um das dann für den Markt, wie wir ihn,
und man kann halt nur so viel bezahlen, wie man halt Miete bezahlen kann,
um das zur Verfügung zu stellen, das ist kein gesundes Gefüge.
Also hier, ja.
Es ist, ja, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was ich dazu sagen soll, dass es so.
Das ist wirklich alles ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz schräg.
Das heißt, wir sind jetzt eigentlich an so einem Punkt, wo man sagen kann,
das ist jetzt einfach so, das wird sich jetzt weiter verschärfen.
Möglicherweise wird irgendwann die Wirtschaft einen solchen Aufschwung erleben,
dass die Bauwirtschaft davon mitgerissen wird.
Dann ist das aber nicht Verdienst von Clara Geiwitz, sondern dann ist das so
ein gesamtwirtschaftlicher Aufschwung.
Aber das sind ja solche Lücken, da sind solch große Bedarfe inzwischen da,
dass das überhaupt nicht mehr aufzufangen ist.
Das heißt, man kann sich eigentlich jetzt für dieses ganze Jahrzehnt und darüber
hinaus darauf einstellen, dass Wohnungsnotüberbelegung dauerhaft 15 Millionen
Menschen betreffen wird.
Ja, so starten wir jetzt in die Alten Republik, bei der wir auch neuen Wohnbedarf haben.
Also nicht nur in der Masse, sondern auch anders wohnen und so.
Also es ist wirklich alles grotesk.
Zurück zu diesem Gespräch, diesem Verfassungsgespräch, hat da Dolbler-Gmelin,
war ja auch mal Justizministerin, also ist mit Buschmann da schon auf Augenhöhe und so.
Also sollte doch auch da beim Mieten, nee, bei der, bei Deutsche Wohnen Enteignen
war sie doch da auch mit engagiert.
Hat sie aber, glaube ich, eigentlich nur verschleppt, ne, das ganze Verfahren.
Ja, das ganze Ding hat sich ja dadurch verschleppt, dass man jetzt es nochmal,
genau so nochmal machen muss, aber mit einem konkreten Gesetzestext.
Hatte man vorher irgendwie übersehen, dass es da zwei, drei Leute in der Politik
ausreichend sind, um einfach so ein ganzes Volksbegehren zu blockieren.
Und jetzt braucht man nochmal, wir haben es ernst gemeint. Allein für diesen
Nachsatz muss man jetzt nochmal ein eigenes Verfahren anstoßen. Also es ist grotesk.
Sie erklärt uns jetzt aber mal 5000 Euro pro Quadratmeter fürs Bauen.
Was ist denn das für ein Quatsch? Wo kommen denn diese Preise her?
Ich will es jetzt auch nicht übertreiben, aber es gibt eine Vielzahl von Möglichkeiten,
die alle gemacht werden müssen.
Mir ist am allerwichtigsten, dass wir auch diejenigen sehen,
die als Normalverdienende in Ballungsstätten arbeiten, tagtäglich,
und die sich die Wohnungen einfach nicht mehr leisten können. Warum?
Weil eine Wohnung in Berlin, ich weiß das auch aus eigener Anschauung,
die man Mitte der 90er Jahre gekauft hat, hat heute das drei- bis vierfache Kosten.
Und das liegt nicht an den Zinsen. Es liegt auch nicht an den Kosten,
sondern das sind die Bodenwertsteigerungen, die aus der Organisation und der
Behandlung von Wohnungen als Marktgut allein betrachten.
Organisation und Behandlung, finde ich, das klingt so aus Verlegenheit,
hat sie wahrscheinlich auch so einfach, sie wollte irgendwie den Satz zu Ende bringen.
Aber das sind im Grunde Grundbegriffe für diesen ganzen Wohnungsmarkt,
Organisation und Behandlung.
Es sind so viele Vorschriften, es sind so viele Subventionsmöglichkeiten,
es sind so viele und da nochmal eine Abgabe und da nochmal eine Steuer und da
nochmal eine Grundsteuer und hier und da alles miteinander verrechnet und so.
Es gibt eigentlich keinen mehr gestalteten Markt als diesen,
wo der Staat wirklich überall drin hängt. und dann ist aber einfach unter dem
ganzen Ding so der Bodenwert explodiert.
Faktor 7000 in 50 Jahren in München oder sowas.
Also das versteht man auch ehrlich gesagt nicht, warum da obwohl in der Bayerischen
Landesverfassung Grund und Boden nochmal extra hervorgehoben wird,
explizit als Eigentum verpflichtet und so.
Warum das dann trotzdem passierte? Also hier, das kann einfach nur durch Lobbyismus
oder wie auch immer erklärbar sein.
Das macht sonst keinen Sinn. Also hier wurde ein Markt einfach so richtig zerstört.
Und dann sagte ich, ja, da sollte man mal einfach...
Das Handlungsvermögen mal wieder nehmen. Jörg Schönborn, das haben wir auch
als Hinweis bekommen aus der Hörerschaft, das ist natürlich gut,
wenn jetzt alle sensibilisiert sind, stellt mal im Grunde unsere Frage.
Ich will einfach aus der Vorbereitung, ich will zwei Zahlen zitieren,
Frau Wager. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht haben Sie eine Idee dazu.
Der deutsche Staat gibt etwa 20 Milliarden Euro jedes Jahr aus,
um Menschen zu helfen, ihre Miete bezahlen zu können. Über Wohngeld,
Grundsicherung und andere Dinge.
Im Verhältnis dazu, die Angaben sind unterschiedlich, was so in sozialen Wohnungsbau
fließt. Bund, Länder, ist auch von Jahr zu Jahr unterschiedlich.
Aber da ist man irgendwo bei drei, vier, vielleicht fünf Milliarden.
Also das heißt, wir geben ein Vielfaches dafür aus,
Menschen zu helfen, teure Mieten zu bezahlen, womit sie am Markt eine Nachfrage
erzeugen, die Mieten steigen, aber wir geben nur einen kleinen Teil dafür aus,
das zu tun, was gerade hier mehrfach gefordert worden ist.
Ja, genau die richtige Frage.
Der Vermieter will Geld? Wir geben es ihm. Der Mieter will eine kostengünstige Wohnung?
Nee. Also wer soll denn das hier machen? Wir sind doch kein Nanny-Staat.
Ja, ich war ja bei Jacobin mit Patrick Schreiner, der über den Sozialstaat jetzt
ein Buch geschrieben hat auf dem Podium.
Und du hast das Vorwort geschrieben. Und der sagte auch, es gibt einen einzigen
Aspekt am Sozialstaat, den die FDP liebt und das ist natürlich das Wohngeld.
Ja, das Wohngeld, diese Dienstwagensachen, dieser ganze Kram.
Aber bei Wohngeld ist es ja tatsächlich Sozialstaat und dass man da sagt,
nee, das ist schon sinnvoll, dass es das gibt.
Ja, es ist nicht nur für die Leute, die diese durch Geburtenlotterie einfach
übernehmen, nicht nur ist es ein bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen,
sondern es hat auch eine garantierte Höhe.
Du siehst einfach so einen Mietspiegel und weißt, die Leute,
die sich das nicht leisten können, stellen für mich einen Wohngeldantrag.
Ja. Das ist einfach genial.
Also das ist wirklich, das gibt es wahrscheinlich weltweit, wenn so nur vergleichbar
in Amerika oder so, dass man solche Arten
von Ausbeutung da irgendwie institutionalisiert und überall absichert.
Naja, Buschmann macht jetzt hier mal so einen Satz, wo ich sage,
das ist sehr weitsichtig, das ist sehr klug. und daran sind Sie schuld.
Aber ich will Folgendes dazu sagen. Natürlich haben wir in Deutschland generell
ein Problem, jetzt sage ich es auch mal ein bisschen theoretisch,
dass wir Geld nicht mehr beliebig in Fähigkeiten oder Zustände konvertieren können.
Warum? Weil viel Geld, das die Politik zur Verfügung stellt, fließt gar nicht ab.
Das hat ein bisschen was mit dem zu tun, was Frau Däubler-Gemelin gerade gesagt
hat, dass wir uns selber auch so ein bisschen so verbürokratisiert haben.
So, das ist eine Lüge. Die Bürokratie ist nicht das Problem.
Die könnten wir ja von heute auf morgen einfach, das ist ja Max Schieritz,
Menge Stellschrauben. Wir haben halt keine Bürokratie.
Aber dieses, wir können in Deutschland nicht mehr beliebig Geld in Zustände transferieren.
Ja, weil wir eine demografische Lage haben, der man einfach Rechnung tragen muss.
Ansonsten ist egal, wenn du 75 Jahre alt bist und fünffacher Millionär,
kommt trotzdem kein Pflegedienst.
Und die nächste Apotheke ist trotzdem 17 Kilometer weit entfernt.
Und das nächste Krankenhaus,
für deine Notfälle, das wirst du in der Notfallzeit nicht erreichen.
Entweder du kriegst halt rechtzeitig die Diagnose oder sonst ist es zu spät.
Also da funktioniert einfach Geld nicht mehr.
Und das sind dann auch echte Wirtschaftskrisen. Es gibt ja so halbechte Wirtschaftskrisen.
Also wenn, keine Ahnung, die in Tagesthemen und heutigen Journalen von Wirtschaftskrise
reden, dann meinen die ja immer zu wenig Geld.
Aber eine echte Wirtschaftskrise ist, wenn auch zu viel Geld es nicht mehr regelt.
Wenn es als Medium einfach ausfällt.
Und dass er das anerkennt und hier Hier aber nochmal versucht,
wieder Bürokratie-Monster-Argument zu machen.
Ne, es ist nicht die Bürokratie, sondern hier sind es einfach andere Mechanismen.
Naja, Marktmechanismen und ihre Zerstörung, also zurück zum Wohnbautag.
Um nochmal beim Kippung zu bleiben, haben wir eben festzustellen,
dass wir drohen, in so ein abrutschendes System abgebauter Kapazitäten reinzukommen.
Und dass wir die 400.000 Wohnungen, die wir im letzten Jahr noch durchaus hätten
errichten können, weil Menschen, Maschinen, Material in Deutschland noch ausreichend
vorhanden war, eben demnächst nicht mehr da sein wird und wir in die Richtung
gehen können, dass wir überhaupt nur noch 200.000 Wohnungen bauen.
Und das ist eben tatsächlich eine fatale Entwicklung. Wir müssen also etwas
anders machen. Wir müssen im Grunde alles anders machen.
Menschen, Maschinen, Material. Nicht Bürokratie.
Die auch. Aber die könnte man im Federstrich. Das könnte Buschmann einfach hier
eine vernünftige Bundestagsentscheidung weg damit.
Aber dass man Menschen, Maschinen und Material noch kaufen kann und er markiert jetzt schon.
Im letzten Jahr hätten wir noch 400.000 Wohnungen mit dem Geld,
das wir haben. Jetzt würde das Geld alleine schon nicht mehr reichen.
Also hier werden wirklich Märkte abgebaut.
Man kann es gar nicht in der Drastik, in der man es betonen möchte, sagen.
Und ich meine, diese Leute gehen
weg oder beziehungsweise sehen die Baubranche nicht mehr als ein Feld,
wo man in Zukunft arbeiten will und ich würde schon nochmal hier stark machen
wollen, dass durch jetzt diese Aufrüstung wir auch dahin kommen,
dass es ein Ringen um diese Art der Arbeitskräfte geht und beim Material ja auch.
Das heißt, natürlich geht nicht jemand, der eben noch Maurer war,
bald Panzer zusammenschrauben, da braucht man natürlich fache Ausbildung,
aber wenn man sich generell Gedanken darüber macht, wie sind menschliche Ressourcen
in Deutschland verteilt, wie viele Leute gibt es, wo sollen die arbeiten,
gibt es genug davon überhaupt, dann ist natürlich immer die Frage,
welche Industrie fördert man gerade und welche nicht.
Und was ich hier sehe ist, dass wir das Bauen ja verkümmern lassen und damit
die Misere mal größer machen und man dann auch noch der Baubranche bald Personal entzieht,
indem einfach andere Arbeitgeber zum Beispiel aus der Rüstungsindustrie die Attraktiveren wären.
Durch diese Industriepolitik, die ja da betrieben werden soll.
Ja, also ich glaube in der Baubranche, wir können ja mal so ein Clip zwischendurch
spielen hier aus der Pflegebranche, bei der Frage…,
Ab wann hat man eigentlich als Branche den zur Verfügung stehenden neuen Jahrgang
ausreichend auf seine Seite gezogen?
Da nennt uns hier Friederik Lauscher, Vorsitzender vom Frankfurter Verband für
Alten- und Behindertenhilfe.
Also der war hier beim HR zu Gast. Mal zahlen.
Wir haben halt einfach zu wenig junge Menschen, die einen Schulabschluss in Deutschland machen.
800.000 Menschen verlassen in Deutschland die Schule.
Über 50.000 davon wählen den Pflegeberuf. Das ist eine sensationelle Quote und
man braucht auch Buchhalter, man braucht Journalistinnen und so weiter und so fort.
Womit wir sehr gute Erfahrungen machen, ist Auszubildende aus dem Ausland holen,
die extrem motiviert sind, aber Deutschland lässt sich schwer verkaufen im Ausland.
Das muss man auch sagen, da stehen wir in Konkurrenz mit anderen und das Thema
Fremdenfeindlichkeit,
das Thema Bürokratie, das spricht sich durchaus rum und da sind wir nicht die
erste Wahl, wenn es darum geht zu sagen, wollt ihr nicht zur Ausbildung nach Deutschland kommen.
Ja, so das betrifft jetzt alle Branchen, auch die Bundeswehr.
So, die Pflege hat von 700.000 zur Verfügung stehenden, 700.000,
800.000 zur Verfügung stehenden jungen Menschen.
Kriegen die gerade jedes Jahr 50.000. Und er sagt völlig zu Recht,
damit ist es ausgebeutet.
Also mehr können wir uns gar nicht versprechen.
Und trotzdem fehlen Hunderttausende.
Also hier sind wir eigentlich wirklich in einem Defizit. Hier kommt man einfach
nicht weiter. Und das, was er im Nachsatz sagte, gilt ja für die Baubranche insbesondere.
Wir sind einfach ein krass ausländerfeindliches Land. Wir kommen hier nicht besonders weit.
Wir müssen sehr gezielt ansprechen. Und das war ja letztes Jahr ein Thema,
als ich da bei dieser einen Veranstaltung war, wo es dann hieß, ja,
also wir haben jetzt einen Bauüberhang und wir wissen, wenn wir den ausleben
und keine neuen Aufträge kommen, dann sind diese Arbeiter weg.
Die haben keinen Bezug zu Deutschland, die arbeiten dann sofort woanders.
Also es ist nicht wie in der Gastro, dass dann einfach, ja, die Studenten kriegen
wir schon mal wieder irgendwie mit dem Fahrrad kurz ins Restaurant zu fahren,
um da zwei Stunden zu arbeiten. Das ist ja hier nicht so.
Fehlen hier dann einfach alle. Das sind einfach Branchen, also hier wird einfach
mal richtig so eine Branche richtig abgewickelt.
Und dazu aber dieser Sinnspruch, was diesen Bedarf nochmal widerspiegelt.
Weil Wohnen ist eben, wie der Ökonom das nüchtern sagt, eben nicht nur ein Konsumgut,
das ist ein Sozialgut und nicht wohnen, nicht wohnen können wir nicht.
Wir können uns diese Branchenabrisse da gar nicht erlauben.
Ganz, ganz, ganz verrückt. So, jetzt haben wir ja verschiedene Branchenvertreter gehört.
Baubranche, also diese Baustoffbranche sagt, das ist Kipppunkt,
wir sehen ja auch nichts am Ende des Tunnels.
Mieterbund sagt, das ist alles total grotesk.
Axel Gadeschko hören wir jetzt vom Verband der Wohnungs- und Immobilienunternehmer.
Herr Gadaschko und Herr Dr. Zapf, wenn Sie das jetzt gehört haben,
diese Studien, die ja nochmal zeigen, dass es durchaus Möglichkeiten gibt, etwas zu ändern.
Herr Gadaschko, wo gäbe es denn für Sie so einen Punkt, wo man sagt,
da müsste man jetzt, das wäre gut, da anzusetzen?
Ja, man muss Ich muss das Ruder ansetzen, denn wir haben gehört,
der Wohnungsbau ist mit das wichtigste Ding in Deutschland und dieses Ding ist im freien Fall.
Unsere Unternehmen investieren in diesem und im letzten Jahr zusammengenommen
minus 50 Prozent, das heißt nur noch die Hälfte von dem, was vorher investiert wurde.
Und das war nicht das, was dazu reichen würde, 400.000 Wohnungen zu bauen. Es reicht nicht.
Eine Branche, die 140 Milliarden Steueraufkommen generiert, 17 Prozent des ganzen
Staatshaushalts, sagt jetzt von Ja auf Ja minus 50 Prozent.
Naja, es kam doch jetzt schon die Meldung, überraschend werden die Staatseinnahmen niedriger sein.
Ja, ganz überraschend. Wie kann das nur passieren? Sieht der Licht am Ende des Tunnels?
Die Situation wird sich im Grunde auch nicht bessern. Wenn gesagt wird,
wir sehen Licht am Horizont, dann muss ich feststellen, wir sehen dieses Licht am Horizont nicht.
Das heißt, die Investitionszahlen unserer Unternehmen gehen weiter zurück.
Mensch, das scheint ja dann ein lustiger Nachmittag gewesen zu sein.
Da kann Manfred Lehmann noch so ein bisschen für Zugzeugen sorgen, aber ansonsten.
Den kann man sich aber auch wahrscheinlich in diesem Jahr das letzte Mal leisten.
Wahrscheinlich, ja. Nächstes Jahr ist er einfach.
Nächstes Jahr macht das so eine KI.
Das stimmt.
Siri liest das einfach vor.
Der nächste Verbandsvertreter deutsches Baugewerbe, ZDB, Wolfgang Schubert-Rab.
Ich möchte nochmal darauf hinweisen, dass wir derzeit von den Zahlen und den
wahrgenommenen Baustellen bei uns in der Republik ein bisschen den Blick verstellt
bekommen für die Situation,
die uns jetzt in den nächsten Zeiten erwarten wird.
Denn das, was wir jetzt in der Vergangenheit gebaut haben, im letzten Jahr,
im vorletzten Jahr, das waren ja Aufträge, die wir vier Jahre lang in die Auftragsbücher
hineinnehmen konnten, die wir jetzt noch abgearbeitet haben.
Es kam aber deutlich weniger nach. Und wenn Sie sich den Ablauf einer Bausituation
vorstellen, dann müssen Sie sich das wie eine lange Leitung vorstellen mit zwei Jahren.
Das, was Sie vorne reingeben, läuft in dieser Leitung zwei Jahre lang,
bis es hinten rausdrüpfelt und dementsprechend wird klar, in welcher Situation
wir in den nächsten Monaten und in den nächsten Jahren sein werden.
Wir werden die Zahlen, die wir alle miteinander anvisiert haben mit den 400.000
über längere Jahre gar nicht erreichen können.
Ja, Mörschheimer hat eben gesagt, er hat Sanders unterstützt wegen des Nation Buildings.
Und dieses Bauen muss man hier ganz wörtlich nehmen.
Wo war denn eigentlich der Wirtschaftsminister?
Baute der in der Zeit gerade die Ukraine wieder auf oder wo war der?
Ja.
Der war doch da das letzte Mal. Warum ist der nicht da?
Also bei der Pressekonferenz jedenfalls nicht. Vielleicht hat er einen Termin
auf der Bühne gehabt oder so. Keine Ahnung.
Siebenkotten versucht jetzt auch mal das große politische Bild.
Wir sagen uns, es gibt Themen wie Verteidigung, wie Klimaschutz,
die große Priorität genießen.
Müsste nicht das Bauen eine genauso große Priorität bekommen?
So, also Verteidigung, Klima, Wohnen. Ich würde sagen...
Damit es was zu verteidigen gibt, sollte man wohnen. Weil die Vorwürfe an die
jungen Leute verteidigen, man würde das Land und man denkt sich so,
der ist gerade nach Stuttgart gezogen, der sucht seit drei Jahren eine Wohnung,
wieso soll der jetzt nach Sachsen fahren, um da Deutschland zu verteidigen?
Der kann dann seinen potenziellen Vermieter in Stuttgart verteidigen.
So, wir haben jetzt einige Zahlen gehört. In Ballungsgebieten Faktor 20 unterhalb
des Bedarfes. ist das Angebot.
Wir haben minus 50% bei 140 Milliarden Steueraufkommen.
70 Milliarden minus heißt das bei diesem Betrag.
Aus allen Richtungen, die Kipppunkte sind überschritten.
Es ist wirklich dramatisch. Wir gucken jetzt ganz kurz noch bei Hard Aber Fair.
Da hat man natürlich, es ist jetzt mehr so stimmungsmäßig, man hat so eine dieser
Regionen mal angesprochen.
Da sieht man, wie die Mieten in den letzten Jahren gestiegen sind.
Sie haben lange in Hamburg gelebt, wo der Wohnungsmarkt auch ziemlich angespannt ist.
Das ist sehr freundlich ausgedrückt.
So, Hamburg. Das ist aber sehr freundlich
ausgedrückt, dass Sie da einen angespannten Wohnungsmarkt sehen.
Ich habe ihn erlebt. Sagt Thiel Wittler hier.
Ja, also sehr viel Geld im Fernsehen verdient und trotzdem, es geht da niemandem
vorbei. Es ist schlimm in Hamburg.
Jetzt hören wir beim Wohnbautag auch so eine kleine Zahl aus Hamburg,
von der wir wissen, es ist jetzt schon schlimm in Hamburg. Jetzt kommt die kleine
Projektion in die nächste Zukunft.
Herr Zalewski noch dazu und dann habe ich hier noch ein paar.
Auch noch eine ganz relativ aktuelle Zahl beitragen. Ich war vor wenigen Wochen
bei unserem Landesverband Nord.
In der Freien und Hansestadt Hamburg sind die Projektbeginne im letzten Jahr
bei unseren Mitgliedsunternehmen um 80 Prozent zurückgegangen.
80 Prozent?
Ja.
Da stehen 400 Leute an, die jede Woche gemeinsam zu einer anderen Wohnung gehen,
um sich die anzuschauen.
Und die kriegen jetzt gesagt, übrigens das Angebot schwindet um 80 Prozent.
Als es der Autowirtschaft in Deutschland mal etwas schlecht zu gehen drohte,
hat man die Abwrackprämie gemacht.
Eine unglaublich teure, schwachsinnige Autoindustrie-Subvention.
Hier ist wirklich Not am Mann und man geht einfach drüber und weg.
Also liebe Hörer, wenn ihr gerade einen Mietvertrag habt, der läuft, niemals kündigen.
Die nächsten zehn Jahre werden keine Wohnungen gekündigt. Ihr findet keine neue.
Ihr denkt, ihr könnt noch irgendwie umziehen. Ihr habt ein Jobangebot in Berlin oder so. Ist nicht.
Ja, in Berlin ist es ja ganz interessant. Ich kenne ja Leute,
die haben einen alten Mietvertrag und ich kenne Leute, die haben einen neuen Mietvertrag.
Und das ist einfach so eine Zweiklassengesellschaft.
Also ich bin auch jemand, der einen alten hat. Und die anderen sagen,
ja, ich habe einen neuen.
Und dann können die sofort sagen, ah ja, dann hast du also nur halb so viel
Geld zur Verfügung wie ich, weil du einfach 50% mehr zahlst.
Ja, wir wollen hier nur andeuten, wie sehr dieses minus 80% in Hamburg,
Faktor 20 in den Ballungsräumen, die Leute unter 30 betrifft.
Ja.
Die Leute über 50 betrifft das nicht. Die wohnen in ihren Dingern.
Ja, manche, also in den Städten, man sieht, also ich finde schon,
dass man jetzt gerade ja etwas beobachten kann, wenn man hier durch die Städte geht.
Ob es Köln ist, wo ich es jetzt viel gesehen habe, Frankfurt auch.
Und man sieht, man sah früher sehr viele Obdachlose, die Flaschen gesammelt haben.
Und jetzt kann man mich natürlich fragen, woher weißt du, dass die Obdachlose
sind? Weil sie aussahen wie Obdachlose.
Ich will jetzt hier nicht in den Diskurs da eintreten, naja,
kann man das dann sehen, Stigmatisierung und so.
Aber was ich jetzt feststellen kann ist, dass sehr viele Menschen zu sehen sind,
die so um die 60 oder um die 70 sind,
die nicht obdachlos zu sein scheinen, die auch noch Klamotten haben,
vielleicht aus ihrer Arbeitszeit, aus einer Zeit, wo es ihnen ein bisschen besser
ging und die Flaschen sammeln.
Und man fragt sich, was ist denn da jetzt los? Ich hatte jetzt in Koblenz kürzlich
eine Frau gesehen, die da so ein bisschen Musik machte auf der Straße und es
sah mir auch eher aus, dass das
für sie jetzt nochmal so eine Möglichkeit ist, ein paar Euro zu machen.
Auch sie sah aus wie eine Seniorin, aber offenbar reicht die Rente nicht und
ich würde mal hinzufügen, um in der Wohnung bleiben zu können.
Und ich glaube, dass sehr viel jetzt stattfindet in diese Richtung,
dass also diese Altersarmut so aussieht, dass die auch nicht sagen können,
na ich verkleinere mich, es ist ja einfach nichts da und sie leben auch oft
gar nicht in großen Wohnungen.
Und wenn sie in städtischen Räumen leben,
dann können sie sich das immer schwerer leisten, dann kommt die Inflation und sowas noch hinzu,
dann haben sie vielleicht diese Mietverträge, die Index gebunden sind,
also an die Inflation gebunden sind und die fangen jetzt an,
Flaschen zu sammeln und das ist die Realität, die auf den Straßen jetzt sehr,
sehr sichtbar geworden ist und klar,
jungen Leute sowieso, bei jeder Veranstaltung bekommt man das natürlich erzählt.
Und vielleicht ist das aber jetzt ein gutes Fundament, um nochmal über Menschenrechte zu reden.
Ich will nur ein paar Clips spielen. Und zwar bin ich gespannt, was du davon hältst.
Und zwar in der Evangelischen Akademie.
Zu Berlin gab es eine Diskussion zwischen Omri Böhm, uns wohl bekannt,
Philosoph Kantianer, hat über den Universalismus ein sehr gutes Buch geschrieben,
wir haben es im Salon, habe ich es mal lange vorgestellt,
wir hatten auch schon mal Sonskripts von ihm, deshalb.
Aber überspringe ich jetzt die Rede von Omri Böhm, wie er den Universalismus begründet.
Er macht das mit Kant und wir kennen so in etwa die Argumente und können das
ja auch sonst nochmal schnell nachlesen. Und ich würde jetzt gerne zu seinem
Counterpart gehen, nämlich Christoph Möllers, den haben wir eben schon mal gehört
mit seinen Bemerkungen.
Naja, bemerkenswert ist ja schon, die AfD glaubt noch an die Politik.
Und er ist ein Mann, der Staatsrechtler ist,
der aber auch ein Buch über Normen geschrieben hat und sagt,
naja, Normen, da denken wir immer, die müssen wir so ganz groß begründen.
Das ist eher so eine Praxis.
Er ist eigentlich kein Soziologe, aber ich habe so den Eindruck,
wenn ich ihn so reden höre, dass es doch soziologische Aspekte bei ihm gibt.
So und er fängt jetzt an, auch über die Menschenrechte zu reden und wir hören
da jetzt erstmal rein bei der Evangelischen Akademie, was da gesagt wird.
Oder als Rechtswissenschaftler irgendwie auf diesen ganzen Menschenrechtsdiskurs
zu schauen und das, wenn man so will, gar nicht zynisch, gar nicht irgendwie
jetzt in dem Sinne abwerten oder so, aber doch mit einer gewissen,
vielleicht sogar Verzweiflung darüber,
dass ich glaube, dass es eigentlich mit diesem Diskurs so in der Praxis vorbei
ist und dass ich glaube, dass wir
eigentlich diesen Menschenrechtsdiskurs irgendwie gerade eher abwickeln.
Also er ist jetzt nicht jemand, der sagt, jetzt kommt die große Stunde der Menschenrechte,
ist also nicht wie der Gast dabei, Richard David Precht, sondern er sieht das
sehr skeptisch mit einem Bedauern.
Er sagt folgendes auch.
Da würde man sagen, naja, wir haben diesen semantischen Konsens,
aber wir haben natürlich auch durchaus relevante Praktiken, die diesem Konsens
in gewisser Weise doch erstaunlich weit gegen das Recht geworden sind.
Wir haben Emanzipationsgeschichten, wir haben Demokratisierungsgeschichten,
wir haben sozusagen eine Vielzahl von politischen Gemeinschaften.
Wir können eine Vielzahl von politischen Gemeinschaften beobachten,
in denen die Menschenrechts-ED sich Bahn gebrochen hat und dazu beigetragen
hat, dass Menschen befreit werden aus Abhängigkeiten, aus staatlichem Unrecht,
aus privaten Verhältnissen, aus feudalen Strukturen und so weiter und so fort.
Historisch draufgeblickt war das ein sehr erfolgreicher Diskurs.
Man kann sich ja erstmal umgekehrt fragen, gibt es eigentlich irgendeinen Diskurs,
der so erfolgreich war wie der Menschenrechtsdiskurs, sei es seit 1800,
seit Thomas Bain oder sei es seit 1945 mit Blick auf die allgemeine Deklaration der Menschenrechte.
In der wir ja doch einen gewaltigen, erst einmal vielleicht semantischen Konsens
darüber begründet haben, dass Menschenrechte eine wichtige oder vielleicht sogar
die zentrale normative Referenz zur Organisation von Gesellschaften sind.
Aber es ist auch daraus die eine oder andere Schwierigkeit entstanden.
Man wird dann auch gleich, glaube ich, dazu sagen, dass diese Befreiungsgeschichten
als solch natürlich, und das ist ja klar, das ist eine Trivialität,
man muss es dann doch nochmal sagen, natürlich nicht universal funktioniert
haben, sondern immer nur unter sehr, sehr spezifischen politischen Gelingensbedingungen.
Sie haben meistens in demokratischen Nationalstaaten funktioniert,
seltener in regionalen Kontexten von, sagen wir mal so, Menschenrechtsverbindungen,
Menschenrechtspakten, wie wir das vielleicht irgendwie in Lateinamerika heute
auch sehen, im europäischen Kontext sehen und eigentlich nie universell.
Also man kann sagen, der Übergang, der faktische Übergang vom demokratischen,
nationalen, erfolgreichen Menschenrechtsschützenden Nationalstaat zur regionalen Integration,
zur internationalen, universalen Menschenrechtsschutz war fast immer auch ein
Umschlag einer benevolenten, freiheitsermöglichen Praxis zur institutionellen Heuchelei.
Der institutionellen Heuchelei, die dafür sorgt, dass Saudi-Arabien heute dem
Rat für Frauenrechte der Vereinten Nationen vorsetzt.
Also da können wir jetzt noch tausend andere Beispiele für geben.
Eben, ja, da stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Also die Säugerei sehen wir ja überall, gerade jetzt, wo ja Steffen Harbarth als,
Verfassungsgerichtsvorsitzender ganz viele Interviews gegeben hat,
um nochmal das Grundgesetz abzufeiern, was er ja sehr klug macht,
weil er dann immer wieder auf die Praxis des Gerichts zu sprechen kommt und
darüber hinaus einfach das Gerede den Politikern, den er ja nicht mal angehört hat, lässt.
Und dann war aber auch die Frage im Raum, ob sich das Verfassungsgericht zu sehr einmischt.
Und dann gab es eine Stelle in einem dieser Interviews, wo er so meinte,
nee, wenn das Gericht gefragt wird, wie hoch der Mindestbedarf ist,
damit irgendwelche Armutsschwellen und so weiter beim Bürgergeld greifen,
dann nimmt man sich Artikel 1, die Menschenwürde, und rechnet dann in Zahlen aus, was das bedeutet.
Und dann hat man eine politische Vorgabe, dieser Wert darf nicht unterschritten werden,
Und wenn dann die CDU kommt und sagt, nee, wir würden aber gerne weniger Bürgergeld
zahlen, dann ist das nicht vereinbar und auch im Grunde nicht möglich,
weil man hinter diese Gerichtsentscheidung einfach auch nicht mit politischer
Mehrheit dahinter kommt.
So, und da an solchen Sachen, muss man sagen, wird es dann doch mal wieder konkretisiert,
obwohl man immer den Verdacht hat, naja, diese Heuchelei ist halt überall.
Da muss man nicht erst mit Saudi-Arabien und dem Menschenrechtsrat der UN oder
so, sondern flächendeckend.
Ja, Böhm kommt jetzt nochmal hier zu Wort und sagt, wie er die Situation jetzt so gerade auffasst.
Er hat ja dann auch schon zuvor davon erzählt, dass ja seine Studenten zunächst
einmal dem Universalismus doch zugeneigt erscheinen,
denn sie sind doch auch für Freiheit und Gleichheit und so und dann aber bringen
sie ihre Identitätspolitik mit hinein. Er sagt nun.
Also er redet jetzt von den Kritikern der Identitätspolitik.
Die sagen ja jetzt eigentlich auch immer, wir sind Universalisten.
Wir sehen aber jetzt, das kann man besonders gut in Deutschland jetzt am Naus-Konflikt
ablesen, dass also die, die über Identitätspolitik sich die ganze Zeit lustig
gemacht haben, betreiben jetzt ihre Identitätspolitik.
Also Weltredakteure betreiben ihre Identitätspolitik und Proststadt macht jetzt
seine Identitätspolitik.
Und unserer Gründe dafür, einige Ideen zu unterstützen.
Und weiter sagt er.
Cover their own identities in Spiel.
So I think that those are basically the reasons for the collapse of this conversation.
The question is, I would argue, whether we have to still defend such a language.
Ja, Identitätspolitik. Gib mir doch einen kleinen Exkurs, einen Clip.
Denn wir haben ja jetzt, auch wenn er sagt, in die Richtung muss man jetzt nicht
gehen, weil kontroverses Thema, aber dieses ganze Israel-Fragen und so.
Wir hatten jetzt in Deutschland diese Sylt-Sache.
Und das ist ja wirklich erstaunlich, inwieweit jetzt dieses,
naja, solange es die Identitätskämpfe der anderen und so weiter,
deren Selbstbehauptungen, dann stehen wir da und machen uns drüber lustig.
Nur jetzt sind es ja nicht irgendwelche jungen amerikanischen Studenten mit
Einwanderungsgeschichte oder was auch immer, die sich zur Hamas so bekennen,
dass wir von hier aus sagen, nee, das geht aber nicht, das ist ja völlig Was machen die denn da?
Sondern wir haben plötzlich unser Eins, also nicht importierter Antisemitismus
im Sinne von, mit Ausländern habe ich nichts zu tun, ich werde ja nie einer sein.
Achso, die Superreichen sind jetzt auch Antisemiten.
Ich wollte ja eigentlich auch mal superreich sein, so ungefähr.
Also man hat eh schon so ein völlig falsches Bild da von den Leuten in Sylt.
Man stellt dann fest, achso, doch keine Superreichen, die arbeiten als Handlanger
für irgendwelche Influencer oder sowas.
Also ich habe es nicht genau verfolgt, aber das waren ja dann so die Geschichten.
Und Dagmar Rosenfeld macht dann in ihrem Podcast Machtwechsel folgenden,
also sie steigert sich da so rein in folgende Fragestellung.
Also diese grölende Menge mit Nazis gleichzusetzen, ist doch eigentlich auch
eine Relativierung dessen, was ein Nazi ist.
Ja, also das... Naja, die Frage ist doch,
ist das, was auf Sylt geschehen ist, ein Ausdruck einer rechtsextremen Gesinnung,
die es in die bürgerliche Mitte und zu den ganz Wohlhabenden geschafft hat?
Also jetzt kommen wirklich alle Identitätsparadoxien auf einmal.
Ich bin ja auch deutsch. Also ich bin deutsch, aber kein Nazi.
Das haben wir ja schon mal jetzt historisch geklärt.
Und mit Christian war ich doch auch immer auf Sylt. Was ist da los?
Genau, so. Aber dann auch dieses...
Hat es diese Ideologie jetzt zu den Reichen in Deutschland geschafft?
Denn wir wissen ja, sonst war ja Rechteideologie immer nur eine Sache für arme Leute.
Ich meine, der ganze Neonazismus 1.0 war der übrig gebliebene Adel und so weiter,
dient sich da an, die ganzen Industriellen brauchen und dann haben wir ein Zwangsarbeitermuseum,
das das Schicksal von 20 Millionen Menschen uns in Weimar erklärt und wir eröffnen
es, nee, nicht 1954, sondern 2024.
So lange hat es gebraucht, bis wir dann irgendwann mal so, ah ja, hm.
Ja, und wir können auch mal bei unseren deutschen Konzernen auf den Homepages
nachgucken, wie die mit dieser dunklen Zeit umgehen.
Es ist wirklich haarsträubend.
Es ist, ja, sehr schön.
Aber da verirrt sich halt überall so dieses, nee, eigentlich bin ich voll der
Universalist, der deutsche Nicht-Nazi und meine Familie war auch immer im Widerstand
und so weiter und so fort.
Und ich habe mir dann nochmal so eine Notiz von Greta, weil es hier auch wieder
so in der Morgenpost, Post, keine Ahnung, dass Greta jetzt droht,
ihr ganzes Erbe aufs Spiel zu setzen, weil sie jetzt vom Klima auf Gaza umgeschwenkt ist.
Da dachte ich auch wieder, naja, beim Thema Klima wurde ihr ja immer angedichtet.
Greta kämpft nicht für sich, sondern stellvertretend für uns alle.
Sie möchte uns im Grunde von unserem blöden Verhalten so ein bisschen also da
steckt ja das Uruniversalistische, ich opfere mich für die Gemeinschaft, Klima geht uns alle an.
So, für mich ist das funktional betrachtet ein ganz kurzer Weg zu sagen,
ich möchte alle Menschen vor Klimaerwärmung schützen,
zu ich möchte alle Menschen vor Gewalt schützen und dann eben nicht mit dieser
deutschen Schuldfrage belastet und überhaupt, weil sie halt U20 ist in Schweden,
ja, da kann man halt schon mal ein bisschen lockerer, sagen wir mal,
über, keine Ahnung, hier liegt so ein Mutkrake auf meiner Dings oder wie auch immer.
Gut, das war ja eh aufgeklärt.
Aber das jetzt überhaupt als Frage,
also dass ja gar nicht die Kontinuität des Universalismus in diesem Denken und
Verhalten einer jungen Frau drin steckt, sondern dass man jetzt plötzlich sagt,
nee, für die Menschheit wegen Klima ist okay,
aber dann Gaza, nee, dann ist sie ja voll Hamas und so weiter und voll die Antisemitin.
Also dann ist sie ja nicht mehr universalistisch für die die Opfer,
denen wirklich die ganze Lebensgrundlage in Gaza weggebombt wurde,
sondern müssen wir unbedingt das ganze Vorzeichen umdrehen.
Und dass das die jungen Leute nicht verstehen, was der Vorwurf ist,
verstehe ich wieder total. Also es ist einfach.
Hier kommt dieser universelle Spur. Ich habe meine Schwierigkeiten deshalb damit,
weil ich hier so weit gehen würde und das sind natürlich Unterstellungen,
aber naja, nicht nur Unterstellungen, sondern man hat ja auch einige Aussagen
von Greta Thunberg gehabt,
die jetzt mehr sind als einfach nur, ich nehme an einem Protest teil,
dass ich glaube, dass dieser Dieser antikolonialistische Impetus,
aus dem heraus das entsteht.
Doppelstandard setzt und am Ende nicht universalistisch ist.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass Greta Thunberg in der gleichen Weise für einen Universalismus
eintritt, wie jetzt Omri Böhm,
der ja auch ein scharfer Kritiker der israelischen Regierung ist, das tut,
sondern ich habe, und da kommt jetzt auch gleich noch was zu,
ich habe den Verdacht, Dass wir so eine neue Art des antikolonialistischen Kampfes erleben,
der nicht universalistisch ist,
sondern der sagt, Kampf gegen Unterdrückung irgendwie ist generell gut,
aber das muss nicht bedeuten, dass man daraus etwas Universalistisches ableitet.
Und ich glaube, wir haben ja auch das Buch von Veit Selck ausführlich besprochen
im Salon und er sagt ja auch am Ende, ja, wohin wird sich das so alles bewegen, er weiß es nicht,
Demokratie, Dämmerung, aber da ist noch diese postkoloniale Theorie.
Die gar nicht demokratisch zum Teil ist.
Was sagt die genau?
Also die dann durchaus eine Affinität haben kann zu autoritären Regimen.
Wir springen gerade mal zu diesem Arte-Beitrag.
Alle werden ja in diesem Monat nach Neu-Kaledonien geblickt haben.
Nein, natürlich niemand. Also kaum einer.
Neu-Kaledonien. Wo liegt das?
Ja, das ist, wenn du so ein Dreieck bildest zwischen Australien,
Neuseeland, Australien, Fidschi, so da in diesem Bereich ist Neu-Kaledonien, gehört zu Frankreich.
Dort ist Macron hingereist, eiligst, weil dort Aufstände toben.
Und wir hören jetzt mal gerade in diesen Beitrag rein, was da eigentlich in
Neukaledonien so abgeht.
Herzlich willkommen. Heute richten wir den Blick erneut auf Neukaledonien nach
den gewalttätigen Unruhen in dem französischen Überseegebiet im Pazifik.
Frankreichs Staatspräsident ist dort nach einer Reise von 17.000 Kilometern eingetroffen.
An einer geplanten Verfassungsreform hatten sich die Krawalle entzündet.
Bei Provinzwahlen sollen all jene stimmberechtigt sein, die in Neukaledonien
geboren sind oder seit mindestens zehn Jahren dort leben.
Also 17.000.
Kilometer ist es weit weg.
Naja, das liegt zwischen Fidschi und Australien. Da muss man schon weit weg.
Hat man da keinen Stadthalter oder so?
Der musste dahin, der hat auch einen wichtigen Termin abgesagt,
weil es da um etwas geht. Und zwar folgendes.
Die Gegner der Reform sehen darin eine Maßnahme zur Beschränkung des politischen
Einflusses der Sibylle.
Ach ja, das müsste ich vielleicht kurz aufklären. Also es gibt...
Eine indigene Bevölkerung, die zum Teil autonom sein will, also sich loslösen will von Frankreich.
Frankreich braucht aber diesen Ort natürlich, will diesen Ort haben und auch
eine Mehrheit der Bevölkerung, es gab also mehrere Referenten inzwischen,
ist dafür, dass man dabei bleibt.
Aber jetzt ist dieser Konflikt erneut ausgebrochen,
weil man nun eine neue Wahlrechtsreform hat und die führt dazu,
dass Zugezogene, die erst zehn Jahre dort leben, auch wählen dürfen.
Eigentlich was ganz Modernes. Dadurch aber dürfen viel mehr wählen,
womit die Stimme der Indigenen natürlich dann im Verhältnis abgeschwächt wird und das ist der Protest.
Paratisten. Dabei wurden bereits drei Referenden zum Verbleib der Inselgruppe
bei Frankreich abgehalten und jedes Mal stimmte eine Mehrheit dafür.
Nun ist es so, dass also bislang vielen Bürgern das Wahlrecht gar nicht ermöglicht wurde.
Das wird jetzt damit ermöglicht. Die Indigenen sind aber sehr sauer jetzt darüber,
dass natürlich ihre eigene Position, ihre eigene Stimme schwächt.
Ich will das jetzt gar nicht in allen Einzelheiten beurteilen.
Das ist etwas, wo ich jetzt nur deletieren müsste. Aber wir hören uns jetzt
mal noch an, warum eigentlich diese Insel wichtig ist.
Der Wohlstand des Gebietes beruht zum großen Teil auf der Förderung von Nickel.
Weltweit hat Neukaledonien die drittgrößte Fördermenge und die fünftgrößten Reserven.
Aber es geht auch um Frankreichs Stellung im Pazifik und um die Verteidigung seiner Interessen.
Etwa 560.000.
Menschen leben in den drei französischen Außengebieten im Pazifik.
Also 250.000, 270.000, das ist nicht besonders viel,
aber wir haben es hier mit einer Bevölkerung zu tun, die sehr viel Alkohol zu
sich nimmt, sehr viel Cannabis.
Also es ist ein großes Problem, sehr viele Straftaten stehen auch in diesem Zusammenhang.
Arbeitslosenquote, das sind jetzt Zahlen von 2018, bei etwa 12 Prozent.
Das Leben ist sehr viel teurer, es ist 33 Prozent teurer als in Frankreich.
Lebensmittel 73 Prozent teurer als in Frankreich.
Mindestlohn und Durchschnittseinkommen sind aber 20 Prozent geringer als in Frankreich.
Das heißt, es ist eine Bevölkerung, der es nicht besonders gut geht.
Nickel ist natürlich wichtig für sie, zerstörte aber auch einiges. Und wir hören weiter.
Seinen Überseegebieten verdankt Frankreich eine ausschließliche Wirtschaftszone
von insgesamt über 10 Millionen Quadratkilometern. Davon entfallen 1,7 Millionen auf Neukaledonien.
Damit verfügt Frankreich nach den USA über das zweitgrößte Seegebiet der Welt.
Außerdem verfügt Frankreich im südlichen Pazifik über eine beachtliche Militärpräsenz
mit 3.000 Soldaten in Noumea und 3.000 in Papeete.
So, und China ist natürlich auch sehr interessiert an dieser Region.
Sowohl in Neukaledonien als auch in Französisch-Polynesien leben viele Chinesinnen
und Chinesen und Pekings antiwestlicher
Diskurs kommt bei einem Teil der indigenen Bevölkerung gut an.
Sie meinen immer noch, in einer Kolonie zu leben.
Das heißt also, dieser Antikolonialismus kann sich sehr gut auch mit einem chinesischen
Autoritarismus verbinden.
Und jetzt kommt noch ein Funfact und ich empfehle diesen Artikel von Silvia
Stöber auf tagesschau.de sehr lang,
sehr ausführlich, wie Aserbaidschan sich gerade einmischt und die Indigenen
dort unterstützt und man überlegt, hä, was hat denn das jetzt damit zu tun?
3.600 Kilometer sitzt der Aliyev weg und was macht er da?
Ja, diese 13.600 Kilometer mögen zwar weit entfernt sein, aber man kann hier über Bande spielen,
nämlich Frankreich ist ja durchaus den Armeniern zugeneigt, was in Aserbaidschan
auf Unmut stößt und jetzt rächt man sich auf diese Weise, verkauft das aber so,
dass es einem wichtig ist, dass Menschen dort ihren Befreiungskampf führen dürfen.
Und so unterstützt man also die Indigenen dort.
Ich kenne mich zu wenig da aus, um jetzt diesen Konflikt an sich beurteilen
zu können, inwieweit die Anliegen der Indigenen richtig sind oder falsch sind.
Ich will nur sagen, diese Seite gibt es, wo also da nicht etwas Universalistisches
unbedingt in Anschlag gebracht werden kann.
Und weil ich jetzt eben so sagte, da gibt es aber ökonomisch einige Verwerfungen
und große Ungleichheit und große Armut, können wir also hier eigentlich jetzt
wieder anknüpfen an diese Debatte Omri Böhm-Möllers, nämlich diese Frage.
Wie begründe ich jetzt den Universalismus? Ich kann das mit Kant prima machen
und Omri Böhm beherrscht das perfekt.
Reicht das aus oder müsste man nicht eine andere Begründung haben?
Du bist ja auch jemand, der sagt, jetzt kommen wir nicht nochmal mit dem alten Königsberger an.
Wir leben jetzt 2024.
Egal was der da gesagt hat in Königsberg.
Naja, er hat ja in Tweetlänge kommuniziert, was zumindest bei uns heute noch bleibt.
Man muss ja nicht das ganze Buch lesen, um alles zu verstecken.
Aber ganz schlecht ist auch nicht. Aber gut, wir hören uns jetzt an,
was Möllers jetzt also antwortet, nachdem wir das gehört haben.
Also Möllers knüpft jetzt an Böhms Kritik der Identitätspolitik erstmal an.
Und warum ist ihnen in gewisser Weise diese Selbstverständlichkeit verloren gegangen?
Das hat natürlich erstmal, glaube ich, tatsächlich so ein bisschen was damit
zu tun, dass der Menschenrechtsdiskurs sehr lange Zeit mit einer gewissen Selbstverständlichkeit
auf erstens mal seine eigene Referenz operieren konnte.
Was meine ich damit? Damit meine ich, man konnte sich relativ sicher sein,
was eigentlich von Menschenrechten geschwärft und durch Menschenrechte geschützt
sind, nämlich Menschen.
Und diese Referenz ist in eine massive Krise geraten im Moment,
dadurch, dass wir im Grunde einen, und ich will das gar nicht kritisch sagen,
aber ich glaube, da liegt ein trotzdem funktionales Problem,
einen komplett entgrenzten Menschenrechtsdiskurs haben, der anfängt mit Naturereignissen,
mit Tieren, mit anderen Objekten, mit zukünftigen Generationen,
in gewisser Weise die gute normative Botschaft des auf Menschen bezogenen Menschenrechts
im Grunde zu vermitteln.
Sondern auch in der Subjektivität des Adressaten zu verallgemeinern.
So nach dem Motto, was für Menschen hilft, hilft auch für andere.
Für zukünftige Generationen, die ja keine Menschen sind, sondern erstmal eine
demoskopische Fiktion oder eine demografische Fiktion.
Also diese Ausweitung der Menschenrechte glaube ich, ist schon etwas,
was wir erleben können und was man ja auch da beobachten kann,
dass plötzlich Autokraten sich gerne auf die Menschenrechte anfangen zu beziehen.
Ja, aber nicht nur die Autokraten. Es ist auch das Bundesverfassungsgericht,
da sagt der Buhmer darf sich nicht auf sein Menschenrecht auf Urlaub beziehen,
wenn danach alle ab 2035 reise ich nicht mehr in den Urlaub dürfen.
Die haben auch noch Freiheitsrechte.
Das ist noch nicht Long-Term-Mission.
Gegen den wir uns auch beschäftigen.
Aber den haben wir ja auch schon gesehen. Der anfängt schon bei D-Growth und
dann weitergeht bis ja, wir brauchen tausend Mozarts in tausend Jahren.
Dann das Problem der Externalisierung.
Der dritte Punkt, der ein bisschen technischer ist, den ich mal ganz kurz erwähnen
will, hängt damit zusammen und das ist ein eigenes Thema, das ich gar nicht
groß ansprechen will, aber das ein bisschen damit zu tun hat,
dass mit der ökologischen Krise und gerade auch mit der Klimakrise der Zusammenhang
zwischen Handlung und Verantwortung verloren gegangen ist.
Weil wir im Grunde mittlerweile bei sehr vielen Handlungen, die wir machen,
die auch legal sind und die auch geschützt sind, Externalitäten produzieren,
Vulgo, CO2, die wir im Grunde selber nicht mehr irgendwie einfangen können.
Und das scheint mir eine sehr wichtige Voraussetzung jeder Form von subjektivem
Rechtsschutz, aber auch individual, jedes Form von Individualrechtsschutz,
aber auch von Menschenrechtsschutz zu sein, dass irgendwie Handlungen geschützt
sind, deren Folgen irgendwie von denjenigen, die handeln, eingefangen werden
können und die sagen anderen nicht.
Ich meine, der Versuch wird unternommen, aber wir können es ganz konkret machen.
Wenn der Netanyahu jetzt ein Zelt zerbombt, dann kann man den dafür zur Verantwortung ziehen.
Wenn ich jetzt mit meinem Privatjet durch die Gegend fahre oder einfach mit
meinem Linienflugzeug hin und her fliege, wenn ich die Heizung aufdrehe und
das Fenster öffne, ich bekomme…,
Keine Strafen, es ist überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Es wird nicht geahndet, kann nicht geahndet werden.
Ich verursache aber in anderen Teilen der Welt ein Desaster, wie wir sehen.
Und das macht es einfach nur, er beschreibt ja nur, dass es das schwierig macht.
Und dann sagt er auch, diese Überhöhung der Menschenrechte in Verbindung mit
dem Grundgesetz ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen schwierig.
Wir reden natürlich jetzt, wie wir heute über Menschenrechte reden,
reden wir natürlich noch nicht so lange.
Wir reden, weil wir sozusagen eine, wenn ich über die bundesrepublikanische
Gesellschaft reden darf, natürlich uns eine gewaltige Selbsterziehung irgendwie,
Gott sei Dank, zugemutet hat, die uns sozusagen die Möglichkeit eröffnet, darüber zu reden.
Gerade das Beispiel der Menschenwürde in Artikel 1 des Grundgesetzes ist ja
ein schönes Beispiel dafür, dass das erstmal ja doch ein bisschen was anderes war.
Das war ja so ein bisschen säkularisiertes katholisches Naturrecht,
Dass ja auch in den ersten zehn Jahren für manche Schandtat benutzt wurde,
von der Penalisierung von Homosexualität bis sonst was.
Und dass ja sozusagen in seinem emanzipatorischen Glanz vermutlich eine Erfindung
der 60er, 70er Jahre ist.
Also das ist natürlich gar kein normatives Argument dagegen,
aber es zeigt natürlich schon, irgendwie kriegen wir die reine Sache nie,
sondern wir kriegen sie ja doch immer nur als irgendwie ein Regime,
das gepflegt werden will.
Wo redet der da? Das klingt mir auch ein bisschen zu flapsig, ehrlich gesagt.
Der redet aber immer so. Das macht das auch mitunter sehr amüsant.
Sehr zurückgelehnt. Das sind alles streitbare Punkte. Entgrenzung des Menschheitsbegriffs
oder des Menschenbegriffs.
Oder hier, das sind so Dekos, die man sich in den 70er Jahren herangeheuchelt hat. Ja.
Ist dich Christoph Möllers eigentlich wie du? Nein, ich weiß nicht.
Ich finde es nicht so gut. Er ist nicht so überzeugt.
Naja, aber es ist doch so, dass das Grundgesetz, also er bringt ja gerade das
Homosexualität unter Strafverstand und dass man dann aber später die Unantastbarkeit der Menschenwürde,
dass man dies dann zu einem emanzipatorischen Projekt macht oder beziehungsweise damit koppelt,
dass das nicht so sein muss.
Damit sagt er doch nur, dass auch dies so eine Historizität hat und auch deswegen
ja heute, also das bestätigt sich ja auch dadurch, dass man jetzt plötzlich
das Thema Klima an Artikel 1 bindet.
Das wäre ja selbst in den 80er Jahren noch nicht denkbar gewesen.
Ja, trotzdem habe ich was dagegen, wenn irgendetwas zu flapsig so abgeräumt wird.
Im Sinne von, ich sage Ihnen nur, was historisch stattfindet, es wurde aussortiert.
Und ich sage, nee, die Welt ist im Wandel.
Und man kann auch sich ruhig mal den neuen und gegenwärtigen Phänomen zuwenden
und erklären, warum etwas so ist, wie es ist und nicht, es funktioniert anders als früher.
Ja, da sind ein paar Sachen rausgefallen.
Er stellt jetzt fest, es ist voraussetzungsreich. Jetzt haben wir eben schon
gesehen, also dieser antikoloniale Kampf dort in Neukaledonien,
das hat auch viel mit Ökonomie zu tun und wir können ja auch sagen,
also dass wir jetzt über gewisse Dinge in Bezug auf Menschenrechte reden,
hat natürlich auch damit zu tun, dass wir andere ökonomische Bedingungen haben.
Das heißt, es ist also nicht einfach nur eine philosophische Überlegung und
dann eine Begründung, die daraus abzuleiten ist.
Und das ist ja sein Kontrapunkt zu Omri Böhm.
Und dann kann man sagen, naja, okay, also es gibt vielleicht auch andere Rahmen,
in denen es immer noch...
Indikatoren dafür gibt, dass es ein bisschen Freiheitsbedürfnis gibt.
Ich kann sagen, also solange Diktaturen Zwang anwenden müssen,
ist da irgendwie noch was?
Das ist ja ein Argument von Fukuyama, dass man sagt, also eigentlich gibt es
da schon so einen generellen Freiheitsdrang in den Menschen.
Man kann sich dann aber fragen, vielleicht ist das der Punkt auch irgendwann
überschritten, vielleicht muss man in China irgendwann gar keinen Zwang mehr ansetzen.
Also ich weiß es nicht, aber man muss es jedenfalls beobachten,
dass man glaube ich schon sagen kann, es gibt nichts, nichts daran ist selbstverständlich,
dass sich Gesellschaften auf Menschenrechte berufen.
Ich finde es gut, wenn sie es tun. Ich habe ja keine normative Kritik an der
Figur. Ich glaube nur, der Voraussetzungsreichtum ist doch immens.
Und der wird sozusagen nicht erfüllt, dadurch, dass man weiß, wie man sie begründet.
Das ist, glaube ich.
Erst mal nur der zentrale Punkt.
Braucht man die Begründung? Du hast jetzt schon gesagt, wir können ja so ein
paar Tweets von Kant lesen, aber wir brauchen jetzt gar nicht die Bücher. Er geht ja noch weiter.
Nur glaube ich tatsächlich, dass diese Begründung selbst eine freie Option ist
und man auch auf die Begründung verzichten können muss.
Das scheint mir sehr wichtig zu sein. Ich glaube, es gibt auch eine Freiheit vom Begründen.
Und ich glaube, dass Leute sozusagen eine Ordnung beobachten können,
sagen, ich will diese Ordnung oder ich will sie nicht, ich will nicht leben
wie in Russland und man ihnen sozusagen die Begründung nicht abverlangen muss dafür.
Und ich glaube tatsächlich, so synkretistisch funktionieren funktionale,
funktionierende politische Gemeinschaften, funktionieren so,
dass manche Leute begründen viel, aber auch nicht und sich andere und ihre Überzeugungen
woanders herholen und vielleicht nicht unbedingt von Begründungen überzeugt sind.
Also da kommt halt sehr viel zusammen und ich glaube, ein Menschenrechtsdiskurs,
der sozusagen sagt, ihr habt jetzt, mein bestes Argument für Menschenrechte
ist ein politisches, ist ein moralisches,
ob ihr davon was habt, ob ihr damit ein schöneres Leben führt,
ob das euren Interessen entspricht, das vergessen wir mal alles.
Das ist halt ein Menschenrechtsdiskurs, der sozusagen die Menschenrechtsidee
selber eher in den Abgrund führen würde, da bin ich relativ sicher.
Ja, also wir haben ja diese Beobachtung aus China, dass die kommunistische Partei
ein klares Ziel hat, erstens an der Macht zu bleiben, zweitens vom Volk nicht bedroht zu werden.
Und dann hatten sie ja gedacht, okay, wir nutzen mal Corona und machen ganz
harte normative Beschränkungen. Jeder kriegt eine App und dann wird da einfach
in Rot, Gelb, Grün angezeigt, in dieser Straße darfst du gehen,
in diesem Bus darfst du einsteigen, hier darfst du einkaufen, wie auch immer.
Und dann haben sie festgestellt, nee, das funktioniert nicht.
Also dieser normative, wir müssen die ganze Zeit begründen, Anweisung geben,
Befehl, nee, wir müssen so eine Etage weiter intrinsisch in die Menschen reinprogrammieren.
Und dann von heute auf morgen Umstellung, nein, wir machen jetzt wieder das
Aufstiegsversprechen, wir fördern und du bist bitte fleißig,
Und findest den Weg selber.
Das heißt, es ist in deinem Interesse, dass du Chineser bist. Genau.
Es ist einfach in deinem Interesse. Du wirst ökonomisch erfolgreicher sein.
Das, was du eigentlich willst.
Also dieses Sicherheitsversprechen, du kriegst kein Corona, hat man wieder eingetauscht
mit, du kannst dein Leben verwirklichen.
Ein bisschen mehr als vorher. Und wenn man von heute auf morgen,
so schnell wie das aufgehoben wurde, also einfach mal so einen Tagesvergleich
sieht, sieht man, okay, das ist wirklich ein krasser Umbau dieses ganzen Systems,
der ja auch in diese Richtung, wie er führt.
Wenn die Chinesen jetzt dabei geblieben wären, eine Milliarde Menschen jeden
Morgen eine Stunde lang zu begründen,
warum sie jetzt, und Corona ist ganz gefährlich und dann kommt der nächste Film,
der das nochmal zeigt, wie auch immer, also dieses nordkoreanische Modell,
wo alle in so einer Gesamtreligion irgendwie drinstecken,
würde ich sagen, ja, aber es wäre doch sehr viel interessanter,
wenn man das empirisch auf der Bühne zeigen würde, statt immer nur von der Begründung
und wie Kant und hier ist der Untergang und so.
Ich bin nicht so überzeugt von diesem Möller. Ich bin ja kein Empiriker selbst
und ich brauche nicht immer Empirie, wenn das kluge Argument,
kann ja da sein und also was doch erstmal verständlich ist, ist,
dass wir doch auch jetzt, nehmen wir mal einen anderen Begriff als die Menschenrechte.
Wir haben den Begriff der Demokratie.
Und man redet jetzt gerade allen Leuten ein, dass sie die Demokratie zu lieben haben.
Jetzt sehen wir, dass vierköpfige Familien in zwei Zimmern hausen,
seit drei Jahren Wohnungen suchen.
Und denen kann ich jetzt zurufen, gell, das ist doch schön mit der Demokratie.
Freust du dich schon? Was hat das Grundgesetz für dich getan?
Nächsten Monat kannst du wählen gehen. Herrlich. Nein.
Ich kann nur nur deren Grundlage verbessern.
Also das heißt, die ...
Demokratie und die Menschenrechte sind also auch unter gewissen Voraussetzungen
nur dann wirklich etwas, was erstrebt wird.
Ich kann das immer noch mit Kant dann genau begründen, warum das so richtig
ist, aber es scheint doch sehr stark durch die faktische Realität relativiert zu werden.
Und das ist ja etwas, was er hier deutlich macht, wenn er auch sagt,
es muss auch um Interessen der Bürger gehen und das darf man nicht ganz ignorieren.
Also die Kontamination des Diskurses mit Bedürfnissen,
mit Interessen, mit eigenen Angelegenheiten, die gerade nicht universalisierbar
sind, scheint mir eine notwendige Bedingung überhaupt einer funktionierenden
Menschenrechtspraxis zu sein.
Ich habe nichts dagegen, ich unterhalte mich gerne gelehrt über Kantexegese
oder über andere Autorinnen, was mit Menschenwürde hat, ich glaube nur eine
politische Ordnung funktioniert so gar nicht.
Ja, das finde ich sehr gut. Also es ist sehr gut, dass wir diese Clips als Clips
gucken und nicht zusammen still in einem Vortrag sitzen, wo das einfach an uns
vorbeirauscht, weil wir jetzt einfach rein plausibilisieren können.
Ein Diskurs über 75 Jahre Grundgesetz hat ganz wenig Sinn, wenn Journalisten
dastehen und die Gelegenheit nutzen, dass diejenigen, die gerade das Grundgesetz
abfeiern, auch noch was zum Sylt-Video sagen.
Und dann sagt der Möchtegern-Kanzler Laschet, sehr gut, die haben alle ihren Job verloren.
Die Bundestagspräsidentin sagt, sehr gut, dass wir da Gesetze haben.
Wir sollten die Höchststrafe anwenden. Fünf Jahre Gefängnis.
Das ist ja original Bärbel Baas.
Hat sie wirklich gesagt.
Laschet und Baas haben genau das gesagt, was ich gerade gesagt habe.
Laschet hat sich darüber gefreut, dass alle ihren Job, alle,
betone alle, Zitat alle, alle ihren Job verloren haben, sehr gut.
Und Bärbel Baas hat gesagt, gut, dass wir Gesetze haben, wir sollten die Höchststrafen
hier auch mal in Betracht ziehen, also fünf Jahre Gefängnis.
Also sie gibt jetzt auch schon Empfehlungen raus an die Richter.
So, genau. Und jetzt haben wir im Kontrast seiner Aussage Armin Laschet,
Bärbel Baas, alle Bundestagsabgeordneten und Steinmeier, der uns nochmal erklärt,
das Grundgesetz ist das Beste, was Deutschland je hervorgebracht hatte.
Das sind alles Leute, die haben diese Grundbedürfnisse nicht.
Mhm.
Die sind einfach befriedigt. Die können reisen, die kriegen immer alle Informationen, die sie brauchen.
Also Information Transportation ist schon mal geregelt. Und wenn sie Hunger
haben, sagen sie einfach zu, dass sie heute Abend nochmal vorbeikommen,
weil es ist ein bewirteter Termin.
Es ist immer ein bewirteter Termin, wenn die abends eingeladen sind.
Und sie haben jeden Abend eine stehende Einladung.
Irgendwo. Irgendein Verband wird sie schon verköstigen.
Irgendwo öffnet sich hier eine Flasche.
Und ja, darüber muss man mal ernsthaft diskutieren, ob wir nicht das Grundgesetz
lieber mit denjenigen, die 10 Millionen Menschen in überbelegten Wohnungen,
ob wir es mit denen mal feiern sollten und dann ernsthaft diskutieren, was hat es uns gebracht?
Müssen wir es weiterentwickeln? Worauf können wir stolz sein?
Was ist scheiße? Ich kann ja alle Fragen mal offen in den Raum stellen. Weil, dass uns die,
durchbefriedigten Eliten unseres Landes, die von ökonomischer Logik keine Ahnung
haben, weil sie sich die ganze Zeit von der Politik da institutionell hofieren
lassen, dass mit denen kein Staat zu machen ist und auch keine Diskussion über den Staat.
Aber ich finde, wenn man auf einer Bühne die Gelegenheit hat,
zu diesem Thema zu reden, sollte man es wirklich plausibilisieren an dieser Gegenwärtigkeit.
Gut, es war hier ein philosophischer Diskurs, aber wir hören ihn jetzt noch.
Das ist ja dann Philosophie.
Gelebte Philosophie.
Wir hören ihn jetzt noch zum Schluss, weil die Leute ein bisschen irritiert
sind jetzt auch im Publikum hier, weil doch universalistisch und das muss doch begründet werden.
Und ich bin mir auch noch nicht sicher, ob ich nicht doch auch am Ende ein orthodoxer
Kantianer da bin und sage, naja, wir müssen das aber alles ganz klar begründen.
Und er sagt jetzt so, naja, das passt sich jetzt.
Kannst dich doch gerne in die Studierstube zurückziehen und nochmal Kant lesen.
Ja.
Das kann doch jeder machen. Ja, ja. Der hat das Recht.
Ja, hab ja auch Kant-Seminare besucht. Wir hören jetzt aber,
warum er so mit Demokratie viel anfangen kann und Menschenrechte.
Also bevor Sie jetzt hier alle umfallen, würde ich tatsächlich sagen,
für mich persönlich ist, glaube ich, also meine Begründungsperspektive für eine
demokratische Ordnung, ist, glaube ich, tatsächlich eigentlich eine katholisch-christliche.
Ich würde sagen, also aus religiösen Gründen glaube ich daran,
dass alle Menschen gleich sind und dass diese Gleichbehandlung sich auch in
politischen Realitäten realisieren muss.
Das ist eine sehr idiosynkratische Form vom politischen Linkskatholizismus,
die ich vertrete, von der um Gottes Willen niemand anders vertreten soll.
Und die auch gar nicht irgendwie sozusagen darauf angewiesen ist,
dass andere sich vertreten.
Aber das ist sozusagen meine und ich glaube, es ist gerade wichtig zu sagen,
dass ich mit einem sehr schrägen persönlichen Weltbild vielleicht in der demokratischen Ordnung lande,
wo andere Leute mit anderen seltsamen Weltbildern da auch landen und wo mich
diese Beobachtung halt gegenüber der Formulierung, naja,
wir brauchen eben eine Begründung und wenn wir eine Begründung haben,
brauchen wir eigentlich auch eine gemeinsame Begründung, trotz allem so ein
bisschen Misstrauen stimmt.
Also, das ist nicht nur schräg, das ist absurd. Er hat zum einen ein universalistisches
Weltbild, das aber nicht alle teilen müssen.
Es ist ein kleiner Privatspaß. Ich denke mir, nee, man sollte dann doch ein
Weltbild finden, gerade ein universalistisches.
Da bist du jetzt doch der Kantianer.
Ja, da auf jeden Fall. Total. Und deswegen auch, und da bin ich auch Kantianer,
man kann sich nicht die Religion als Grundlage raussuchen, weil die ist wirklich nicht anschlussfähig.
Er macht das ja nur für sich, also er will ja keinen Anschluss haben.
Er sagt einfach, ich gehe davon aus, aufgrund meiner Religion,
dass die Menschen gleich sind, das passt gut zu Demokratie und Menschenrechte.
Deswegen, jetzt hast du ja vorhin gefragt, hat Putin Tucker Carlson eine halbe
Stunde lang verarscht, veralbert, vorgeführt.
Jetzt frage ich dich, wenn jemand als Universalismusphilosoph vor Publikum.
Also der Mann ist Staatsrechtler.
Anschluss suchend, ein Staatsrechtler, der aber an dem Abend einen philosophischen
Diskurs auf Anschluss suche mit Publikum, er redet und dann am Ende aber die Pointe macht,
Ich mache es religiös und ich weiß, nicht alle sind Christen,
übrigens einer der größten Problemherde auf dieser Welt, den wir haben.
Und zweitens, und damit sage ich Ihnen nur, wie ich darüber denke,
mein Universalismus-Bild muss aber nicht von anderen geteilt werden.
Frage ich dich, hat er die da alle gerade veralbert?
Nein, die Frage ist ja, ob er überhaupt diese Art von Universalismus gut findet
oder ob er, also er teilt die Werte der Menschenrechte und der Demokratie, würde aber sagen,
eine universalistische Begründung mit Kant ist nicht notwendig,
um Demokrat zu sein und um für die Menschenrechte zu sein.
Ja, es führt vielleicht sogar genau in das Gegenteil, beziehungsweise bringt
es nicht wirklich weiter,
wenn man nicht die Voraussetzungen sieht für Demokratie und Menschenrechte und
das meint zum Beispiel auch so etwas wie Ökonomie und dann kann man sich nochmal selbst fragen,
warum sieht man das eigentlich so? Also warum ist man eigentlich Demokrat?
Und dann kann man das ja für sich irgendwie begründen und das tut er jetzt religiös
und sagt, deswegen gefällt mir das gut.
Und ich glaube, was er da macht, ist wirklich nicht das Publikum einfangen,
sondern es eigentlich maximal provozieren.
Und wenn er sagt, der ist bei der evangelischen Akademie, der sitzt da und sagt,
ja der Linkskatholizismus, der hat mir immer gut gefallen.
Gut, lass mich mal mit einer Pointe schließen, thematisch, wir holen es ganz
gegenwärtig, wir haben auch Fragen bekommen,
ich hatte mir so ein paar E-Mails rausgeschrieben, machen wir dann vor dem Salon
nächste Woche, aber eine Frage war, sollte man echt so viele Biologie-Grundbegriffe verwenden?
Ins politische Denken rüberholen. Wie zum Beispiel, warum nicht Regression?
Warum verfolgt ihr dem Selk und sagt Devolution?
Also das Gegenteil von Evolution. Denn Evolution ist ja ein biologischer Grundbegriff.
Und meine Antwort ist da, naja, weil wir bei der Evolution als biologischen
Vorgang es mit einer durchschaubaren Rationalität zu tun haben.
Die aber keinem Bewusstsein folgt.
Wir können mit ihr nicht diskutieren. Wir können sie nur verstehen,
aber wir können nicht mit ihr diskutieren.
Und das ist sehr einladend, weil wir in der Soziologie oder in der Gesellschaft
selbst sehr viele Vorgänge haben, bei der die einen strukturell realistisch
rangehen, der andere liest nochmal Kant und so,
aber der Lauf der Dinge, der ist davon unberührt. So.
Und in diesem Themenkomplex gucken wir jetzt ganz gegenwärtig nach Indien zu
einer Sachlage, die so viele Menschen betrifft, wie wir es uns nicht vorstellen können.
Das ist nicht nur ganz Europa, sondern das ist ganz Europa mal zwei und noch
mehr. Wir reden jetzt hier über Indien, Pakistan.
Da leben 1,6 Milliarden Menschen. Das übersteigt alles. Das übersteigt sogar
die Einwohnerzahl Afrikas.
Also es ist wirklich gigantisch. und jetzt haben wir es da mit handlungsleitenden
Problemen aller Menschen zu tun die wir nachvollziehen können,
die wir verstehen können, es gibt große Wissenschaft aber wir können mit der
Ursache einfach nicht diskutieren,
das Schicksal stürzt einfach auf diese Menschen herein, auf eine Art und Weise
wie wir es uns, für uns nicht vorstellen können, also ich weiß nicht wir sitzen
jetzt hier langärmlich und es
ist Mai, sobald die Temperatur über 26 Grad sind, wird es mir zu warm Ja.
So, wir können uns nicht vorstellen, was hier in Pakistan gerade abläuft.
In Pakistan gibt es eine Hitzewelle. Peter Hornung.
51 Grad werden für den kommenden Sonntag vorhergesagt in der südpakistanischen
Provinz Sindh mit der 15 Millionen Einwohnerstadt Karachi.
Und auch in anderen Regionen von Pakistan könnte es ähnliche Temperaturen geben.
Die Behörden bereiten sich nach Berichten pakistanischer Medien auf den Katastrophenfall vor.
Sie stellen kühle Räume als Notunterkünfte zur Verfügung.
Es gibt große Wasservorräte und Krankenhäuser bereiten sich auf Hitzeopfer vor.
Alle Schulen sind bis Ende des Monats geschlossen.
Die Regierung erklärte, die Temperaturen seien derzeit 4 bis 6 Grad höher als üblich.
Betroffen seien davon alle flacheren Landesteile.
Befürchtet wird auch, dass die große Hitze die Gletscher im Himalaya schneller
schmelzen lässt und es in der Folge zu Flutwellen und Überschwemmungen kommen könnte.
Pakistan gehört zu den Ländern, die am meisten vom Klimawandel betroffen sind.
Vor zwei Jahren waren weite Teile des Landes überflutet worden.
Zuvor hat es auch eine schwere Hitzewelle gegeben. Es folgten heftige Regenfälle
und eine massive Gletscherschmelze.
So, 51 Grad heißt Feuchtkugeltemperatur im nomadischen Jahrhundert.
Der Schweiß auf der Haut und die Verdunstung reicht nicht mehr,
um die Körpertemperatur auf unter 36 oder 36 Grad zu halten.
Also es ist eine akut tödliche Temperatur. Ja.
So.
51 Grad, das war jetzt ein Clip aus der ersten Hälfte des Mai.
Und ich wollte ja, habe eben gesagt, ich hole das Ganze ins Gegenwärtige.
Jetzt gerade, also in Neu-Delhi, in Delhi, die jemals krass gemessenste Temperatur 52,3 Grad. hat.
Unvarial ist ja.
So, also wir wissen, ich habe jetzt eben gesagt, wie viele Leute da leben.
Ich will es mal runterbrechen.
Der ORF zum Beispiel informiert, in Pakistan wurde gestern in der Stadt Jakobadab,
Jakobadab,
Ne, Babat. So, Jakob Babat. 51 Grad gemessen. Es handelt sich um die bisher
höchste Temperatur, die dieses Jahr auf der Erde gemessen wurde.
In dieser Stadt leben 191.000 Einwohner.
In den 70ern lebten dort weniger als 60.000. Also da können wir schon mal im
nomadischen Jahrhundertstile,
da leben ganz schön viele Menschen, die sind entweder da hingezogen oder die
sind so jung, also die brechen eh gerade ins Leben auf oder die sind da gar
nicht verankert, weil die können auch woanders leben.
So, der Stern. Extreme Hitze in Pakistan.
Es ist, als würde man buchstäblich in der Hölle leben, sagt dort einer.
Man hat das Gefühl, auf brennenden Kohlen zu laufen, wenn man in die Sonne tritt.
In dem Falle Zitate von C. Shankar Shani, ein Rikscha-Fahrer in Dadu.
Ich gehe also zu Wikipedia, gucke, Dadu.
170.000 Einwohner. In den 70ern 30.000.
Also bei der Frage, kann das wirklich stimmen mit dieser These?
Ein Grad mehr bedeutet eine Milliarde mehr Menschen in Bewegung.
Ja, wo kommen die her? Da her.
Warum? Na, weil die nichts mit Dadu zu tun haben.
Da ist nicht irgendwie, der Opa hat schon immer hier und so,
sondern da leben einfach Menschen, die nichts damit zu tun haben.
Dann gibt es hier diese Region, das ist ganz Pakistan, hier unten rot,
sind 55 Millionen Einwohner.
Das ist mehr als halb Deutschland, da unten mal so an der Ecke,
wo man eigentlich, ja und es ist da nicht mal besonders dicht besiedelt oder
so. Also es ist wirklich crazy und in Indien hat man jetzt eine neue Vorkehrung getroffen.
Es gibt einen Wasserminister in der Region Delhi, Atishi Malena,
was dann dazu führt, unter anderem sollen in mehreren Gegenden von Delhi einstweilen
nur noch einmal täglich Wasser geliefert werden.
Also da gibt es gar keine Wasserleitung, sondern da wird Frischwasser hingefahren.
Was jetzt bedeutet, in einigen Regionen Indiens, die jetzt gerade 51,
52, 53 Grad erleben, gibt es für 15 bis 20 Minuten Wasser am Tag.
Das ist die Realität. geht. Da liest keiner Kant. Da will auch keiner wissen,
was irgendwo mal irgendwann und so weiter.
Da will auch keiner was jetzt abstraktes zum Thema Menschenrecht oder so hören.
Also hier regiert einfach die Gegenwart und zwar so wie es sie es vorher nicht gab.
Weshalb man automatisch, ja, ja, wir müssen jetzt hier mal Begriffe entgrenzen und so weiter.
Das führt jetzt gar nicht, also hier muss man jetzt ernsthaft über Sachen nachdenken.
Weshalb ich jetzt sage, wir brauchen jetzt mal neue Grundbegriffe und wir holen
sie uns von Eckart von Hirschhausen.
Der war im Table Media Podcast zu Gast und wir hören mal zwei Ausschnitte,
die ich sehr interessant fand und die wir dann für uns mitnehmen können.
Zum einen die Sollastalgie.
Gerade zum Beispiel dieses Thema Natur hat auch in Deutschland Riesenzustimmung.
Wenn wir jetzt den Frühling haben, wenn wir merken, Mensch, früher waren da mehr Singvögel.
Warum sind die nicht mehr da? Weil die Insekten weg sind. Warum sind die Insekten
weg? Weil wir eine Landwirtschaft machen mit extrem viel Einsatz von Dünger und Pestiziden.
Also wenn man den Leuten erklärt, dass sie einen hohen Preis zahlen für die
körperliche und, das ist mir auch neuerdings ein sehr großes Thema geworden,
die seelische Gesundheit.
Ich war hier auf dem Psychiaterkongress der GPPN, auch dieses Jahr wieder als
Keynote-Speaker, auch mit einer Arbeitsgruppe zu Solastalgie.
Also Solastalgie ist das Wort
dafür, dass der Trost, den die Natur uns eigentlich spendet, schwindet.
Dass ich durch den Wald gehe und ich bin Berliner, ich bin mit meinem Fahrrad
und meinem Vater hier durch den Grunewald.
Und diese Lebendigkeit, die gibt es nicht mehr. Wenn Menschen sagen,
Waldbaden ist gesund und vier von fünf Bäumen sind laut aktuellem Schadensbericht
tot oder kaputt, dann spüren wir das.
Dann wird aus einer Naherholung eine Nahtoderfahrung.
Das ist ja gut. Also die Solastalgie, man fühlt sich nicht mehr zu Hause und
trauert darüber. Jetzt gibt es einige Comedians auf der Bühne.
Ich habe den Namen nicht präsent, aber er hat so einen kleinen Mitschnitt auf
YouTube gestellt, in dem nochmal dargestellt wird, all diese Long-Term-Missen-Ideen.
Wird dann nicht als Longtime müssen, aber Elon Musk will irgendwie die Menschheit
interstellar machen und Jeff Bezos ja auch, nur überall auf der Welt,
überall im Universum wäre es schlechter als auf der Erde.
Also selbst wenn wir jetzt sagen, in Indien ist es richtig scheiße,
52,3 Grad, was bedeutet, es ist ja nur ein paar Wochen im Jahr,
aber innerhalb dieser Zeit sind drei Stunden draußen tödlich.
Also du kannst einfach nicht vor die Tür gehen. So, und das ist trotzdem noch
unter allen Gesichtspunkten die beste vorstellbare Welt.
Ist immer noch hier im Vergleich zu Mars oder Venus. 500 Grad und die ganze
Zeit explodiert da so irgendwelche Gase, die dich sofort verbrennen und du kannst
da nichts bauen und hast überhaupt keine Materialien.
Also auf der Erde ist es immer am besten, selbst unter diesen Gesichtspunkten,
gibt es keine weiteren Auswege.
Und wir werden auch in Deutschland so Erlebnisse haben, dass Menschen einfach
in ihren Wohnungen sitzen und nicht wissen, wo sie hingehen können.
Wenn sie den genügend Platz haben in ihren Wohnungen. Genau.
Wenn man einen Keller hat, könnte man auch in den Keller gehen und sich davon
so 5 Grad Minus versprechen im unmittelbaren Erleben.
Oder, und das ist ja das Bild, auf das ich so warte und das man auch mal kabarettistisch
vorbereiten könnte, Rentner, die tagsüber einfach in ihrem Auto sitzen.
Die nicht irgendwo hinfahren oder so, sondern die einfach nur gucken,
ob der Strom noch reicht, um die Klimaanlage zu betreiben. Weil das der einzige
Ort ist, wo sie hin können, wo eine Klimaanlage ist.
So, und das Bild muss man sich mal vor Augen führen einfach.
So ein Straßenzug von geparkten Autos und in jedem zweiten sitzt einfach so
ein älteres Ehepaar drin, weil es einfach nirgendwo anders hin kann.
Und der Agent, der da dahinter steckt, der politische Akteur,
mit dem ist nicht zu diskutieren.
Wir können ihn, und das machen wir jetzt seit Jahren, einfach,
gibt es eine Statistik kurz vor dem Wetterbericht und so, wo nochmal erklärt
wird, wie krass es jetzt ist, aber man kommt da einfach nicht raus.
Und über die Medizin kann man ja diesen biologischen Grundbegriff Brückenschlag immer schön machen.
Und deswegen hier nochmal Hirschhausen zum Zweiten.
Und wenn die Klimakrise das Fieber von Mutter Erde ist, dann ist das Artensterben ihre Demenz.
Demenz ist das krankhafte Vergessen von dem, was man schon mal gewusst hat.
Jede Art enthält die Weisheit, die Innovation, die von Versuch und Irrtum,
von Mutation und Selektion über Millionen Jahre Wissen, wie geht Leben auf diesem
Planeten, gesammelt hat.
Und mit jeder Art, die weg ist, und zwar irreversibel, für immer weg,
fehlt auch dieses Wissen.
Und wenn man dieses Netz sich vorstellt, jeder, der Kinder hat,
kennt dieses Phänomen, dass man so Klettertürme auf dem Spielplatz hat und man
denkt, oh Gott, Dreijährige klettern hoch, wie tief können die fallen?
Ah, da ist noch eine andere Lage unten drunter.
Und mit jedem Knotenpunkt, mit jeder Art, die weg ist, fehlt sozusagen eins
dieser Sicherungssysteme und irgendwann fallen wir ins Bodenlose.
Ja, also die Fallhöhe wird immer höher. Erderwärmung ist Fieber Artensterben ist Demenz,
Und noch haben wir dieses sich selbst regulierende System Natur,
nur wenn sie zerstört ist, ist sie zerstört und auf dem Weg zur Zerstörung wird
es die Natur nicht weiter stören.
Also wir sind die einzigen, die das beobachten, dass es halt so ist.
Du hast es ja auch immer wieder betont. Und damit ist aber auch echt nicht zu
diskutieren. Also es gibt da keine Philosophie oder so.
Und da werden auch alle hehren idealistischen Konzepte sofort zusammenbrechen bei 52 Grad,
sagt niemand mehr in irgendeiner Weise, ich muss mal gucken,
ob das auch mit einer universalistischen Begründung einhergeht,
es spielt keine Rolle mehr.
Insofern ist da der pragmatische Ansatz angesagt.
Wir sind gespannt, mit welchem Pragmatismus wir uns dann der großen Außenpolitik
nähern mit Richard David Precht. Nochmal, wir lesen das Jahrhundert der Toleranz.
Stefan hat schon einige Bücher angekündigt. Ich habe auch schon gesagt,
ich werde mal alles auf den Kopf stellen mit Philipp Mano.
Ich werde sagen, ja, vielleicht haben wir gar kein Demokratiedefizit,
vielleicht ist das auch eine eigenartige Ideologie mit der liberalen Demokratie.
Müssen wir jetzt also am Ende böse Buben verteidigen aus Ungarn oder der Türkei? Wir werden sehen.
Jedenfalls bin ich gespannt auf unsere Diskussion und man kann dieser Diskussion
dann folgen, wenn man in den Salon kommt.
Das ist also der Zusatzcontent zu diesem Podcast.
Man kann diesen Podcast dann auch überall hören, wenn man ihn abonniert hat.
Man muss nicht vor dem Laptop sitzen, sondern man kann den dann immer so hören
wie alle anderen Folgen, regulären Folgen auch.
Das ist möglich über Steady.
Da geht man über neue20er.de drauf. Man kann auch über Spotify auf den Button
klicken, dann kommt man auch zu dem Steady-Abo.
Sonst kann man es noch über Patreon oder Apple abschließen.
Und dann freue ich mich auf die nächste Woche.
Sehr gut. Bis dahin. Bis dahin. Immer schön kühl bleiben.